Sag, dass du mich liebst, denn wenn du mich nicht liebst, dann werde ich ganz wuschig.
Wie jetzt?
Der Computer.
Achso.
Es ist wichtig, dass der Computer einen liebt, weil wenn der Computer einen
nicht liebt, dann macht er einem Ärger. Und wenn der Computer einem Ärger macht, dann ist man fucked.
Das ist doch fucked, dass man dann fucked ist. Oder?
Ich habe aus dieser Zeit der 90er noch einen Voodoo-Computer,
wo so ein Kissen in Rechnerform, wo so Sachen draufstehen wie Baddisk und Lost
Sector und Systemabsturz.
Und dann kann man halt mit den dazugehörigen Nadeln und kann man dann Probleme
lösen oder anderen Leuten Probleme verschaffen.
Hat das geholfen?
Ich habe es nie ausprobiert. Ich bin ja nicht so ein gemeiner Mensch.
Na ja gut, vielleicht ist es ja auch mehr so ein Akupunkturset und du hättest
deine Probleme sehr viel einfacher irgendwie lösen können.
Akupunktur beim Computer.
Ja, Computerakupunktur. Das ist eigentlich noch ein Bereich,
der ist noch komplett, weiß ich nicht, unerforscht auch auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise.
Da ist bei den Schwurblern noch Luft nach oben.
Ja, ich denke also man kann auch so Globuli, also vielleicht könnte man ja halt
auch mal so, keine Ahnung.
Naja, also Hand auflegen hilft schon. Ich habe ja in meiner wilden Jugend in
Göttingen ja mal im Computerladen gearbeitet, drei Jahre.
Comtech war das damals. Das war in Göttingen eine ganz coole Bude,
habe ich glaube ich auch schon mal erzählt. Das war auch so eine Kette.
Ne?
War auch so eine Kette, aber anders als Wobis und Eskom waren wir natürlich
die Guten, die sich lange hingestellt haben, eine Stunde erstmal erklärt,
wie so ein Computer überhaupt funktioniert.
Das Schöne war halt, dass wir da die ganzen Profs und die ganzen Uni-Institute alle beliefert haben.
Also wir waren quasi so der Seller, die Dealer dafür, die Uni Göttingen.
Und ich war dann der, der sonntags dann immer die Reparaturschichten in der
Werkstatt gemacht hat, weil ich die Hände hatte, die müde Rechner wieder zum Leben gebracht haben.
Das war halt eine Zeit, das kann man sich ja heute alles nicht mehr vorstellen,
wo wirklich halt so das gezielte Ruckeln an PCI-Karten und Memory Slots wirklich
zuweilen noch was geholfen hat.
Das kann man sich heute nicht mehr vorstellen.
Weiß ich nicht, die Jugend da draußen, die hat doch bestimmt noch nie irgendwas,
aufgemacht und da mal reingeguckt.
Jetzt wieder Jugend-Bashing bei Freakshow Nummer 282 vom 15. August 2024.
Ja, die magischen Hände, also ich meine, ich weiß natürlich wovon du redest,
ich würde aber jetzt nicht sagen, dass Ruckeln heute komplett ausgeschlossen ist Ja.
Wackelkontakte, solange du noch irgendwie physische Dinge hast.
Passiert sowas Genau, aber die Frage ist ja immer, liebt der Computer einen
und man muss ja dann auch eine emotionale Bindung eingehen Also man muss ja
auch ein bisschen, wie in jeder guten Liebe, man muss ja auch investieren,
Also wenn man möchte, dass der Computer einen liebt, dann muss man eben halt auch Gutes tun.
Was ich übrigens früher bevorzugt gemacht habe, bevor ich die Hände aufgelegt
habe, war das Ohr auflegen.
Das hast du glaube ich schon mal erzählt, dass man also am Klang der Festplatte
relativ gut hören kann, was ist denn da eigentlich gerade los.
Und das hat mich auch irgendwie immer so ein bisschen verbunden mit der Maschine.
Also man hat so einfach dieses, das Innenleben gespürt und es war einfach quasi Ohr aufs Herz.
Ich habe mal gegoogelt, ich habe diesen Macintosh Computer Voodoo Puppe Plüschtier
mit Pins zugehört bei Ebay gefunden.
Auch noch ein Macintosh?
Ja, der Link ist schon im Chat.
Der Linke ist schon im Chat. Schöne Grüße auch an alle im Chat.
Ihr wisst ja, wir haben immer Chat nebenbei. Also unser Meta-Ebene-Slack-Kanal
Lattensound Freakshow.
Und da könnt ihr auch hier in den Podcast reinfühlen. Wir fühlen dann auch zurück.
Sag, dass du uns liebst, Chat.
Genau. Fächelt uns was in die Aura.
Macintosh-Computer-Voodoo-Doll?
Ja, so sieht das Ding aus. Nicht so Macintoshig, wie wenn ich das mal so sagen darf.
Überhaupt nicht, um ehrlich zu sein. Also das geht besser.
Aber zumindest der Zeichensatz, den sie benutzt haben, um diese ganzen Sachen aufzunehmen.
Ja, aber so sieht doch kein Macintosh aus. Kein Macintosh hat die Tastatur so
nach vorne. Das sieht ja eher aus wie so ein Pad.
Ich weiß. Ich habe ja auch nur gesagt, wie die Auktion heißt und nicht,
dass das Ding tatsächlich ein Macintosh wäre.
Aber vielleicht gibt es ja auch eine Computer-Voodoo-Doll. Ich meine,
am Ende ist es wie mit den Globuli und so.
Also es muss halt, wenn es dir hilft...
Dann ist ja auch gut.
Ich fand es zumindest ein nettes Geschenk, als ich es damals geschenkt bekommen habe.
Ja, das stimmt.
Und du hast es häufig und intensiv genutzt.
Nein, gar nicht eigentlich.
Ich sehe nur dieses eine Modell, das scheint sich nicht so richtig durchgesetzt zu haben.
Wie gesagt, das Ganze als Computerproblem-Akupunktur zu verkaufen,
ist wahrscheinlich hilfreicher.
Dann müssen die Leute so Nadeln reinstecken in ihren Computer,
an alle Löcher, die es so gibt, solange bis es wieder läuft.
Ich fürchte, das hilft nur bei dem Reset-Knopf.
Naja, das kann nicht immer helfen. Das ist kontraproduktiv, oder?
Es hilft halt manchmal.
So ist das. Na gut, also herzlich willkommen bei der Freakshow.
Ich bin's Tim, Roddy ist am Board.
Genau.
Wie ihr schon gehört habt und wie ihr auch schon gehört habt, ist auch Ralf an Bord.
Wunderschönen guten Abend.
Unsere kleine...
Hallöchen.
Super Sendung von alten, weißen Männern. Für euch.
Weisen, weisen, bitte.
Alten, weisen Männer.
Die einen sagen so, die anderen so.
Die einen sagen so, genau. Die meisten sagen so.
Tja, was haben wir denn? Wir sind ja gerade im Urlaubsmodus eigentlich,
aber trotzdem hat sich dieser Termin so ergeben.
Wie ist denn das so mit eurem Urlaub?
Ich wollte ja eigentlich schon weggefahren sein, aber ich hatte letztes Mal
ja schon erwähnt, dass da irgendwie der Einbau einer Wärmepumpe bei mir ansteht.
Wie das nun mal so ist mit Handwerkern und Firmen und so hat sich das natürlich
alles nach hinten verschoben. Leider auf unbestimmte Zeit. Ich weiß noch nichts Näheres.
Am Dienstagmorgen, also vorgestern,
kam da irgendwie der Meister oder was auch immer dessen Job da ist vorbei und
hat nochmal geguckt, wie es denn so ist und rannte mit Sorgen zerfalteten Gesicht
und Zollstock da durch die Gegend.
und meinte, oh, da kommen wir ja gar nicht durch. Und oh, das ist ja total eng.
Und oh, was ist denn das für eine Deckenhöhe? Und oh, die passt ja hier nicht
hin. Da muss ja so und so viel Platz.
Und zum Schluss meinte er, na ja, aber ich habe eigentlich noch überall eine
Wärmepumpe eingebaut bekommen. Das kriegen wir schon hin.
Okay, wie klang das? Wie zuversichtlich bist du, dass das...
Das Einzige, was mir ein bisschen Sorgen bereitet, ist, dass er meinte,
na ja, mit dem Bagger können wir hier aber nicht reinfahren.
Man, da ist zu wenig Platz. Das müssen wir dann schon per Hand schaufeln.
Und jetzt habe ich so ein bisschen Bedenken, dass das teurer wird,
wenn die da tatsächlich in Handarbeit irgendwie 80 Zentimeter tiefe Gräben ziehen,
um dort die Rohre reinzuverlegen.
Und wieso kommen sie da nicht rein mit dem Bagger?
Oh, zu eng. Ah, der kann sich ja gar nicht drehen hier. Hier ist ja überhaupt kein Platz und so.
Was ist denn der Bagger? Du hast doch da auch eine Autozufahrt, oder nicht?
Ja, naja, es geht mehr um den Ort, wo dann das Außengerät hin soll.
Äh, egal. Ich nehme mal an, dass die da ankommen werden, dann diskutieren sie
groß rum und dann holen sie doch den Bagger.
Aber wir werden sehen. Ich werde berichten.
Okay, gut. Also kein Urlaub bei dir?
Genau, das Einzige, was ich gemacht habe, ist an der Stelle,
wo das Außengerät hin soll oder wo ich es hinhaben will, sagen wir mal so,
stand halt jetzt bis letzte Woche noch ein Baum, bis Anfang letzter Woche.
Ich habe dann mit einem beherzten Besuch beim Baumarkt dort eine Motorsäge gekauft
und die entsprechende Schutzausrüstung und diesen Baum klein gemacht.
Das ging relativ schnell. So einen Baum fällen hat man irgendwie eine halbe,
dreiviertel Stunde durch.
Aber dann grab mal so einen Baumstumpf aus.
Das ist richtig harte Arbeit.
Das hat mich fünf Tage gekostet. Allerdings immer nur die Abende. Aber trotzdem.
Fünf Tage hast du gebraucht für einen Baumstumpf?
Ja.
Okay, aber der war ja auch frisch. Also der war noch gut vernetzt sozusagen.
Der war richtig gut vernetzt, ja. Gott sei Dank ein Flachwurzler.
Sonst hätte ich ihn wahrscheinlich gar nicht rausgekriegt.
Aber was war denn das eigentliche Problem, dass er so viele Äste hatte?
Er hatte relativ viele Wurzeln, ja. Und der Boden war auch so,
dass ich im Prinzip mit dem Schippchen da mehr oder weniger so Sandkasten-mäßig
wie ein Archäologe geschaufelt habe. Frei geblasen.
Und nicht mit der großen Schaufel irgendwie rangehen konnte.
Und dann war das halt so abends immer so zwei, drei Stunden.
Und dann hat das seit fünf Tagen...
Mit Wasser?
Ja, habe ich mir auch sagen lassen, aber ich glaube, also da der Boden so eine
gewisse Lähmigkeit hat, wäre das Wasser möglicherweise nicht abgelaufen und
dann hätte ich halt eine trübe Brühe mit einem Baumstumpf drin gehabt.
Du hast einen lähmigen Boden in Brandenburg.
Nee, ist ja nicht Brandenburg, ist ja Berlin.
Ist noch diesseits da. Okay, gut.
Also ich hatte damals sehr viel Erfolg mit der Applikation eines Wagenhebers.
Ich habe die Bäume dann am Ende, die Stümpfe dann mit dem Wagenheber aus dem Boden rausgepresst.
Okay, naja, gut. Habe ich jetzt auch nicht einen Wagenheber?
Was, du hast keinen Wagenheber?
Nein.
Echt nicht? Ist in deinem Auto
nicht hinten einfach irgendwo einer rein verbaut, ohne dass du es weißt?
Also ich würde nicht Auto fahren ohne Wagenheber, ganz ehrlich.
Naja, sagen wir mal so, ich habe ja neulich das Problem mit den Reifen gehabt
und dabei festgestellt, dass das Auto 1,8 Tonnen wiegt. Also müsste ich auch
einen entsprechend fetten Wagenheber haben.
Hast du mal in deiner Anleitung danach geguckt?
Weil also bei mir ist es so, der ist an einer Stelle verbaut,
wo du ihn nicht findest, wenn du nicht vorher dann auch darauf hingewiesen wirst,
dass es hinter dieser Klappe und dann noch den Nippel rechts durch die Lasche
gezogen und plötzlich hältst du einen Wagenheber in der Hand.
Nee, in der Anleitung habe ich tatsächlich noch nicht geguckt.
Mach mal. Und dann halt uns auf dem Laufenden.
Aber nein, also ja, keine Ahnung. Also ich habe ihn ausgebuddelt,
habe dann die Wurzeln alle einzeln abgesägt und...
Genau. Und das war es, glaube ich, eigentlich alles schon, was ich zu dem Thema
erzählen wollte, weil es ist ja, wie gesagt, nichts passiert.
Und ich war deswegen auch nicht weg.
Okay, gut. Live von Es ist nichts passiert. Schalten wir um zu Ralf war im Urlaub.
Ich war im Urlaub. Zwei Wochen, natürlich viel zu kurz. Aber in Dänemark,
da war ich auch schon echt lange nicht mehr.
Warum fährt man als pflichtschuldiger Familienvater nach Dänemark?
Crickets and Tumbleweeds. Das ist bei euch schon ein bisschen länger her, ne?
Ich war da auch. Spoiler, ich war da auch. Aber deswegen bin ich nicht nach der... Ja, doch.
Was wurde in Dänemark erfunden? Tim, du weißt es.
Lego.
Der Klemmbaustein.
Der Klemmbaustein, wie man jetzt sagen muss.
Muss man das sagen? Ich weiß nicht, ich muss das nicht sagen.
Sagen wir mal so, Lego ist relativ drastisch da drin, Creator abzumahnen,
die Klemmbausteine benutzen, die nicht von Lego sind und sie trotzdem als Lego bezeichnen.
Und deswegen muss man dann seine ganze Gewohnheit seines Lebens beiseite legen,
damit man so the good guy ist und richtige Pronomen benutzt sozusagen für diese Klemmbausteine.
Was ist denn das für ein scheiß Name?
Klemmbausteine. Also das ist doch nicht Lego gegen Klemmbaustein.
Kein Wunder, dass die Amerikaner sich lustig machen über die deutsche Sprache.
Also Modbricks und Ähnliches würden es sich liebend gerne Legosteine nennen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, weil das Wort so doof ist, habe ich es jetzt gebraucht.
Ich finde, das macht doch erst irgendwie...
Nein, ich vertrete ja in der Tat die Theorie, dass Lego das Apple der Spielewelt ist.
Es gibt erstaunlich viele Parallelen, wenn man das mal durchspielt,
von irgendwie doch erstaunliche Qualität und Innovationskraft,
super Marketing, sehr gutes Design, fantastische Usability, perfekte Interoperabilität,
wenn man denn im Ökosystem bleibt, also alles passt halt mit allem zusammen.
Und keine fremden Klemmbausteine.
So, und auf der anderen Seite eben.
Fremd-Klemmbausteine.
Keine Fremd-Klemmbausteine, genau.
Und auf der anderen Seite aber halt extrem Spaß befreit, was jegliche Art von Konkurrenz angeht.
Umgang mit den eigenen Händlern, Umgang mit Supportstrukturen,
völlig überzogene Preisvorstellungen, absurde Gewinnmargen.
Also man kommt da relativ weit, wenn man das mal vergleicht.
Nichtsdestotrotz, ich war halt
schon immer in meinem Leben Lego-Fanboy und jetzt hat man endlich mal,
man macht das ja alles nur für die Kinder, aber wir sind jetzt eben nach Dänemark
gefahren, um dann dort mal nach Billund zu pilgern, wo eben das große Legoland
ist und das Lego-Haus steht.
So, das sind also die beiden Attraktionen in diesem ansonsten wirklich sehr
kleinen, sehr überschaubaren Städtchen, aber das ist halt so die Lego-Stadt, wo man dann so hinfährt.
Wie gesagt, da war ich auch schon.
Mir war das jetzt zwar nicht neu, dass Lego aus Dänemark kommt,
aber ich denke tatsächlich bei Lego nicht als erstes an Dänemark.
Okay.
Lego ja nicht mit dänischen Kulturreferenzen spielt, wie das zum Beispiel Ikea ja macht.
Das fängt ja schon bei den Logofarben an.
Und ich denke, bei Ikea hat jeder sofort Schweden am Start.
Und Schöttbullar.
Und all ihre lustigen Produkten haben, die immer so komisch schwedisch klingen,
aber nicht sind und all das.
Ja, das ist allerdings von Lego eine bewusste Strategieentscheidung gewesen.
Man kann dort nämlich auch ins Lego-Museum gehen, wo man dann also die komplette
Firmengeschichte nochmal eingetrichtert bekommt, unten im Keller.
Ist in der Tat schön gemacht.
Und dort gab es dann den Moment, ich weiß es nicht mehr, wann das war,
also nagelt mich da jetzt nicht auf ein Jahrzehnt fest, ich glaube Ende 60er
oder sowas, wo also der damalige auch noch erste Lego-Gründer,
also seine Untergebenen angeschrien hat,
versteht ihr denn nicht, worum es ihr geht?
Wenn wir das richtig anfassen, dann wird die ganze Welt das kaufen und nicht
nur Dänemark, weil da gab es also eben Strömungen innerhalb der Firma, die gesagt haben,
wir müssen mehr hier auf Nationalfolklore gehen und müssen jetzt hier irgendwie
dänische Kultur abbilden und das wollte also der erste Lego-Chef dezidiert nicht.
Der wollte es eben gleich weltweit vertriebsbereit haben, das Ganze.
Naja, und das ist ihm dann ja auch ganz gut gelungen. Und da sind wir dann also
zwei Tage dann wirklich da gewesen.
Den ersten Tag dann im Legoland, was am Ende des Tages, muss man sagen,
muss halt ein mehr oder weniger gewöhnlicher Vergnügungspark ist,
so wie man die halt kennt.
Da gibt es in der Mitte so, was auch der Anfang war, dann halt so diese nachgebauten
Stadtteile und sowas. Aber wenn man irgendwie jetzt wie unser eins hier das
Miniatur Wunderland in Hamburg gewohnt ist, dann ist das schon ein bisschen
lame, muss man mal ganz ehrlich sagen.
Das ist traurig, das ist nicht nur lame, das ist traurig, das ist richtig traurig.
Also es ist schon, natürlich ist es irgendwie so der spirituelle Kern dieses Parks, aber…,
Also da ist man da auch echt in fünf Minuten oder maximal zehn Minuten mit fertig.
Da gibt es also nichts, was jemanden, der ansonsten jetzt irgendwie so Lego
Masters Finale guckt, irgendwie einen in die Hände klatschen lässt.
Ich weiß noch, dass ich als Kind so mit zehn Jahren oder so oder vielleicht
sogar noch jünger dort mal war mit meiner Mutter.
Und da gab es nur diesen Kern, nur dieses wir gucken uns diese aus Lego nachgebauten
Dinge an. Und das fand ich damals fand ich das ziemlich cool.
Ja, da hat man einfach keine Vergleichsgeschichte und da waren plötzlich aus
Steinen, die man selber auch zu Hause hatte, waren so riesige Sachen gebaut.
Ja, ja.
Klar, wenn man das noch nie irgendwo gesehen hat, ist das natürlich interessant,
aber heutzutage hat man das gefühlt ja irgendwie in jeder Stadt auf die eine
oder andere Art und Weise.
Auf jeden Fall erinnere ich mich auch, dass ich schon mal in Legoland in Deutschland war.
Also hier in Berlin haben wir ja auch eins. Was? Potsdamer Platz.
Ach so, dieser komische Tunnel da.
Genau. Oder draußen die Giraffe steht.
Nee, ich rede jetzt von so einem richtigen Freizeitpark-Legoland-Dingsbums.
Genau, also die sind mittlerweile auch nicht mehr unter der Ägide von Lego.
Das erfährt man auch in diesem Museum, weil die also irgendwann vor,
das ist noch gar nicht so lange her, zehn Jahren oder sowas,
sich gefragt haben, okay, Krise, digital, Computerspiele, wie können wir überhaupt noch überleben?
Und dann haben sie gesagt, okay, wir konzentrieren uns auf das Kerngeschäft
und also eben Klemmbausteine und Modelle und deutsche Adventures und lassen
die ganzen anderen Sachen drumherum bleiben.
Und seitdem sind die Parks unter der Ägide von irgendeinem Franchise.
Aber diese ganzen Lego-Computerspiele laufen doch eigentlich auch ganz super.
Die laufen, glaube ich, noch ganz gut. Ja, genau. Das war so Teil der Expansion.
Also als ich da war, das war glaube ich vor fünf Jahren oder so,
also deutlich vor Pandemie noch, da fand ich das erstens super teuer und zweitens
mal einfach auch super schlecht.
Also teuer, ja. Aber in Dänemark halt alles ein bisschen teurer.
Ja schon, aber ich meine ich und die beiden Jungs, wir haben halt 150 Euro Eintritt bezahlt.
Wobei die Karten für die Kids teurer sind als für die Erwachsenen.
Was?
Das war bei uns nicht so. Gut, dafür kommst du aber auch umsonst auf alles drauf.
Wenn du dich lange genug an die Schlange anstellst.
Die Schlangenlänge kannst du digital in der App dir anschauen.
Aber du kannst halt dann auch noch so ein Zusatzding sie kaufen,
wo du halt an die kurze Schlange dich anstellen kannst.
Ja, das fand ich allerdings auch frech. Aber das hat zum Glück niemand gemacht.
Man kann sich quasi eine kürzere Schlange mit noch mehr Geld erkaufen.
Ich war da so mega gestresst.
Ne, also wir waren ganz entspannt, weil meine Frau natürlich mal wieder die
beste Strategie von allen hatten.
Wir waren relativ früh da, aber jetzt auch nicht ganz so zur Toreröffnung und
dann sind wir ans Ende des Parks gelaufen und haben von dort quasi die Attraktion
rückwärts gemacht, was dazu führte, dass wir auf relativ vielen der Fahrgeschäfte die ersten waren.
Ah ok, ihr wart relativ früh da.
Ja, so eine Stunde nach Eröffnung oder sowas und das hat dann aber gereicht,
weil sich also das Gros noch nicht so weit durch den Park von vorne durchgearbeitet hat.
Ich hatte übrigens dort im Legoland tatsächlich einen Hörer getroffen.
Ich war da nur so super gestresst, dass ich mich da nicht so richtig drauf einlassen
konnte. Tut mir so ein bisschen leid, nachträglich.
Aber Grüße hier jetzt, falls du das hörst.
Ja, also gestresst waren wir dann nicht. Das hat gut funktioniert.
Also meine Jungs sind jetzt fünf und sieben. Die hatten da echt viel Spaß.
Also Legoland, das kann man machen. Aber dafür würde ich sagen,
muss man da nicht hinfahren. Im Gegensatz zu eben der zweiten Attraktion,
die wir dann am zweiten Tag gemacht haben, nämlich das Lego-Haus.
Und das ist weniger bekannt als das Legoland.
Das ist der eigentliche Tempel, wo man also hin will, wenn einem irgendwie Lego
im Herzen was bedeutet. Weil sie da eine komplett andere Philosophie fahren.
Also das ist halt wirklich nur ihre eigene Bude.
Die Architektur ist fantastisch. Ich habe es mal mitgebracht für euch.
Und zwar natürlich als Lego-Set. Kann man das dort kaufen.
Das ist jetzt noch nicht ganz zu Ende gebaut hier. Aber ich höre schon mal, dass...
Dir sind Klemmbausteine runtergefallen.
Dir sind ein paar Klemmbausteine runtergefallen, genau.
Das sieht so ein bisschen aus, als hätte irgendjemand so ein paar Rittersporttafeln
wild in die Gegend geworfen.
So, das heißt also, ihr könnt jetzt auch zu Hause mal irgendwelche Luftaufnahmen
von, ich sammle hier gerade vom Boden, Klemmbausteine auf.
Legosteine heißt das.
Es sind ja sogar Legosteine.
Es sind ja Legosteine.
Wenn es schon welche sind, sollte man sie auch benennen.
Könnt ihr jetzt also mal Lego-Haus Billund googeln und dann seht ihr entsprechende
Aerial-Shots, wie das Ganze in echt aussieht. Es soll halt daran erinnern,
als sei es aus Legosteinen gebaut, einigermaßen naheliegend.
Allerdings sind die alle eher quadratisch, also jetzt nicht unbedingt diese
2x4er-Klassik-Bausteine außer am Dach. Da hat man dann genau so einen großen noch verbaut.
Aber es ist trotzdem eine total coole Architektur, vor allen Dingen,
weil diese ganzen Terrassen, aus denen das besteht, die ganzen farbigen Terrassen
außen, sind alles einzelne Spielplätze.
Das heißt also, man hat quasi draußen, auch das ganze Haus ist von außen vollständig
bespielbar, was ich für so einen Ort, bei dem es um Spielzeug geht,
im Kern schon mal eine...
Das Haus ist 12.000 Quadratmeter groß und beinhaltet 25 Millionen Legosteine.
Richtig. Wir hatten so ziemlich alle davon in der Hand.
Also man kann da reingehen und überall liegen Legosteine rum?
Naja, es ist schon ein bisschen anders. Also als erstes kriegst du mal einen
Chip um das Armgelenk, wie überall in Dänemark.
Also der Alltags-Digitalisierungsgrad in Dänemark ist ja absurd im Vergleich zu Deutschland.
Der Alltags-Digitalisierungsgrad in jedem Land ist absurd im Vergleich zu Deutschland.
Ich habe das auch schon auf Mastodon geschrieben. Ich war jetzt zwei Wochen
in Dänemark im Urlaub. Bekanntermaßen gibt es dort dänische Kronen und keinen Euro.
Ich habe in den zwei Wochen kein einziges Mal Bargeld in der Hand gehabt.
Ich habe kein einziges Mal meine Kreditkarte in der Hand gehabt.
Ich habe noch nicht mal mein Permanent in der Hand gehabt. Ich habe alles komplett
nur mit meiner Watch bezahlt.
Ich war in England, ich war in den Vereinigten Arabischen Piraten,
ich war in der Türkei, ich war in der Ukraine.
Ich habe nicht ein einziges Mal Bargeld gewechselt.
Und dann kommst du zurück und gleich, wenn du aus dem Flieger rauskommst,
um dir so eine scheiß Buskarte zu kaufen oder so, dann nehmen sie einfach kein
kontaktloses Payment an.
Ja, es ist...
So eine Karte reinstecken hatte ich gerade nicht zur Hand, also es war einfach...
Es ist schon wirklich betrüblich. Auf jeden Fall, die Grundphilosophie dieses
Lego-Hauses ist eben, dass sie auch dort keinerlei Franchises ausstellen,
also nicht Lego Star Wars und Lego Harry Potter und Lego Ninjago oder was es
da so alles mittlerweile an Unterthemen gibt, sondern da gibt es wirklich nur normale Steine.
Lego, nicht Logo.
Wirklich runtergebrochen auf das...
Auch keine Männchen?
Männchen gibt es. Du hast dann halt innen drin, ich würde sagen,
so 20 verschiedene Bereiche,
die dann halt jeweils einen spezifischen Aspekt rausholen und bespielbar und
experimentierbar machen.
Und es fängt im Eingangsbereich schon an. Das fand ich schon sehr, sehr cool.
Du kommst da also rein, hast dein Band Und das Erste, woran du dann vorbeiläufst,
ist eine große, eindrucksvoll aussehende Maschine.
Ich packe mal einen, oder Maschinenkomplex eigentlich eher, ich packe es mal in den Chat rein.
Du kannst mal den Slack aufmachen und da sieht man jetzt das Haus von oben nochmal schön.
So, diese Maschine hier, mach die mal ruhig groß.
Das ist eine Original-Lego-Produktionsstraße.
Engel Victory 40 heißt der Apparat.
Engel Victory 40, mit Sicherheit speziell für Lego in der Tat gebaut.
Machen wir mal. Victory klingt ja schon mal ganz gut.
Achso, das Teil, das stellt jetzt da live Lego-Steine.
Für dich her.
Aber das ist ja im Prinzip nur ein Spritzgurtsautomat.
Ja, danach werden sie dann aber auch noch schön verpackt. Die Verpackung wird
vor deinen Augen gedruckt.
Mittlerweile ja aus Papier und nicht mehr aus Plastik. Das stellen sie gerade ja komplett um.
Spritzgießmaschine Victory, der universelle und holmlose... Ich habe gerade harmlos gelesen.
Ein holmloser Alaskan.
Holmlos, genau. Ist die optimale Basismaschine für ein breites Feld an technischen
Spritzgießanwendungen und Verfahren.
Die bewährte Holmlostechnologie, das Wort geht einem nicht vor der Zunge,
sorgt für eine besonders homogene Schließkraftverteilung.
Sie investieren bei großen Werkzeugen mit geringem Schließkraftbedarf nur in
die tatsächlich benötigte Schließkraft.
Also das ist ja aber schon immer meine Sorge.
Also wenn ich groß bin, will ich auch ein heulbloser Alleskönner werden.
Nie wieder Gedanken über meine Schließkraft machen müssen.
Darum geht's. Okay, also das ist hier eine Produktionsstraße und Und im Zentrum
ist sozusagen diese Spritzgussmaschine.
Genau, und dahinter wird dann also die Papiertüte bedruckt, live und verschweißt.
Und ich habe jetzt also hier mal meine sechs rote Standardsteine, kriegt man also mit.
Die sind jetzt also live für mich aus dieser Maschine produziert worden.
Waren die noch warm?
Die waren quasi noch warm. Aber bloß nicht aufmachen, das ist bestimmt viel
wert irgendwann in tausend Jahren. an.
Besonders, weil ja sonst niemand da hingeht.
Das ist ja so mein Lieblingsstein, muss ich sagen. Also der 4x2.
Der 2x4er, also der 8er, der klassische.
Der 8er Block, das ist einfach früher, also früher als Kind hatte ich eigentlich
im Wesentlichen nur das und die Hälfte davon.
Und schon so dieser Einer, das war schon der totale Luxus und Dachziegel und so weiter.
Ja, meine Mutter hatte als ich Kind war irgendwo second hand mehrere Kilo Legosteine gekauft.
Und das weiß ich noch, weil sie der Meinung war, die müssten doch irgendwie
sauber zu kriegen sein, hat sie die gesamten Legosteine in einen Kopfkissen
Bezug getan und in die Waschmaschine getan.
Die war nie so laut, die Waschmaschine, wie in diesem Waschgang. Es war unglaublich.
Aber wird sauber.
Oh, ist sauber geworden, ja.
Und was dieses Lego-Haushalt auszeichnet, ist, dass sie da halt nicht stehen
bleiben, sondern das Ganze dann halt nochmal quasi mit irgendeinem Spin immer sowas versehen.
Das heißt also, du hast jetzt deine Tüte mit deinen sechs Steinen.
Jetzt ist ja die Frage, ja, was macht man denn jetzt aus diesen sechs Steinen?
So, und dazu bekommst du dann...
Hier, Ralf, deine Chance. Spritzgrößmaschine Engel Victory 40. 2500 Euro.
Versand möglich.
Meine Kinder werden begeistert sein.
Das ist doch genau das Richtige für die Gartenlaube.
Für den Spritzguss zwischendurch. 3D-Drucker kann jeder. Ich habe eine holmlose
Spritzguss-Druckmaschine.
Sehr schön. So, was ich jetzt also in der Hand halte, ist eine Checkkarte,
die auch von diesem Automaten mir gedruckt worden ist.
Und diese Checkkarte ist also personalisiert. Sprich, da steht mein Name drauf.
In dem Fall jetzt hier der von meinem Sohn, ich habe mich eben vergriffen,
jeder hat also eine bekommen.
Und dort ist jetzt meine ganz persönliche Glückskombination dieser sechs Legosteine drauf.
Ganz persönliche Glücksmelodie?
Es gibt nämlich über zwei Milliarden Möglichkeiten, wie man eben diese sechs
Steine kombinieren kann. Oh.
Und jeder Besucher, Besucherin, Kind und Kegel bekommt also seinen Hash und
hat dann also auf ewig seine ganz individuelle Glückskombination mit diesen sechs Scheinen.
So und das atmet schon ganz gut den Geist, wie das da abgeht und wie das Ganze so aufgezogen ist.
Das finde ich schon, habe ich so.
Du hast aber schon ein bisschen Pech gehabt, ne? Weil so als Grabstein oder
so ist das schon so ein bisschen irgendwie naja.
Also vorm Tod nochmal dahin, um seine eigenen Grabstein-Hash abzuholen.
Ja. Und so sind dann halt so von Grundprinzipien halt viele dieser Stationen,
dass es also immer noch so ein Spin gibt, so ich habe irgendwas gebaut und dann
passieren dann da aber Dinge mit.
Also beispielsweise kann ich hier nochmal ein Bild posten, wo man also so eine
kleine Form sich baut. Warte mal, ich glaube bei dem...
Was, Claudia, oder hier sieht man es mal,
man hat also graue Grundplatten, ich glaube so 20 mal 20 Steine oder sowas ungefähr ist die,
oder Noppen ist die groß und auf der darf man dann bis zu einer Bauhöhe von
zwei Steinen eine beliebige Form bauen mit den ganzen Teilen, die da rumliegen.
Da stünden dann auch noch Gesichtsformen, also so Augen und Münder und Nasen und sowas.
Und diese Platte, die man dann gebaut hat, wie gesagt ungefähr 20x20,
die steckt man dann in einen fröhlich leuchtenden Apparat rein.
Nein, das passt dann ganz genau,
dass es also dann da reingeht und dann sieht man, wie dann also das blitzschnell
gescannt wird, was man gebaut hat und dann fließt das digital richtig auf so
einer quasi digitalen Wasserstraße nach oben bis zu einem Display,
wo dann die Figur, die man selber
gebaut hat, dann plötzlich animiert wird und zum Leben erweckt wird.
Und dann tanzt sie dann also plötzlich fröhlich zur Musik und gerade eben hatte
man sie quasi noch in den Händen.
Also auch so ein Übergang zwischen analogem Spielen und was kann man dann digital daraus machen.
In einer anderen Station konnte man Fische bauen aus Lego, die man dann in so
einen riesigen Screen hochladen konnte. analoges Spielen.
Das muss wirklich ein Ende haben. Gerade Lego ist nun wirklich überhaupt nicht die Bohne analog.
Das ist 3D-Spielen. Haptisches Spielen.
Sehr viel digitaler als Lego kann es ja kaum noch werden.
Inwiefern?
Diskrete Einheiten. Was digital heißt.
Immer dieses Gleichsetzen mit digital ist, wenn es mit Computern zu tun hat
und analog ist, wenn kein Computer dabei ist. Das ist einfach Unsinn.
Digital ist, wenn du mit Einheiten arbeitest, die klar abgetrennt sind.
Und da ist ja einfach mal Lego mal das Beispiel überhaupt.
Also klarer abgetrennt als bei Lego ist es ja nun wirklich nicht.
Jetzt rollst du mit den Augen, als würdest du mich nicht verstehen.
Ich ahne, worauf du hinaus willst, aber diese Art von Interpretation von digital
ist mir in der Tat komplett neu.
Das ist das, was digital heißt.
Digitus, der Finger.
Mit dem Finger abzählbar. Das ist das, was digital heißt.
Wenn etwas digital ist, das meiste auf diesem Planeten ist digital.
Das nahezu alles in unserer Welt ist digital.
Diese ganze Wahrnehmung, irgendwas sei nicht digital und erst wenn ein Computer
auf dem Tisch steht, ist irgendwas digital, ist totaler Quatsch.
Leben ist digital.
Das meiste ist digital, würde ich jetzt auch nicht sagen.
Ich bitte dich. Das gesamte, alles was lebt, ist digital.
Aber du hast natürlich im Prinzip abzählbar viele Atome in einem Menschen.
Nein, auch das ganze Leben ist digital gespeichert.
Also Wikipedia tends to disagree.
Was? Ich habe gerade mal Begriffsklärung digital in Wikipedia eingegeben.
Du musst nicht überhaupt in die Wikipedia gucken.
Du hast erstmal recht, Digitus, Finger, nicht analoges, diskretes oder abgestuftes
Signal, siehe Digital-Signal.
Dann ist es aber nicht mehr digital, sondern es ist schon ein Digital-Signal.
Das ist dann schon wieder weit weg vom Digital-Signal. Vom Legostein. Was? Moment mal.
Nein, nein, nein. Also das ist schon eine Fehlinterpretation,
dass es sich bei digital um ein Signal handelt.
Zählen ist digital. Das ist ja auch kein Signal. Damit speicherst du ja eine Information.
Du abstrahierst. Wenn du den Wald von den Bäumen trennen kannst,
dann hast du eine digitale Interpretation vorgenommen, weil du eben weißt,
wo ein Baum anfängt und wo ein Baum aufhört. Danach hast du einen Wald.
Und auch das ist ja eine Aussage für sich, wobei weit natürlich schwierig zu
greifen ist, aber mit Lego-Arbeiten ist hochdigitales Arbeiten,
weil du ja quasi mit extrem klar abgetrennten Dingen arbeitest. ist.
Ich will mich jetzt nicht so sehr auf,
Begriffswirrwarr versteifen, aber es muss einfach langsam mal klar werden.
Ich meine, ich finde das so absurd.
Du kannst, geh mal raus und frag mal Programmierer und Leute,
die seit 30 Jahren mit Computern arbeiten, ob sie einem erklären können,
was digital ist. Und das kann keiner.
Das ist wirklich vollkommen absurd.
Naja gut, aber das sind dann auch die Leute, die dann ständig von irgendjemandem
erzählen bekommen, dass irgendwas cyber wäre Und diese ganzen Bullshit.
Ja, ich weiß, das ist wahrscheinlich ein Begriff, der sich auch nicht mehr einfangen lässt.
Aber das würde mich ja wohl nicht davon abhalten, darüber zu ranten bis an mein Lebensende.
Ja, aber es stimmt schon, es gibt viele Dinge, die sind einfach abzählbar.
Und sobald sie abzählbar diskret sind, sind sie im Prinzip digital.
Also da hat jemand das Beispiel Bargeld gebracht.
Das ist im Prinzip ausgesprochen. auch eine digitale Einheit.
Also kleiner als einen Cent gibt es bei Bargeldnummern nicht. Fertig.
Ja, immer wenn Zahlen dabei sind, ist es...
Und selbst wenn du das Centstück auseinandersägst, hast du nicht einen halben
Cent. Und dann hast du nämlich gar keinen Cent mehr.
Also digital ist ja die Basis des Lebens auf diesem Planeten.
Also erst als wirklich DNA entstanden ist und damit den Code des Lebens gespeichert
hat, die einzige analoge Nummer dabei ist, dass du so eine Randomisierung hast,
weil die Natur vergessen hat, in der DNA eine Fehlerkorrektur einzubauen.
Wenn wir das hätten, dann würden wir uns immer eins zu eins ideal kopieren können.
Es gibt die Fehlerkorrektur, aber wenn die zu gut funktionieren würde,
gäbe es halt keine Evolution.
Das stimmt.
Und die DNA, würde ich sagen, ist auch so ziemlich das einzige Beispiel in der
Natur, wo ich sagen würde, okay, da liegt eine Information digital vor.
Also ich meine, wie groß ein Baum gewachsen ist, ist nun mal analog.
Klar, das ist eine Interpretation des Sinneseindruckes.
Nein, aber wie viele Blätter er hat, wäre dann nach der Lesart schon wieder
eine digitale Information.
So, da kommen wir langsam auf einen grünen Zweig hier.
Solange wie du gut definieren kannst, was ein Blatt ist. Also die Menge von
Chlorophyll, die er produziert, ist dann wieder analog.
Und die hängt halt auch von vielen Faktoren ab. Also das ist.
So lange eine analoge Größe, wie du keine klare Messmethode und Bemessungsmethode gefunden hast.
Du kannst natürlich jederzeit einen Wert einfangen.
Also eine Temperatur ist eine analoge Größe, aber du kannst sie natürlich in
Grad einteilen und dann hast du eine digitale Information daraus gemacht.
Ja, aber dann hast du sie quantifiziert.
Genau, das ist die Quantifizierung, das ist der Unterschied zwischen der Schallplatte und der CD.
Im Großen und Ganzen, ja.
Dieses Bild ist großartig.
Es lässt sich jetzt, glaube ich, schwer vorlesen, sodass es noch zündet. Das ist Chat-Humor.
Wir müssen in unsere eigenen Witze machen.
Gut, ich fürchte.
Okay, also Lego. Entschuldigung, dass ich da jetzt so die Werbe rausgenommen
habe. Du hast totale Begeisterung gezeigt und ich finde das eine super Idee.
Das Kind erstellt ein digitales Bild mit Lego. Und das digitale Bild fließt
dann digital nach oben, aber dann wird es halt physikal, es wird anfassbar,
ach nee, stimmt, es wird nicht gedruckt, sondern es wird dann sozusagen elektronifiziert.
Es bewegt sich dann virtuell analog.
Ihm wird Leben eingehaucht. Genau.
Okay.
Und nach dem Motto laufen, hast du da so 20, 30 Stationen halt so und das ist
schon cool, da hat man also in der Tat auch als jung gebliebener Erwachsener viel Spaß.
Von daher würde ich dann also so das Fazit ziehen. Also wenn man nach Dänemark
fährt und Lego gerne hat, dann ist Billund schon eine Reise wert.
Aber wenn, dann tut euch den Gefallen und geht mindestens auf jeden Fall ins Lego-Haus.
Und Legoland, das kann man machen, aber das wo der eigentliche Spirit wohnt, das ist das Haus.
Okay, verstehe.
Wo der eigentliche Spirit wohnt. So ein kleiner Waldgeist oder was?
Genau. Das hat auch einen tollen Baum in der Tat ganz im Zentrum stehen.
Den habe ich auch ein Bild von gemacht.
Der ist so 20 Meter hoch, würde ich sagen.
Ein 20 Meter hoher, nur aus Legosteinen gebauter Mammutbaum,
um den sich quasi das ganze Haus so rumrangt. Auch sehr schön.
Ist auch ganz, ganz klein hier in meinem Modell drin enthalten, in der Mitte.
Wie gesagt, da fehlt jetzt oben noch das Dach. Da ist mein kleiner noch nicht
fertig geworden mit dem Bauen.
Was ich ganz lustig finde, es gibt irgendwie, es gibt ja so Printables und wie
sie alle heißen, diese Webseiten, wo man 3D-druckbare Modelle sich runterladen kann.
Und da hat tatsächlich auch jemand diese Lego-Blume, diese Allerwelts-Lego-Blume,
die so aus so drei Blüten besteht und so und die man irgendwo draufstecken kann,
in ungefähr Nachttischlampengröße nachmodelliert, dann kann man die sich ausdrucken
und als Lego-Blume auf den Tisch stellen.
Die habe ich bei mir zu Hause. In exakt irgendwie 20 Zentimeter Höhe.
Ich habe mir fest vorgenommen, nichts auszudrucken, was man einfach nur hinstellt.
Es müssen schon Sachen sein, die irgendwie was tun.
Wenn man sich diesen insgesamt wirklich sehr, sehr teuren Besuch noch etwas
schön rechnen will, dann muss man eben hingehen, genau wie ich das hier gemacht
habe und dann in dem Lego-Shop, den es dann natürlich auch gibt,
dann Modelle kaufen, die es nur dort gibt.
Das heißt also pro Jahr gibt es so drei oder vier verschiedene Sets von Lego,
die du nur im Lego-Haus Billund bekommst und offiziell nirgends wo anders auf der Welt.
Und wenn man die also im Keller lagert und zehn Jahre später verkauft,
ist das in der Tat eine ganz profitable Wertanlage.
Die gehen dann also schon echt hoch im Preis.
Und ich habe jetzt aber schon alles verdorben hier mit meinem Lego-Haus,
was es dort also aktuell gibt, weil sobald du es geöffnet hast,
ist es halt quasi nur noch ein Zehntel wert.
Von dieser Architecture Serie gab es mal eine Box, wo nur weiße Steine drin
sind und ein richtig dickes Handbuch, wo sie das mit der Architektur nochmal
erklären und du kannst halt alles nachbauen.
Das fand ich irgendwie sehr geil, aber es war mir viel zu teuer.
Naja.
Genau, wir sind jetzt hier gerade, Tim ist nochmal auf Google Earth unterwegs
und guckt sich jetzt hier von oben nochmal das.
Leider alles nicht in 3D, da fragt man sich ja wirklich.
Nicht in 3D, aber geh nochmal ein bisschen ran, dass man es wirklich nochmal
sieht. Dass du es siehst.
Dass wir alle es sehen. Also diese ganzen Plattformen, die ich da beschrieben
habe, ich glaube irgendwie 15 oder sowas, da sind alles einzelne Spielplätze oben auf dem Haus drauf.
Du kannst also alle belaufen und jedes von denen hat ein anderes Thema.
Jede von diesen Plattformen hat eine klassische Lego-Farbe, wie die klassischen
Lego-Steine halt gefärbt sind.
Und Kinder können da halt 15, wie viel auch immer, verschiedene Spielplätze
ausprobieren. Sehr cool.
Ja, so war das mit Dänemark.
Sowas gibt's auch von Ikea.
Lohnt sich aber nicht halb so sehr. Dafür ist der Eintritt jetzt...
Wie es gibt? Ikea-Land?
Naja, nicht Ikea-Land, aber es gibt so ein Ikea-Museum in... Wofür steht A?
Engsholm, Ang... Wie auch immer.
Ich war da auch mal gewesen, was ich ganz lustig fand, ist, dass die Billigregale,
die sie dort haben, da biegen sich auch die Bretter durch.
Das scheint, also auch Ikea scheint nicht davor gefeit zu sein,
dass ihre Qualität nicht gut genug ist.
Ansonsten nicht halb so beeindruckend wie das, was du jetzt da geschildert hast.
So, wo ihr nicht wart, ich auch nicht, wir alle nicht, aber ich muss das mal
ansprechen, ist Olympia.
Stimmt.
Olympia lässt euch wahrscheinlich kalt, oder?
Sehr kalt.
Ich habe ein bisschen was geguckt, aber wirklich wenig.
Es wäre schön, wenn mir so kalt wäre, wie Olympia mich lässt,
aber es ist leider zu warm hier drin.
Waren halt exakt die zwei Wochen, wo wir in Dänemark waren und wir hatten anderes zu tun.
Beziehungsweise meine Kinder sind erschütternd sportunbegeistert.
Gucken keinen Fußball, gucken keinen Olympia. Das interessiert die überhaupt nicht.
Also mein Großer ein bisschen so, dass einmal schwimmen gucken,
wie die Großen das machen, weil er selber jetzt auch im Verein ist,
aber da macht gar nichts Klick.
Es ist auch, ich meine, ich habe auch so meine Schwierigkeiten,
mich für dieses Ereignis zu begeistern.
Ich bringe das jetzt eigentlich auch nur deshalb auf, weil sie ja ambitioniert
in die Organisation dieser Veranstaltung gegangen sind und alles so an der Seine ausgelegt haben.
Vor allem die Eröffnungsveranstaltung, die ja ganz furchtbar ins Wasser gefallen
ist. Da zog ja gerade so richtig ein fettes Gewitter oder zumindest ein starker
Regen über die Stadt. Das hatten sie jetzt nicht verdient.
Aber das eigentliche Zwischenereignis war ja, dass sie die ganzen Schwimmwettbewerbe
tatsächlich dann auch in der Seine abfeiern wollten.
Nicht alle, aber so die Langstrecken-Geschichten.
Ja, klar, also Becken schwimmen kannst du da jetzt nicht machen,
genau, aber halt so diese Geschichten und dafür haben sie ja dann richtig viel
Geld in die Hand genommen und jahrelang ihre Wasserinfrastruktur.
Gepäppelt, um dieses Problem der Abwassereinleitung in die Seine in den Griff zu bekommen.
Ein Thema, was ja auch Berlin schon seit längerer Zeit verfolgt.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, mit welchem großen Erfolg Aber es wird ja
hier seit vielen, vielen Jahren, es gibt ja und gab viele Baustellen,
wo also große Rückhaltebecken eingebaut werden,
um einfach dieses Problem in den Griff zu kriegen.
Das ist im Prinzip ein bisschen ein Anschluss auch an unser Scheiß-Thema,
weil wir ja sozusagen dieses Problem haben,
dass wir diesen ganzen Unrat da halt so alles in ein Loch kippen und naja,
wenn es dann halt heftig regnet, dann….
Gibt es halt Überlauf und irgendwann muss es ja irgendwo hin und wenn du halt
die ganze Scheiße nicht in die Straße schicken willst, willst du halt nicht
oder in die Wohnung, dann geht es halt in den Fluss und das Problem hatten die natürlich dann auch.
Ich glaube am Ende haben sie es irgendwie hinbekommen, aber die Veranstaltungen
mussten mehrfach verschoben werden.
Ich finde es ja gut, dass sie das irgendwie machen und Paris hat ja im Gegensatz
zu Berlin und anderen deutschen Städten, wo ja jetzt Parteien irgendwie wieder damit ankommen,
Jetzt irgendwie, man müsste ja mal die Städte autofreundlich machen,
war das nicht irgendwie sowas, was die FDP jetzt irgendwie auf den Tisch gelegt hat?
Also ich weiß nicht, wie weit man im letzten Jahrhundert verfangen sein kann.
Ich verfolge ja deutsche Innenpolitik mittlerweile fast überhaupt nicht mehr,
aber das spült dann doch hoch und man fragt sich wirklich, was hat die eigentlich?
Bei der FDP wird es Zeit, dass die von der 5%-Hürde mal wieder abgeschnitten werden.
Ja, das hilft ja nicht. Die Leute gibt es ja dann auch mit dieser Grundeinstellung.
Und ich weiß gar nicht, ob die das jetzt wirklich meinen oder ob die das nur
so aus Prinzip von sich geben.
Ich glaube, das ist einfach nur eine Lobbypartei, die am meisten zahlt.
Übrigens, bevor ich es vergesse, zum Thema Wasser nochmal und Berlin und Wasserwerke.
Ich habe mich gestern mit jemandem unterhalten, der tatsächlich für Berliner
Wasserbetriebe arbeitet.
Und da ist es ja so, Berlin hatte ja die Wasserbetriebe verhökert, das Tafelsilber.
Und hat sie dann vor einigen Jahren wieder zurückgekauft.
Und dieser private Betreiber hat den Laden relativ stark runtergewirtschaftet.
Surprise, surprise.
Surprise, surprise. Und die haben jetzt das Problem, dass sie eigentlich Leute suchen.
Und zwar ist es so, dass die meisten länger dort Beschäftigten kurz vor der Rente stehen.
Und sie jetzt dabei sind, neue Leute, jüngere, aber eigentlich auch mittelalte Leute einzustellen.
Und wenn hier...
Also Ingenieure für Anlagenbau und alles, was man so macht, um irgendwie technisches
Gerät an den Start zu kriegen.
Wenn ihr nach Berlin wollt oder so, es lohnt sich mal bei den Berliner Wasserbetrieben
nachzugucken, was die so für Jobs offen haben.
Die scheinen momentan richtig zu suchen Leute,
mit denen sie die gesamte alte Technik jetzt wieder auf Stand kriegen und die
müssen jetzt auch relativ stark die Leute einstellen,
damit sie tatsächlich den alten Leuten, die noch wissen, wie es geht und auch
noch wissen, wo die Papierakten sind,
irgendwie das Know-how aus dem Rücken leiern, bevor die in Rente gehen.
Also so als kleiner Tipp zwischendurch.
Ja, das ist ein guter Tipp, weil das Problem, das gibt es ja auch im Handwerk genauso.
Also es ist ja alles so ein bisschen unpopulär, sich so Berufen zuzuwenden,
die so mit der Realität was zu tun haben.
Nachdem jetzt irgendwie 10, 20 Jahre alle dem Cyberspace hinterhergelaufen sind und den Bitcoins,
stellen wir halt fest, dass man, um so eine Gesellschaft zu organisieren,
dass so mit gut ausgebildeten Leuten, die so Handwerk- und Ingenieurskonzepte,
drauf haben, dass es eigentlich gar nicht so eine Scheiß-Idee war.
Also einfach nur mal so jemanden zu bekommen, der irgendwie in der Lage ist,
eine Wand einzureißen oder aufzubauen oder sonst wie eine Küche zu bauen und
mehr zu machen, als selber da vor dem Ikea-Manuel zu sitzen.
Das ist ja mit den Taxifahrern schon genauso. Ich meine, heute kein Taxifahrer
mehr, der sich in Berlin auskennt.
Die starren ja alle nur noch auf ihren Navi und gucken irgendwie durch die Gegend.
Ja, aber Elon hat uns doch die Robotaxis versprochen.
Wir haben erzählt, wir haben jetzt hier eine optische Besucherzählung bei uns installiert.
Die ist jetzt in einer Amerika-Gedenkbibliothek auch seit zwei oder drei Wochen
noch wirklich up and running und vier Fünftel der Projektzeit ging bei Warten auf Handwerker drauf.
Lahnkabel verlegen, zwei Löcher bohren.
Weil das so lange gedauert hat? Oder so lange gedauert hat, bis man jemand gefunden hat?
Nee, bis die Gewerke mal irgendwie ins Tun kommen.
Das hängt dann ja auch wiederum alles an der BIM. Das kannst du auch alles nicht selber machen.
Du kannst auch nicht irgendwen beauftragen. Da gibt es dann alle schöne Zuständigkeiten
und Verantwortlichkeiten.
Das dauert dann Woche um Woche um Woche, um irgendwo ein Loch zu bohren in Berlin.
Das ist schon betrüblich. Aber naja.
Ja, also öffentliche Infrastruktur ist auf jeden Fall etwas,
da müssen wir besser werden und das bezieht sich halt nicht nur auf den Verkehr,
sondern eben auf sowas wie Wasser.
Ich finde es schön, dass Paris da jetzt solche Schritte gemacht hat und selbst
wenn es jetzt für Olympia nicht gereicht hat, ist das halt auch wieder so ein
bisschen so, oh mein Gott, was ist, wenn wir das jetzt alles,
wie geht dieser Witz, What if we have,
saved, built a better world for nothing.
Also, ich finde das ja ganz gut.
Und ehrlich gesagt, ich beneide schon die Leute, die so in 30,
40, 50 Jahren hier leben werden.
Wo, jetzt sagen wir mal, meine Chancen, da aktiv noch beizuwohnen,
überschaubar geworden sind.
Weil ich glaube, es wird dann auch irgendwann so diesen Schritt geben,
der steht ja jetzt unmittelbar bevor.
Also jetzt haben wir ja diese ganzen Abwehrkämpfe von der FDP und von anderen
Blitzpiepen, die die ganze Zeit rückwärtsgewandten Unsinn erzählen,
obwohl vollkommen klar ist.
Auch die C-Parteien.
Ja, auch die C-Parteien, es ist vollkommen klar, es wird irgendwann klimaneutral laufen.
Es werden irgendwann nicht jedes Fahrzeug mit seinem eigenen Kraftwerk unter
der Haube durch die Gegend marschieren.
Ich stelle mir das mal so vor, als ob da so ein eigenes Kohlekraftwerk sozusagen da drin ist.
Und da merkt man mal, wie absurd das eigentlich ist.
Obwohl so Holzvergaser ist jetzt schon so ein bisschen länger her.
Ja, und du weißt, was ich meine. Also dieser ganze Aufwand, der heutzutage in
so ein Fahrzeug getrieben wird, nur um das irgendwie durch die Gegend zu fahren,
wirkt ja absurd im Vergleich zu dem, was man eigentlich wirklich an Technologie benötigt dafür.
Ja.
Und mit dem Wasser ist es dann halt genauso. Also irgendwann lebt man mal auch
in Berlin vielleicht in einer gesunden Stadt.
Ich habe hier als Party-Pupa nochmal aus der Sportschau reingegeben.
Drei von vier deutschen Starterinnen sind nach schwimmender Szene erkrankt während Olympia.
Also mal auch wieder gucken. Ja, Zufälle passieren auch so und da muss man erstmal
wieder genauer hingucken.
Es hat am Ende nicht ganz hingehauen. Sie haben es immerhin so weit gebracht, dass es überhaupt ging.
Dass nicht alle krank wurden.
Naja, eben. Und sie haben halt Pech gehabt.
Wer kommt ins Ziel?
Sie haben ja Pech gehabt, weil wir so einen regenintensiven Sommer haben.
Also wäre der Sommer so wie letztes Jahr gewesen, bin ich mir relativ sicher,
hätte das funktioniert.
Aber wenn halt alle drei Tage stark Regen kommt und dir irgendwie alles wieder
in den Fluss spült und du eben noch nicht diese Überkapazitäten aufgebaut hast.
Insofern vielleicht auch ganz gut, dann machen sie wahrscheinlich auch noch
ein bisschen weiter, bis es dann wirklich funktioniert und dann kann man da auch mal drin baden.
Du fragtest, ob ich was von den Olympischen Spielen mitbekommen habe.
Eine Sache habe ich gesehen und zwar, ich weiß nicht seit wann Breakdance olympisch ist.
Zum ersten Mal gewesen.
Zum ersten und zum letzten Mal.
Nur war da irgendwie eine australische Starterin, die eine sehr merkwürdige
Vorstellung davon hatte, was Breakdance ist.
Da gab es so, glaube ich, auch das eine oder andere Meme zu.
Ja, das war traurig. Da gibt es aber auch den einen oder anderen Hintergrund,
also dieses Wissenschaftlerin eigentlich in ihrem echten Leben zum Thema,
Tanzen, Breakdance und so weiter und hat halt im Sinne der teilnehmenden Beobachtung,
wie wir Sozialwissenschaftler sagen würden, halt auch selber dort sich schon erprobt.
Und ist in einem Vorentscheid aber dann halt nominiert worden von Australien war es.
Ob sie sich unter Restwelt und dem Breakdance damit jetzt einen Gefallen getan
hat, darüber kann man jetzt irgendwie streiten, aber das, was dann irgendwie dort...
Darüber kann man nicht streiten, hat sie nicht. Also das war...
Ja, aber ich erinnere an Eddie the Eagle. Wir erinnern uns den einzigen jemals
erfolgreichen, in Anführungszeichen, Ski-Weitspringer aus Great Britain, England.
So über den hat sich auch die ganze Welt lustig gemacht, aber auf eine sehr
wohlwollende Art und Weise, was der sich traut und dass es doch cool ist,
dass auch solche Exoten dort irgendwie teilnehmen können.
Oder das Bob-Team aus Jamaika?
Dem gegenüber finde ich.
Jetzt das was Die haben ja auch was geleistet Er hat sich nicht den Hals gebrochen
Eddie the Eagle gebe ich dir Der hat jetzt keine besonders guten Leistungen
erzielt, bloß bei dieser,
australischen Breaking, heißt das ja korrekt Breaking Performance vermisste
man halt das Element Breaking Also es war sozusagen,
irgendwas, aber es hatte nichts mit dem zu tun, weswegen da eigentlich alle hingekommen sind.
Von daher kann ich es schon verstehen, auch wenn ich nicht ausschließen möchte,
dass es hier mal wieder funktioniert hat, draufzuhauen, weil es halt eine Frau
war und es vielleicht beim Mann nicht so funktioniert hätte. Man weiß es nicht.
Ach ja, Eddie the Eagle. Wann war denn das überhaupt?
Das ist schon ein bisschen her.
Ja, aber wann?
Also jetzt hat jemand den Wikipedia-Artikel rausgekramt. hier,
1963 geboren, ich glaube seine Hochzeit, das waren so Ende 80er, hätte ich jetzt gesagt.
89 stürzte er in Innsbruck und brach sich das Schlüsselbein. No surprise here.
Als größten Moment bezeichnet er die Abschlussfeier Olympischen Spiele 88,
also Ende 80er Jahre. Na, schon ein bisschen her.
Genau, 88 war er dann dabei in Calgary.
Oberstdorf 86, Großchance, Platz 110. Von 110. Zehnen.
Ich dachte, der olympische Gedanke ist... Der ist halt so die Hälfte der normalen
Distanz halt, ist der gesprungen. Da gibt es bestimmt Videos auf YouTube.
Aber ich dachte, der olympische Gedanke ist dabei sein.
Ja, aber der olympische Gedanke, also er hat aber auch einen Skisprung durchgeführt
und die Diskussion bei dieser Australierin war halt...
Ob sie überhaupt Breakdance gemacht hat.
Genau. Und das war, sagen wir mal, einer Disziplin, die jetzt,
vielleicht so ein bisschen gehofft hat, auch zu bleiben, auch wenn das glaube
ich für Los Angeles schon abgesagt ist, was mich ein bisschen wundert,
weil Amerika und so, aber egal.
Also ich habe mir das zufälligerweise auch angeschaut und naja,
ich habe es eh nicht so mit Olympia.
Ja, es gibt da halt so eine gemeine Vertonung von diesem Ossi-Man,
der immer spaßige Videos kommentiert.
Also etwas, was ich in der Tat gesehen habe, was mich total geflasht hat,
ist in der Tat Speedclimbing.
Oh ja.
Ich habe in meiner jetzt auch schon 15 Jahre zurückliegenden Jugend auch mal
ein bisschen geklettert.
So richtig mit Sicherung und Vorstieg und Routenauskundschaften und sowas.
Aber immer nur in der Halle, nicht draußen.
Dafür hat es dann nicht gereicht. Aber dann hast du schon einigermaßen einen
Eindruck, auch wenn um dich herum richtig gute Kletterer sind,
was denn so schnelles Klettern irgendwie bedeutet.
Und jetzt hatten sie halt hier bei Olympia jetzt die Split-Kletterer halt am
Start und hier den Frauenwettbewerb gewonnen hat.
Die hat also zwei Weltrekorde hintereinander einen aufgestellt,
einen im Vorlauf und einen dann im Finale.
Und das ist so absurd. Es sieht einfach aus, als würde die halt horizontal irgendwo langlaufen.
Ich habe mir dann die Männer-Finals angeguckt. Die waren nochmal schneller.
Die waren also eine Sekunde schneller.
Aber es sah irgendwie nicht so magisch aus. Also da merkst du einfach so,
die machen das halt. Die haben halt einfach die Muskeln und die ziehen sich da hoch.
Und es sieht alles irgendwie physisch aus. Und die scheint einfach irgendwie Magie am Start zu haben.
Ja, das war so total Spider-Man-nützig.
Die hat so eine Eleganz. So, dann denkst du dir, verdammt, du willst jetzt irgendwie
so fünf Minuten dich fünf Minuten dran abarbeiten und die macht das in vier
Sekunden. Was ist da los?
Tolles Video. Guckt euch das mal an.
Alexandra Miroslav heißt die gute.
Wo war die her nochmal? Aus Polen, glaube ich, ne?
Zumindest da ist eine polnische Flagge in dem YouTube-Video.
Das spricht dafür.
Alright, dann können wir ja das Olympia-Thema beiseite legen.
Da haben wir doch länger drüber gesprochen.
Als ich dachte. Ja, es gibt immer irgendwas.
Irgendwas ist immer.
So, womit machen wir weiter?
Wir hätten auch ein bisschen Feedback vielleicht. Letzte Sendung, kurz und knackig.
Was wurde eigentlich aus dem Paradies?
Was wurde eigentlich aus dem Paradies? Gut, dass du fragst. Wer denn uns Freakshow
berichtet von einem Jahr? Ist es jetzt schon ein Jahr her?
Keine Ahnung.
Oder war das dieses Jahr?
Das war dieses Jahr.
Nein, doch.
Ja, stimmt.
Ansonsten würden die Mühlen der Justiz da auch sehr, sehr lange mühlen.
Also wir erinnern uns, meiner Frau wurde ein Fahrrad geklaut.
Wir haben es mit einer Hundertschaft der Polizei uns wieder erkämpft.
Und wir hatten dann dadurch eine sehr klare Identifikation des Täters.
Da es in einer Garage gefunden wurde, die halt auf eine Person zugeschrieben war.
Und jetzt haben wir also jetzt nach zwei Monaten, hat es ziemlich genau gedauert,
jetzt erinnere ich mich auch wieder, haben wir jetzt eine Mitteilung von der
Staatsanwaltschaft bekommen, dass jetzt also diese Person zu Bußgeldzahlungen
auch verurteilt worden ist.
Zweimal 600 Euro, das ist jetzt nicht übermäßig viel, das waren ja drei geklaute Fahrräder.
Habe ich jetzt nicht im Kopf.
Weil das hängt ja immer davon ab, was der oder die sonst so verdient.
Ja, aber Verfahren ist halt eingestellt.
Das heißt also, er hat jetzt keine Vorstrafe, sondern damit ist also quasi jetzt die Tat vergolten.
Wenn man sich aber ein bisschen im Justizsystem auskennt, dann weiß man,
wenn der jetzt nochmal irgendwo auffällig würde,
es gibt ja auch durchaus eine interne Datenbank noch, wo die Einträge noch bestehen
bleiben von solchen Aktionen, dann wird dem, denke ich, nochmal durchaus heftiger
auf die Finger geklopft.
Das heißt also ein pädagogischer Wert oder Erziehungseffekt dürfte da schon vonstatten gehen.
Aber es ist was passiert und er ist nicht ungeschaden davon gekommen.
Und das ist ja irgendwie so ein Aspekt, den ich ein bisschen gruselig finde.
Wir kennen jetzt seinen Namen, er kennt unseren Namen.
Das ist halt irgendwie so Teil von seinem Verfahren halt an der Stelle.
Na ja, jetzt kann man sich mal besuchen und Hallo sagen.
Tja, viel Spaß.
Das gehört zum Rechtsstaat halt auch dazu. Ein anderer kurzer Punkt,
wo ich aber einfach etwas vertrosten würde.
Es gab einen geharnischten Kommentar zu unserer letzten Sendung,
dass ich mutwillig und vermutlich bosartig Effective Altruism und E-Excel,
also Effective Acceleratism,
schwierig,
E-Accelerationism, Gott was für ein Wort, zusammengeworfen hätte.
Wir erinnern uns, das war diese ganze Silicon Valley Schleife,
die wir da mit den Techbros, die wir da gezogen haben.
Ich erinnere mich ehrlich gesagt nicht, aber egal.
Dazu möchte ich nur folgendes Statement verlesen.
Mir ist ja wohl bewusst, dass das zwei unterschiedliche Strömungen sind.
Ich halte es aber für Diskussionswert, inwieweit die sich nicht doch sehr stark
gegenseitig beeinflussen und dass dort auch die Schnittmenge sehr diffus und unscharf ist.
Es könnte aber ganz interessant sein, dazu vielleicht mal wirklich irgendwann
ein Schwerpunktthema mal in einer Sendung zu machen.
Das würde ich also jetzt nicht so zwischen Tür und Angel diskutieren,
aber mir ist also sehr wohlbewusst, dass das zwei unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe
sind, aber es sind eben beides Schuhe und nicht das eine ist ein Schuh und das andere ist ein Auto.
Ja, ich kann mir auch vorstellen, woher die Klage so herrührt,
ohne mich zu sehr in diese ganze Themenwelt reingelesen zu haben,
weil dieser Effective Altruism hat ja so im Kern die Idee, nee,
ich will der Welt was Gutes tun,
aber ich bin ein Nerd und ich möchte gerne die Effizienz meines Helfens selber im Griff haben.
Ich will nicht einfach nur irgendwo in irgendeine ineffektive Organisation was
reintun, wo dann 40 Prozent in Verwaltungsvorgängen und sonstigen Bestechungsmaßnahmen,
also die Wahrnehmung von außen, verpuffen.
Sondern ich möchte das gerne analysieren und das ist ja so eine Bewegung,
die dann so, dann ja wir machen das messbar und wir machen das,
wir beobachten das und dann quantifizieren wir die Effizienz unseres Handelns.
Kann ich jetzt mit meinem Dollar, wie viele Menschen kann ich mit meinem Dollar
jetzt durch einen Monat bringen, wenn ich das hier reingebe oder da reingebe.
Das ist so ein bisschen die Grundidee.
Das heißt, das ist, sagen wir mal, ein sehr gut gemeinter Ansatz mit so einer Nerd-Perspektive.
Vor allem mit einer Nerd-Perspektive von Leuten, die sich, sagen wir mal,
Dinge auch leisten können.
Die dann aber sagen, mir geht es gut, anderen soll es auch gut gehen und ich
bin ja generell der Welt gegenüber positiv eingestellt und deswegen so. Und da.
Kommt dieser Begriff her. Da ist er entstanden, aus dieser Motivation heraus.
Mittlerweile, wie das immer so ist, ist das aber alles aufgegangen in so einem
Melting Pot von allen möglichen Ansichten darüber.
Die sehr oft was mit, wie reiche Menschen die Welt sehen und wie sie sie gerne beeinflussen wollen.
Da ist das drin gelandet und effektiv Altruism ist halt nur ein Ding,
was mittlerweile mit diesem Tazkriel-Sammelbegriff zusammengehakt wird,
wo dann eben auch noch so Transhumanismus und diese Singularitaria und Kosmism
und Rationalism und Longtermism und all diese ganzen anderen Isms,
die wir jetzt links und rechts um die Ohren gehauen bekommen in dem Kontext,
wenn man halt über Musk und Thiel und die ganzen anderen durchgedrehten,
die 50 Prozent der durchgedrehten Valley-Bewohner.
Die einfach zu viel Zeit und zu viel Geld haben und auch in so einem Größenwahnsinn
auch gerade anfangen vor sich hin zu glühen und alles besser wissen.
Und am Ende aber auch darüber auch nur ihre Macht ausüben.
Und deswegen sind diese ganzen Begriffe halt jetzt beschädigt.
Und so wie du wahrscheinlich den Begriff Krypto nicht mehr eingefangen bekommst
und Cyber, werden dann wahrscheinlich auch solche Begriffe Langzeitschaden genommen haben werden.
Und da kann man jetzt noch so entrüstet drüber sein, das ist leider alles gerade
dabei, komplett überfahren zu werden von so einem Cyber-Truck.
Cyber ist aber auch so ein richtiger Deppenmarker geworden.
Ja, genau.
Also genauso wie Blockchain.
Ja, eben. Okay. Deppenmarker, da wollte ich mich ja auch noch drüber aufregen.
Also das ist natürlich jetzt wieder eine Klage im Urwald, also das hört natürlich
wieder keiner. Ich äußere das jetzt.
Nichts wird sich ändern. Ist mir absolut bewusst. Wir kennen ja alle den Deppen-Apostroph.
Und den Deppen-Bindestrich.
Das Deppen-Lehrzeichen.
Es gibt viele Ausprägungen.
Ja, aber viel hat ja auch damit zu tun, mit so einer Verwirrung der,
wie soll ich sagen, der Gültigkeit von Sprache und Schreibung.
Sprache ändert sich ja die ganze Zeit und es lässt sich ja nicht ignorieren,
dass der Einfluss des Englischen enorm ist.
Ja, ich habe meinen Kampf dagegen auch aufgegeben. Das hat keinen Sinn.
Das ist jetzt faktisch, dass die Leute lange Worte auseinanderschreiben und
sich da auch nichts bei denken und dann ist es halt so.
Ja und das ist ja auch nicht so im Deutschen gar nicht mal jetzt so klar,
wo du jetzt mit einem Bindestrich agierst oder wo du ein Wort zusammenschreibst
und man kann ja auch lange darüber diskutieren, was nun besser ist,
weil die Lesbarkeit ist teilweise mit Bindestrichen halt besser.
Aber da ist das Englische ja auch nicht so klar. Also auch im Englischen schreibst
du manchmal die Worte einfach hintereinander oder manchmal mit einem Bundesstrich
und manchmal schreibst du es auch zusammen.
Das ist sehr selten, aber ja.
So selten ist das glaube ich gar nicht. Du hast auch viele zusammengesetzte
Worte im Englischen, die irgendwann mal zusammengesetzt worden sind und die
du halt in eins schreibst.
Wo man auch sagen könnte, warum schreibst du das nicht als zwei Worte.
Weiß ich nicht, haben die anderen schon so gemacht.
Da fällt halt auch ein bisschen dieser Deppenapostroph rein,
der halt bei Pluralbildung und bei Besitzanzeige schon immer sein Unwesen getrieben
hat und auch sehr schwer zu fassen ist.
Andreas Buch, wo du halt hinten dann Apostrophes drinstehen hast,
anstatt halt Andreas Buch einfach zusammengeschrieben.
Und ich verstehe, wo es herkommt, weil man sieht jetzt überall aus dem Englischen,
wo nun mal dieser Genitiv mit Apostroph S gebildet wird.
Und im Floral auch mit S-Apostroph, was ich fürchterlich finde, aber ja.
Ja, und dann ist das Deutsche halt auch so ein bisschen komisch dabei.
Also da macht jetzt Deutschland nicht so sehr viel mehr richtig,
in Anführungsstrichen, und es ist auch alles nicht so klar geregelt.
Es ist schwierig, darauf reinzuhauen, der Deppen-Apostroph.
Apostroph ist einfach Realität.
Aber ich habe ihn auch in den letzten Jahren, finde ich, wirklich wenig gesehen.
Ich hatte den Eindruck, dass da irgendwo die Leute gemerkt haben, da war was.
Schauen wir nochmal hin.
Ja.
Aber, aber.
Andreas, ihm sein Buch. Genau, so nämlich.
Andreas, ihm sein.
Schreibt der Chat gerade.
Wo ich aber nicht mitgehe.
Ja.
Wo ich mir sage, wenn schon Apostroph, dann richtig.
Weil es gibt ja auch noch den Deppen-Akzent.
Und der Deppen-Akzent ist ein Computertastatur-Problem.
Schaut mal auf eure Tasten. Wo ist das Apostroph?
Welches?
Es gibt nur eins.
Das ist bei der, wie nennt man das Ding? Raute mit Shift.
Korrekt. Dabei handelt es sich um ein Apostroph.
Das andere ist ein Back-Tick und ein Forward-Tick.
Oder auch ein Akzent.
Oder ein Akzent, wenn man es denn auf einen Buchstaben drauf tut,
der einen Akzent verträgt.
Richtig, ein Akzent, Ägu und ein Akzent, das Akzent Graf und ein Akzent Ägu.
Ah, show on, okay.
Ja genau, ein Zirkonflex ist das Dach.
Ah, ich verstehe, was du meinst.
Akzent, Zirkonflex ist das Dach. So, und was machen die Leute,
wenn sie ein Apostroph schreiben wollen? Sie hauen auf diese Taste.
Ich kann das auch hier wieder in gewisser Hinsicht verstehen.
Ich habe viel Verständnis für die Menschheit heute, aber es hat auch Grenzen
und ich möchte nur mal kurz darauf hinweisen,
falls ihr das noch nicht begriffen habt, ja das deutsche Keyboard Layout ist
bekloppt, weil es nämlich nicht mehr unseren Schreibgewohnheiten entspricht
und eine komplette Taste dafür zu opfern,
nur ein Akzent Ägu und ein Akzent Graf anzubieten, was wirklich niemand braucht.
Die auch noch Deadkeys sind.
Die auch noch Deadkeys sind. Und das auch noch direkt neben dem Delete,
wo man irgendwie öfter ist.
Dann kann ich ja auch verstehen, dass das sozusagen, aber verdammt nochmal typografisch
handelt es sich dabei einfach um Akzente.
Deswegen ja Dead Key, eigentlich drückt man diese Taste,
um dann einen Akzent auf etwas drauf zu machen und man kann natürlich die Taste
drücken und dann ein Leerzeichen drücken und dann hat man nur das Akzent,
aber das ist dann halt eigentlich kein Apostroph, sondern nur das Akzent. aus.
Und ich meine, das ist natürlich schon praktisch, wenn man viel mit Franzosen redet.
Es ist auch vielleicht ganz praktisch, wenn man viel mit einem polnischen,
so, slawische Schreibung und so, und also da kommt dann schon mal so,
auch mal so ein Akzent auf ein S und sowas drauf in beide Richtungen.
Aber es ist halt trotzdem ein Drama, so eine Tasse auf der Tastatur zu haben
und dann kommen mir die Leute und sagen, ja hier, Caps Lock könnte man ja weglassen
und so. Weißt du? Sowas gibt es ja auch.
Und das wäre eigentlich die Taste, die man weglassen müsste.
Aber sie ist nun mal da und ich möchte darauf hinweisen, dass es sich dabei um Akzente handelt.
Und der Apostroph ist über dem Lattenzaun.
Man sieht den Unterschied dann aber eigentlich ganz gut, wenn man es erstmal
getippt so vorsichtig sieht.
Genau, wenn man es nämlich mal schreibt.
Und guck mal, dein Beispiel mit Andreas und Andreas jeweils mit dem Akzent und mit dem Apostroph.
Das Apostroph hat auch einfach ein komplett anderes Kerning.
Ja, genau.
Und das ist das, was den Deppen-Akzent so typografisch so schwierig macht für
mich, dass das einfach auch die Typografie komplett zerstört und dann siehst
du das auf Schildern überall,
in Werbungsanzeigen.
Leute, ihr arbeitet in der Werbung.
Kriegt ihr da keinen Kurs Typografie?
Erzählt euch keiner, wie die Symbole heißen in eurem Zeichensatz?
Lernt man das? Das ist ja wie mit den den Klemmen an, die drei Stunden lang
da irgendwie ihr Rohr reinschrauben oder irgendwie eine Steckdose installieren,
die Elektriker, weil sie alle nichts mehr gelernt haben. Schlimm.
Was ich noch viel schlimmer finde, ist, dass Leute das falsche Akzent dann tatsächlich
im Französischen verwenden, wo dann Krepp nicht mehr Krepp heißen, sondern Kreb oder Gräb.
Also das ist schon ganz fies.
Also hier auf deine Frage, so lernt er denn keine Typografie mehr?
Das macht halt heute alles Kennen wahr für die Leute.
Was macht alles Kennen wahr?
Ken war, kennste, oder?
Nee.
Ist so ein Programm, was benutzt wird für Design, aber ich habe keine Ahnung,
welche Qualitäten das hat.
Ja, Design ist halt jetzt, also das ist halt quasi, also eigentlich begrüße
ich ja solche Initiativen.
Das heißt also Demokratisierung von oder Verfügbarmachung von vernünftig aussehendem
Design und Layouts, ohne dass man dort irgendwie groß was studiert,
gelernt, wie auch immer.
Ach Gott, das habe ich hier gerade gestartet.
Also es ist so eine Art MS Paint für Design.
Ja, also du hast halt zig Vorlagen, du kannst aber auch mit einer KI sprechen
und sagen, Achtung, ich möchte zum Geburtstag meines Fünfjährigen was zum Thema
Lego machen, entwäfe mir mal eine Einladung dafür.
Und dann baut er dir ein relativ gut aussehendes Template zusammen,
was du dann noch anpassen kannst und so richtig klickmichbunti-mäßig sich zusammenschiebt.
Und je nachdem, wie so üblich, diese Tools sind aber halt nicht komplett strunzend
doof, sondern da steckt also schon eine Menge ganz guter Logik hinter.
Die waren jetzt vor ein paar Wochen wieder in den Medien, weil sie ihr KI-Trainingsmaterial
unter anderem von den App-Guidelines von iOS abgeleitet haben.
Dass dann also plötzlich, wenn du dem Tool gesagt hast, baue mir mal eine Wetter-App
oder einen guten Template für eine Wetter-App, dann sah die exakt so aus wie
quasi das Apple Weather-Programm.
Das ging vor ein paar Wochen irgendwie rum. Also das ist mal wieder alles sehr zwiegestalten,
weil du halt mit solchen Tools schon relativ schnell heutzutage zu brauchbaren
Ergebnissen kommst, genau wie Bildgenerierung für Werbung, hatten wir auch schon
vor einem Jahr in der Sendung, das wird auch nach wie vor im Tagestakt besser,
aber die Leute verlernen natürlich Handwerk auf der anderen Seite und dann kommen
auch solche Effekte dabei raus.
Genau, Kenba wollte Affinitik kaufen. Haben Sie das nicht auch?
Das haben Sie doch auch, oder?
Also, okay, meinetwegen. Aber wenn man sich mit irgendwas beschäftigt,
dann sollte man einfach ein bisschen die Zeit nehmen. Das ist doch gar nicht
so schwierig, finde ich.
Also ich meine, die meisten Themen, um da wirklich mal so die Basics drauf zu
kriegen, ist doch in der Regel, naja gut, wie viel Zeit braucht man dafür? Ein, zwei Wochen?
Ja gut, aber du redest von einer Branche, wo teilweise halt auch Korrekturlesen
jetzt nicht unbedingt die stärkste Suite ist.
Also klar, die professionellen Werbebuden, die können das schon,
aber alles was so unterhalb ist und
kein Geld ausgeben will und selber an irgendeinen Druckservice schickt.
Ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass die Welt morgen fehlerfrei ist. Ich möchte nur eins.
Ich möchte gerne, dass ihr alle zu euren Freunden geht und sagt,
weißt du, was der Deppen-Akzent ist?
Und dann zeigt ihr die falsche Taste und dann zeigt ihr die richtige Taste.
Und wenn ihr eine E-Mail bekommt mit Deppen-Akzent, dann lehnt ihr die Annahme
der E-Mail ab, weil falsche Typografie.
Du meinst, der Deppen-Akzent ist das neue Comic Sans?
Da werden wir jetzt zehn Jahre kämpfen müssen, fürchte ich. Und vielleicht auch verlieren.
Tja, Fehlermeldung 499, wrong typography.
So, übrigens danke nochmal an Philup gerade im Chat. Das mit der Wetter-App-KI,
das war nicht Kenverson, das war Figma.
Aber auch so eine Bude, die so in dem Dunstkreis unterwegs ist.
Mit diesem AI-Thema, da werden sich schon so einige...
Aber Figma ist sehr viel stärker darauf ausgelegt, tatsächlich auch Designs für Apps zu machen.
Und auch mehr, ich glaube, mehr so mit, was so Designer benutzen.
Also bei uns in der Firma wird das benutzt.
Ob das eine gute Idee ist oder nicht, steht auf einem anderen Blatt.
Aber zumindest können die da scheinbar relativ effektiv mit arbeiten.
Gut. Nächstes Thema. Vielen Dank.
Was, bleiben wir doch gleich mal bei den Definitionen vielleicht.
Was ist, ihr seid ja hier in der Meta-Ebene.
Und ich vermute auch mal, ihr wisst.
Jetzt wird es Meta.
Ja, was ist denn die Meta-Ebene?
Also was ist die Definition davon?
Also meine Vorstellung von Meta war immer, es ist über etwas.
Also Metadaten sind Daten über Daten.
Also Daten, die bestreiben, wie Daten auszusehen haben, die anderen Daten, deswegen sind die Meta.
Insofern würde ich sagen, ist die Meta-Ebene halt die Ebene,
auf die man geht, um auf das, was man eigentlich tut, zu gucken.
Aber das ist jetzt natürlich auch keine schnittige Definition des Ganzen.
Also Meta kommt in der Tat aus dem Griechischen, heißt auch drüber, drüber, jenseits.
Und ich würde auch sagen, der entscheidende Punkt ist der Analyseaspekt.
Das heißt also, ich begebe mich auf eine Meta-Ebene, um etwas,
was da drunter liegt, zu analysieren und besser betrachten und besser verstehen zu können.
Es ist also quasi keine, eine Meta-Ebene ist nicht sinnfrei,
sondern man, nutzt sie immer mit einem Ziel, nämlich das darunter besser verstehen
und analysieren zu können.
Bist du zufrieden?
Naja, also man merkt einerseits, dass ihr natürlich Ahnung habt von dem Thema.
Aha.
Also das ist ganz klar. Aber man merkt natürlich auch, dass wir als alte weiße
Männer ein Disconnect haben mit der aktuellen Zeit, weil ich habe jetzt entdeckt,
dass es alles ganz anders Ja, es ist. Okay.
Schauen wir mal an, was die Generation Z zu dem Thema zu sagen hat.
Um Gottes willen.
Ja, scheiße, wo waren wir gerade? Metaebene. Ach so, stimmt. Was Metaebene ist.
Metaebene heißt post-ironic. Das heißt post-ironisch.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man post auf Deutsch übersetzen kann. Aber das ist, wenn du dich...
nutzt, worüber die auf Ernst lachen, über die Leute lustig machst,
die darüber auf Ernst lachen. Das war die kurze Definition, die ich je gehört habe.
Hast du es gecheckt? Ich hab's schon verstanden. Aber ich dachte, ich hab's auch.
Damals schon verstanden. Aber ich hab's, glaube ich, einfach falsch angewendet.
Du hast es komplett falsch angewendet. Das Ding ist, das sagen ja jetzt auch
schon so die Zuhörer oder so Zuschauer, weil ich sag das auch voll oft in Videos
und ganz viele checken das.
Aber ganz viele benutzen das auch komplett falsch. Also ganz viele sind da so,
Kim, du bist wieder auf Meta-Ebene unterwegs. Einfach nur, wenn ich auf einem
London Bridge einen TikTok mache, dass es nicht auf Meta-Ebene unterwegs sein. Also sorry.
Ähm, Meta-Ebene ist zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt so sagen würde,
bombastischer Seitenblick. Krimineller, beleidigender Seitenblick.
Weil das würde ich niemals auf Ernst sagen. Das sage ich auf Meta-Ebene.
Ah, okay, verstehe.
Oder mein Gucci-Gürtel. Den habe ich mir gekauft. Ich trage den wirklich,
aber ich trage den nicht auf Ernst. Ich trage den auf Meta-Ebene.
Man kann auch Sachen anziehen auf Meta-Ebene.
Ich meine das nicht ernst, meine Gucci-Caps.
Ich habe mir Gucci-Caps gekauft. Ich finde das zwar irgendwie cool,
aber ich trage das post-ironic.
Und es checkt keiner.
Aber indem ich für mich selber weiß, ich finde das einfach nur lustig,
dass manche das auf Ernst tragen und trage deswegen diese Gucci-Cap auf Meta-Ebene.
Ist mir egal, ob andere das checken, aber ich trage das so. Oder diesen schönen
neuen Gürtel, den ich hier habe von Burberry. Findet ihr den?
Ich trage den auf Meta-Ebene.
Den trägst du nicht auf Meta-Ebene. Naja, so eine ganzen.
Markensachen trage ich immer auf Meta-Ebene.
Weil irgendwie ich kann so richtige Markensachen nicht ernst nehmen,
weil ich ja eigentlich immer alles.
Fake hatte vom Bazaar. Und jetzt habe ich mir manchmal so echte Sachen gekauft
und ich kann das irgendwie.
Nicht ernst nehmen, dass ich sowas trage. Aber ich finde es trotzdem,
deswegen trage ich, wenn ich Designer-Sachen kaufe... Also Meta-Ebene quasi
sich selber zum Klauen machen?
Nein, die Leute, die das alles ernst nehmen und ernst meinen zum Klauen machen.
Eigentlich finde ich das einfach nur cool. Das glaube ich nämlich auch.
Aber das Wort ist geil. Hast du das erfunden oder gab es das schon vorher?
Das Wort Meta und das Wort Ebene gab es auf jeden Fall beides vorher.
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe das noch nie vorher gehört, aber ich glaube nicht,
dass ich es erfunden habe.
Weil ich dachte, Meta hat auch was mit Zocken zu tun. Das wurde mir auch mal
irgendwie... Von Facebook oder was? Weil das von Facebook Meta heißt oder was?
Ja, bestimmt. Nee, nicht deswegen. Aber man sagt, glaube ich,
bei einem Zocken auch manchmal so, das war gerade richtig Meta.
Boah, ja, okay, nee, dann gibt's das, weil dann ich.
Keine Ahnung, sofort googeln, wann das Wort erfunden wurde.
Okay, wollen wir auf innen gehen? Wir bleiben diesmal bei so komischen Themen die ganze Zeit hängen.
Die kleinen Menschen. Die kleinen Menschen sind so auf Meta-Ebene.
Das finde ich auf Meta-Ebene lustig. Das ist einfach eine, ich kann es nicht
mehr gut beschreiben, so eine höhere Ebene. So eine höhere Ebene.
Vielleicht steige noch auf diese Ebene. Du wirst da noch drauf kommen. Hoffentlich.
Wo kramst du so was auf?
Können wir uns da jetzt kurz mal auf Meta-Ebene drüber lustig machen?
Bitte. Was ist denn das für zwei Hörer? Alter.
Wo findest du sowas? Wie stolperst du darüber?
Das ist mir zugetragen worden. Also das stammt jetzt nicht aus meinen persönlichen Abonnements.
Das Ganze nennt sich Podcast im Übrigen. Findet dann natürlich nur auf YouTube
statt zwischen diesen beiden Damen mit dem charmanten Namen Taschenbilliard.
Und es gibt da nicht sehr viel zu sagen.
Also für einen Podcast sind die verdammt gut gestylt. Aber vielleicht ist das auch Meta-Ebene.
Also auf Ernst jetzt, ja?
Ja, nee, auf Meta.
Also man muss das jetzt auch gar nicht tiefer diskutieren. Ich wollte nur darauf
hinweisen, dass es sehr unterschiedliche Auffassungen darüber gibt, was Meta eben so ist.
Ja, da habe ich jetzt was gelernt und ich meine das nicht Meta, sondern in Ernst.
Aber diese Stelle hast du...
Auf Ernst!
Diese Stelle mit, hast du diesen Begriff eigentlich erfunden?
Da kam schon so eine echte Spannung auf. Da hätte es kippen können.
Ja, also schon erstaunlich. Aber nee, den gibt es schon länger.
Ja, ein schönes Fundstück.
Ein schönes Fundstück.
Sehr gut, ja.
Also das ist, ja, und das zeigt auch wieder sehr schön, dass also Dinger können
auch einfach komplett abreißen.
Also Wissen geht einfach verloren.
Also für mich persönlich ist der Gedanke, dass das Wort Metaebene irgendwie so unbekannt ist,
Dass man fast annehmen kann, das wäre jetzt gerade im Rahmen irgendeiner Jugendspracheentwicklung
neu entstanden und zusammengewürfelt worden, den finde ich also wirklich unfassbar.
Ja, sass.
Na, aber ich meine, auf der anderen Seite, überleg dir mal, wo liest man den denn im Alltag so?
Tageszeitungen werden eh nicht mehr gelesen so.
Könnten wir einfach mal auf Sponn mal gucken oder Bild oder was auch immer.
Gucken wir doch mal, Bild hat doch jetzt auch hier so eine Suche über alles.
Ob Bild den Begriff Metaebene benutzt?
Also Meta-Ebene im Alltags-Wortschatz sind nun mal irgendwo auftaucht überhaupt
noch so. Es kann sein, dass es auch einfach ein altertümliches Wort geworden ist.
Gucken wir mal, was hier die Bild...
Also ich merke natürlich auch, dass wenn ich Leuten von der Meta-Ebene erzähle
und sie in irgendeiner Form sich das merken sollen, sodass sie die Domain eintippen
können, zum Beispiel das schon,
manchmal einen zweiten Anlauf braucht, klarzumachen,
ist jetzt nicht der Meter gemeint ist zum Beispiel.
Ich hätte da noch ein L hinmachen müssen, weil die Metal-Ebene kann sich jeder zeigen.
Okay, Live-Experiment. Das ist jetzt doch interessanter, als ich dachte.
Also ich bin auf bild.de gegangen und die haben eine Suche und dort habe ich
jetzt einfach mal Meta-Ebene eingegeben.
Jetzt ratet mal in den allen Artikeln, die auf Bild Online stehen,
und das sind ja doch so einige, wie häufig dort im Jahr 2024 24-Meter-Ebene vorkam.
Im gleichen Satz mit einem FDP-Politiker?
Also du meinst in allen Artikeln, die BILD online veröffentlicht hat?
Genau, in diesem Jahr. Wie viele waren das?
Gar nicht.
Einer. Und wann war das Jahr, in dem vor dieser einen Erwähnung,
die eine Erwähnung war am 16.01.24.
Zu welchem Thema?
Ricarda Lang und die Grünen. Die Grünen auf die Meta-Ebene sprechen über Emotionen
und Diskurs und so weiter.
Auf Ernst dann auch?
Auf Ernst. Auf Ernst. Was war das Jahr, in dem davor der nächste Artikel quasi
kam, der nächstjüngste quasi?
Ich fürchte, das hat ein paar Jahre gedauert.
28.10.2021. Das heißt also im Jahr 2022 und im Jahr 2023 gab es keinen einzigen
Beitrag auf Bild Online, wo Meta-Ebene als Wort drin war.
So und jetzt brauchst du dich nicht mehr fragen, warum das Thema mehr kennt.
Also Bild-Zeitung ist jetzt für mich jetzt nicht unbedingt gerade mein Maßstab.
Nein, natürlich nicht, aber das ist zumindest die untere Kante des Spektrums.
Es geht noch tiefer. Nicht viel.
Ich probiere jetzt mal den Tagesspiegel. Ich meine, das Problem ist natürlich
auch, wir wissen nicht, wie gut ist diese Suche.
Ja, also von denen.
Was sie an Snippets haben, die hat jetzt auch schon Bindestriche gefunden.
Ja, so Meter, Minusebene, nicht zusammengeschrieben.
Also da würde ich jetzt fast sagen, so schlecht ist die wahrscheinlich nicht.
So, jetzt gucken wir doch mal.
Spiegel Online. In den letzten zwölf Monaten 15 Artikel.
Also immerhin das 15-fache, aber jetzt auch nicht.
Mehr als einmal pro Monat.
Mehr als einmal, aber eben auch nur einmal pro Monat.
Tagesspiegel bringt es auf 8 für 2024.
Also wir können uns darauf einigen, es ist jetzt kein Wort, was so fürchterlich ist.
So, seit 2005 Spiegel Online. Das heißt also in den letzten zehn Jahren roundabout
173 Erwähnungen. Nicht viel.
Also dass das jetzt kein Wort des täglichen Gebrauchs ist, der im Supermarkt
permanent fällt, das ist mir ja durchaus bewusst.
Allerdings hätte ich ja jetzt erwartet, dass so mit Meta,
die Firma benennt sich so um Metaverse und überhaupt auch das Wort Meta an sich, ähm,
dass es schon eine gewisse Bekanntheit hat über jetzt Meta-Ebene hinaus.
Meta-Ebene ist ja schon nochmal ein spezieller Aspekt, so ein metaphorischer Ort.
Und Meta-Daten ist ja nun auch etwas, was schon gerade in den letzten Jahren
eine weitere Verbreitung gefunden hat.
Auch relativ neu sogar.
Ja, aber im technischen Zusammenhang. Also die beiden wirken jetzt nicht so als...
Nein, aber es ist ein Wort, über das berichtet wird. Es ist ein Wort,
was neu aufgekommen ist.
Ja, aber ich glaube, da bist du auch so ein bisschen in der Bubble.
Ich fürchte auch. Ich habe jetzt mal Google Trends angeworfen.
Das hatten wir letzte Sendung ja schon zum Thema Narrativ. Wir erinnern uns
an diese KSR-Plattform.
So, Verhältnis Meta-Ebene zu Narrativ ist 17 zu 1.
Das heißt also Narrativ wird 17 Mal so häufig verwendet wie Meta-Ebene.
Und Narrativ ist schon kein besonders populäres Mainstream-Wort, würde ich behaupten.
Also ich fürchte Meta-Ebene ist schon ein ganz schöner Exot.
Ja, und war es auch immer.
Wenn ich mir die letzten zehn Jahre hier angucke, hat es sich auch überhaupt
nicht irgendwie mal, dass es jetzt früher mal populär gewesen wäre.
Also Google Trends bietet mir jetzt hier einen Rückblick auf 20 Jahre in Deutschland,
ja nur Deutschland, ich glaube das ist das einzige was relevant ist,
jetzt könnte man natürlich sagen, okay was war 2006 schon groß irgendwie da,
da ist das Interesse 2011, 10 angestiegen.
Warum wohl? Na?
2010, Gründung der...
Naja, also 2005 wurde ja die Meta-Ebene hier überhaupt sozusagen gestartet,
beziehungsweise, ich weiß gar nicht, wann habe ich das Meta-Ebene umbenannt,
das weiß ich nicht mehr so ganz genau.
Auf jeden Fall die richtigen Podcasts, das ging ja alles so 2008,
dieser Podcast ging 2008 los.
Und dann, ja, hat das ja seinen Höhepunkt im November 2011 erreicht.
Und dann ging es schon wieder zurück. Naja.
Tja, wie sagt man so schön? Aus Meta-Ebene wurde auf Ernst und Ernst ist jetzt drei Jahre alt.
Ja, also jetzt wissen wir auf jeden Fall, das ist alles nur postironisch.
Die Damen wissen zwar auch postironisch nicht so richtig zu erklären,
aber das ist dann halt so.
Halifax schreibt gerade, finde ich aber auch ganz richtig im Chat,
wir müssen jetzt die beiden Taschenspielerinnen nicht zu den Kronzeuginnen einer
ganzen Generation machen. Ja.
Achso, entschuldige, der Podcast heißt Alpha Females, die Folge heißt Taschenbillard,
das habe ich gerade falsch gesagt.
Aber die Art und Weise, wie sie sich da aus dem Fenster lehnen, ist schon lustig.
Ja.
Aber kann man schon mal drüber lachen.
Kann man schon mal ein bisschen schmunzeln. Haben wir jetzt auf jeden Fall getan. Alright.
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
Ich habe was Schönes gefunden über Club Marte.
Gerade noch getrunken.
Gerade noch getrunken. Ich hatte zwar einst schon im CRE 175 am 15.
Februar 2011 einen Podcast zu dem Thema veröffentlicht. Da ist eigentlich fast alles gesagt.
Trotzdem bin ich heute auf ein YouTube-Video was ganz ordentlich gemacht und,
recherchiert wurde und nochmal ein paar Fakten zusammengetragen habe,
gestoßen zur Geschichte von Club Marte.
Club Marte, the lost history of Germany's trendiest soda.
Und das hat nochmal so zwei, drei Aspekte aufgebracht.
Ich hatte nämlich tatsächlich in meiner Erinnerung die Geschichte ein bisschen,
also ganz bisschen anders noch in Erinnerung gehabt.
Tatsächlich gibt es Club Marte schon wirklich ziemlich lange,
gut 100 Jahre und hatte es dann ein wenig schwer durch die beiden Kriege,
immer gerade wenn es jetzt irgendwie neue Initiativen gab,
das Getränk weiter zu popularisieren, kam ein Krieg dazwischen,
aber es ist ja dann, wie wir alle wissen, auch ganz gut gegangen.
Wie war doch gleich der ursprüngliche Name, der war so merkwürdig?
Bronte.
Bronte, Sektbronte.
Sektbronte, genau.
Und ist irgendwie so aus dem Süden Deutschlands nach Köstritz und dann wieder
zurückgekommen und ist dann am Ende 1994 bei der Loscher Brauerei gelandet in
München-Steinach und dort ist sie auch immer noch.
Aber was ich nicht wusste, was in diesem Video klar nochmal gesagt wurde,
was für mich jetzt insofern keine Neuigkeit ist, als dass ich es sofort bestätigen
kann, aber ich hatte es nicht so klar im Kopf,
Club Marte macht aus Prinzip keine Werbung.
Es gibt keine Club Marte Werbung, es gibt kein Club Marte Sponsoring.
Okay, kann sein.
Habt ihr wahrscheinlich noch nie gesehen, jetzt wo man es mal sagt.
Ich überlege, ob ich mal eine Club Marte Werbung gesehen habe.
Die Antwort ist, hast du nicht, weil das ist sozusagen das Hausprinzip der Loscher
KG, dass sie das nicht tun.
Club Marte hat sich immer darüber definiert. Das ist ganz hübsch,
weil natürlich auch die Geschichte von Hackern und Techno dort auch explizit entsteht.
erwähnt wird. Das fand ich dann sehr erfrischend, deswegen habe ich mir das
angeguckt, das wurde mir so im Algorithmus,
zugespielt und ich dachte mir so, aha, okay, schauen wir mal und tatsächlich,
haben wir das Computerclub und die Berliner Techno-Bewegung kommt zur Sprache.
Ja, bei mir schwappte das auch vorbei, aber ich habe das Video tatsächlich nicht gesehen.
Aber wo wir schon bei Club Marte sind, Ja, erzähl.
Ich habe da neulich so eine absurde Idee gehabt und habe sie dann auch in die
Tat umgesetzt und habe mir gedacht, was passiert eigentlich,
wenn man ein Bier braut und statt Brauwasser Clubmate benutzt?
Und, was passiert?
Es ist besser, als ich gedacht hatte. Also...
Also mal zurück. Wenn man so in Hobbygrößen Bier braut, dann,
also ich nehme zum einen Maischen immer so um die 20 Liter Wasser,
23 je nachdem, habe ich also beim Getränkehändler meines, Vertrauen ist jetzt
übertrieben, aber da wo ich immer hingehe, zwei Kästen Clubmate gekauft.
Und habe die halt so wie sie sind in den Braukessel gekippt und dann mit dem
Malz eingemeischt und den Rest im Prinzip so wie man es halt macht weiter durchgezogen.
stellt sich heraus, ja, schäumt wie Sau.
Erst mal. Es beruhigt sich dann, Gott sei Dank. Und man kann damit tatsächlich brauen.
Das Jungbier, als es rauskam, war fürchterlich sauer, weil Club Marte ganz offensichtlich
Säurungsmittel enthält.
Weil da ist ja so unglaublich viel Zucker drin. Und damit es nicht komplett
pappsüß ist, machen die da irgendwie Säurungsmittel rein und wenn man den Zucker
weggärt, dann bleibt halt nur die Säure übrig.
Aber nach drei, vier Monaten Reifung jetzt ist es eigentlich ganz lecker geworden.
Also man kann das tatsächlich trinken, wenn ich dran denke, bringe ich nächstes
Mal ein paar Flaschen mit.
Das mach doch mal.
Ich hab das jetzt nur überhaupt nicht auf dem Schirm gehabt,
sonst hätte ich längstens was mitgebracht.
Ja, kann man machen. Ob das eine gute Idee ist, muss jeder für sich selbst entscheiden.
Ich habe geguckt, keine Ahnung, vielleicht weiß das von unseren Hörern jemand besser, aber,
soweit ich recherchiert habe, ist Koffein relativ temperaturresistent.
Also man kann das Zeug kochen und es geht nicht kaputt.
Kaffee halt.
Ja, dementsprechend müsste jetzt in der 0,3 Flasche des fertigen Bieres ungefähr
so viel Koffein sein, wie vorher in einer 0,5er Flasche Club Mate war. Ja.
Also derselbe Typ, der dieses History of Club Marte Video gemacht hat,
hat auch ein How to Mass Produce Club Marte at Home Video gemacht.
Das wäre vielleicht dann auch nochmal was für dich.
Und ich packe auch gleich nochmal in die Shownotes das entropia.de-Wiki,
wo es eine Seite gibt, leckeres mit Mate und wo all diese ganzen tollen Mate-Getränke-Rezepte
drin sind, aber auch essbares.
Also es gibt Mackelpudding, Floretti, Tomate, Muffin, Wackelschudding.
Wahrscheinlich sollte man da auch das Wok, das Waffel-Operation-Center nochmal
erwähnen, das auf diversen Chaos-Veranstaltungen immer aktiv ist und Waffeln mit Club-Matte.
Ah ja, guck an, das sind wahrscheinlich die Muffeln. Felssalat mit Matte-Dressing,
fünf Matte-Terrine, Schukis, Marmüsli.
Was, fünf Matte-Terrine? Ja, steht da.
Matte-Pfannkuchen und so weiter. Da kannst du dann halt auch dein Bier mit eintragen.
Musst du dir nur ein fancy Name für einfallen lassen.
Ja, den habe ich schon.
Na?
Loschers Albtraum.
Okay,
der passt. Der ist gut.
Ich komme ja aus der Provinz Göttingen, war ich ja viele, viele Jahre, 20 Jahre.
Und so vor 15 Jahren, als das so auch mit der Netzszene und Republika und sowas
alles losging und mit dem Podcasting auch bei mir, da hast du da keine Mate gekriegt in Göttingen.
So, das hast du also neidisch sabbernd nach Berlin gestarrt,
wo es das dann also schon gut zu kriegen gab und es gab glaube ich dann irgendwann
einen einzigen Großmarkt in ganz Göttingen,
wo man dann Mate hatte und dann sind alle hingepilgert und haben sich dann einen
Kasten für die Podcastaufnahme ins Wohnzimmer gestellt.
Ja, das hat wirklich Geschichte, auch in Berlin.
Es war ja auch so, als wir dann angefangen haben, den Kongress in Berlin zu
machen, dann gab es ja immer im Januar die Marte-Krise.
Weil der Kongress sozusagen sämtliche Bestände, alles was ja irgendwie in den
Norden geliefert wurde, landete auf dem Kongress und wurde dort auch vernichtet.
und dann gab es immer für eine bestimmte Anschubzeit so Schwierigkeiten mit
den Nachlieferungen und das artete irgendwann mal aus, wo es wirklich irgendwie
so einen Monat lang irgendwie keine Marke zu kaufen gab oder sowas.
Das war schon speziell.
Das Problem existiert jetzt so nicht mehr.
Nee, zum Glück.
Ich trinke die immer noch ganz gerne, muss ich sagen.
Mir ist sie zu süß geworden. Ich trinke gerne Flora Power, weil die nicht so süß ist.
Aber die wird auch schon süßer, habe ich das Gefühl. Oder ich bin einfach,
ich kann keinen Zucker mehr ab. Das kann auch sein.
Ja, also die Club Mate, die kann schon was, aber es ist wie mit allen im Leben,
wenn man zu viel davon in zu kurzer Zeit zu sich nimmt, dann wird es anders.
Aber als Junk immer noch wunderbar.
Absolut.
Also ich habe tatsächlich, das ist wirklich sehr lange her, da war der Kongress
noch in Berlin, da habe ich tatsächlich meine Nacht durchgemacht mit diversen Flaschen Mate.
Da ist man dann irgendwann zwar wach, aber kann sich nicht mehr konzentrieren.
Bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo auch dann der Horizont nicht mehr so richtig an der
Stelle bleibt, wo er sein soll.
Also ohne, dass man jetzt Gleichgewichtsprobleme hat. Also das ist,
ja... Mäßigung ist eigentlich immer angesagt.
Die Club Marte Welt.
Schunk müsst ihr auf jeden Fall mal alle ausprobieren, wer das noch nicht gemacht
hat. Das ist auf jeden Fall das Getränk.
Gut, dann anderes Thema.
Ich könnte berichten. Ich habe einen Fehler gemacht Nacht und habe einen Wassertank,
einen Wassersack in meinem Auto transportiert. Der war nicht ganz dicht.
Der Wassersack war dann nicht mehr im Auto, aber es verblieb etwas Wasser im Auto.
Nicht in diesen Mengen, wo es dann irgendwie alles raus trieft und rostet oder
irgendwie oder vollkommen überschwommen ist oder sowas.
Nee, es war einfach nur feucht hinten auf diesem Teppich, den man so hinten drin hat.
Und dann stellte ich das Auto eine Woche lang in die Sonne.
In so ein Parkhaus, aber es war heiß.
Die Natur bahnt sich ihren Weg.
Und die Natur bahnte sich ihren Weg und als ich dann irgendwie dieses Auto wieder
abholte, roch es schon irgendwie sehr unangenehm und ich merkte dann schnell,
ich habe mir da so einen schnell wachsenden Schimmel eingetragen,
der dann auch so richtig so mit weißen Härchen schon irgendwie sehr sichtbar.
Innerhalb von einer Woche?
Innerhalb von einer Woche da raus kam. Vielleicht hatte das auch schon eine
Vorgeschichte und so weiter. Es wird jetzt nicht nur das Wasser gewesen sein.
Schimmelspuren sind überall, das kann man nicht verhindern.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall hat er da mal den Turbo eingelegt und dann hatte ich den Salat.
Zumal ich dann eben auch dieses Auto für eine längere Fahrt und Transport brauchte
und das alles irgendwie nicht so sauber war.
Naja, zu meinem großen Glück hatte jemand zufälligerweise zufälligerweise gerade
so eine Flasche Schimmel-Ex zur Hand, sodass ich dann erst mal schnell so erste
Maßnahmen ergreifen konnte.
Sofortmaßnahmen am Unfallort.
Genau, Sofortmaßnahmen am Unfallort,
um irgendwie diesen Schimmel so ein bisschen in den Griff zu kriegen.
Aber der schlechte Geruch, der war natürlich jetzt irgendwie am Start.
Ich bin dann irgendwie mit offenen Fenstern zurückgefahren und dann ging das
schon irgendwie alles so halbwegs, nachdem ich mühsam den Wagen nochmal einen
Tag mit offenen Fenstern in der Sonne getrocknet und ausgebürstet habe und so weiter.
Also ich habe schon so einiges an Maßnahmen ergriffen, natürlich mit Maske und so.
Aber dann hatte ich so ein bisschen das Problem, dass also insgesamt der Gesamtzustand
dieses Wagens halt bedenklich war.
Und wenn erstmal so irgendwas angefangen hat zu wachsen in so einem Auto und
feucht ist und du kannst das ja auch nicht so ohne weiteres auswringen, was machst du dann?
Diese Windabweiser wären jetzt kein...
Eine Alternative gewesen, oder?
Windabweiser?
Was sind Windabweiser?
Windabweiser sind so Plastikdinger, die man sich so ins Fenster oben reinmachen
kann, sodass, wenn man das Fenster offen lässt, selbst beim Regen es nicht reinregnet,
sondern das Auto durchlüften kann.
Achso, um sozusagen die Feuchtigkeit langsam rauszuholen. Naja,
also ich glaube, ich hatte die Feuchtigkeit insgesamt schon ganz gut im Griff,
aber es war halt einfach, der Zustand dieses Wagens war einfach nicht mehr fresh.
Also das war einfach eine Geruchsgemenge-Lage, die zwar nicht mehr ganz so bedrohlich,
aber definitiv nicht angenehm war.
Aber es war nur in Anführungszeichen in diesem Bodenbelag drin.
Nicht schon… Das weiß man ja nicht, wo es jetzt drin war.
Aber da war es zu sehen.
Da war es zu sehen, da wuchs es irgendwie raus und war dann nicht mehr zu sehen,
nachdem ich es da aufwendig rausgebürstet, also erst geschimmel-exed habe,
also am Ende ist das auch alles nur Wasserstoffperoxid und da wird schon jetzt
erstmal das weitgehend getötet gewesen sein, aber du weißt ja nicht,
wie du schon sagst, also Schimmelsporen sind überall und keine Ahnung,
ich wollte einfach mal einen clean cut haben.
Und da wurde ich dann mit einer Produktkategorie unserer modernen Welt vertraut
gemacht, die mir bis dahin noch vollkommen unbekannt war, nämlich einen Ozongenerator.
Ah, das hatte ich. Ja, ist immer weiter.
Das klingt ein bisschen schwurbelig.
Nein, nein, das ist überhaupt nicht schwurbelig. Das ist genau das, was es auf der Dose sagt.
Nämlich ein Gerät, was einfach durch Hochspannung Sauerstoff so trennt und wieder zusammenbaut,
dass daraus Ozon wird.
Genau, also die ganzen O2-Moleküle der Luft werden abgetrennt und verbinden
sich in diesem Prozess zu Ozon, also O3.
und ich kann euch das Gerät auch mal kurz zeigen, wenn ihr möchtet.
Ralf, du könntest es vielleicht mal kurz holen, das ist die Tür auf und dann...
Gerne doch, ich werde jetzt das Klo betreten, in der Hoffnung,
dass dort nicht zu viel Schimmel auf mich wartet.
Da ist überhaupt gar kein Schimmel.
Alles weg ozoniert.
Genau, so links dann auch noch mal die Tür aufmachen und dann schaut sich so ein blaues Gerät an.
Der Gerät ist blau.
Der Gerät ist blau, genau, da ist es schön.
Oh, das sieht aus wie eine zu klein geratene Nebelmaschine.
Ja, genau, so ähnlich sieht es aus.
Mit so einem GIF oben.
Ozone Generator.
Ist eigentlich auch sowas ähnliches wie eine Nebelmaschine, kommt bloß kein
Nebel raus, sondern kommt halt nur Ozon raus.
60 Gramm pro Stunde steht da.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das viel ist, aber ja.
60.000 Milligramm ist schon ein bisschen mehr.
Du kriegst auch Geräte mit weniger Leistung, aber du siehst schon,
es ist sehr einfach aufgebaut.
So ein Stromanschluss, Schalter ein und dann hast du da so eine Eieruhr.
Je nach Gerät kannst du die auf 30, 60 oder 120 Minuten stellen und dann schaltet
sich dieses Gerät einfach hart wieder ab.
Oder auf Hold.
Oder? Sehe ich das richtig?
Hold geht auch noch?
Ja.
Okay, Hold habe ich nicht gesehen.
Caution, use in unoccupied spaces only.
Genau. Und das ist nämlich die Idee, was ich nämlich nicht wusste oder was mir
nicht so bewusst war, dass Ozon der totale Lebewesen-Töter ist.
Und wenn euch jetzt sozusagen irgendwie mal sowas passiert ist,
wie irgendein Gemüse oder ein Obst oder irgendwas, was so verwesen und verwelken kann.
Oder ihr habt Rattenbefall im Auto gehabt oder der Marder hat sich Hunde,
Katzen, Gerüche aller Art,
die ausgelöst sind von Organismen aller Art. Sagen wir es mal so.
Ich hatte schon Ratten im Auto, aber in einer Plastikkiste. weil ich die wohin
gefahren habe, um sie dort freizulassen.
Achso, ja gut, aber die haben da nicht gehaust oder so.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ja genau, also das war so eine Story, die ich gehört habe, so Wohnmobilratten
haben sich irgendwie reingeschlichen durch irgendein schlecht abgedichtetes
Loch und fanden es dann super und dann hast du halt den Spaß.
Und dann musst du halt diesen Geruch und auch diese ganze Kontamination,
die damit verbunden ist, die willst du halt loswerden.
Und dann nimmst du so einen Ozongenerator.
Gegen Rauch hilft das, glaube ich, auch. Wenn irgendwas total angekokelt ist
und so diesen Verbranntgeruch nicht von irgendwas raus.
30 Jahre geraucht.
Also generell Gerüche. Weil auch diese Gerüche sind letzten Endes kommen von
irgendwelchen organischen Verbindungen.
Und das Ozon macht dem den Gar aus.
Das heißt, du stellst dann dieses Ding in dein Fahrzeug oder das geht natürlich auch in Zimmern.
Also auch wenn du jetzt ein Zimmer hast mit Schimmel oder aus welchen Gründen
auch immer, dass da mies drin riecht, dann könnte das sein, dass das eben hilft.
Die Geräte sind günstig.
Und du machst es halt an und musst natürlich dann dafür sorgen,
ganz klar, dass dann halt auch alle Schotten dicht sind, weil Ozon ist dann
halt lebensgefährlich.
Also du machst es halt an, um den Bio-Hazard da zu installieren und alles,
was bio ist, den gar auszumachen.
Ja, das sollte man nicht einatmen.
Das heißt, nachdem man da Ozon ausgestrahlt hat und im Idealfall quasi die ganze
Luft des Raumes gesättigt ist oder jeglicher Sauerstoff in Ozon umgewandelt wurde,
dann sollte man das für sich ein,
zwei Stunden ruhen lassen. Mindestens kann man natürlich auch länger.
Also ich habe da alles gehört von Bedienungsanleitung, sagt eine Stunde reicht
und andere haben gesagt, ich habe dann erstmal drei Tage das Auto stehen lassen,
weil kann nur besser werden.
Und dann musst du halt ordentlich lüften und das Ozon langsam raus.
Naja, das Ozon baut sich ja auch ab, weil es so reaktiv ist.
Also wenn es nicht mehr nachproduziert ist, dann ist es irgendwann auch wieder weg.
Ja, better safe than sorry, sage ich nur, aber es hinterlässt dann sagen wir
mal seinen eigenen Geruch, also es riecht dann halt nach Ozon und das ist dann
auch nicht gleich sofort wieder weg,
aber du ersetzt den einen Geruch durch den anderen und irgendwann….
Wie ist das irgendwie mit Lebensmitteln, wenn man es also beispielsweise in
der Küche einsetzen wollen würde?
Die kannst du danach vergessen.
Weil das ist genau das, wo es so gegen vor geht.
Also sollst du mal das tunlichste nicht in deiner Küche anziehen.
Nein, nein, das ist jetzt nicht so, oh, es riecht nicht so gut in der Küche,
ich mach mal hier Ozon an.
Dann kannst du halt alle Lebensmittel komplett wegschmeißen und sollst auch
keine Haustiere in der Nähe haben und so weiter.
Das ist halt, sagen wir mal, für leere Zimmer oder Zimmer, von denen du weißt,
dass da nur noch Todzeug drin ist.
Ja, mal so als Produkttipp unseres modernen Lebens.
Die zwangsläufige Frage natürlich irgendwie Umweltbelastung,
das heißt also, wie viel trägt man dann zur Entstehung des Ozonlochs bei oder
verbleibt das alles in Erdnähe, weil nicht nach oben so flüchtigt?
Also erstens, wie ich bereits sagte, es ist relativ reaktiv,
deswegen löst es sich halt auch relativ schnell auf.
Und das heißt deswegen hast du halt Ozon ja auch nicht normal in der Atmosphäre.
Weil Du machst da O3 und das trennt sich dann danach in O2, also normale Sauerstoffmoleküle
und dann hast du ein einzelnes O und das ist halt das Reaktive.
Das ist brutal reaktiv.
Und das schmeißt sich dann halt auf die ganzen organischen Verbindungen und
macht denen den Gar aus. Das ist sozusagen der Effekt. Also das Ozon an sich verschwindet.
Da bleibt halt erstmal irgendwas übrig, was vielleicht sich noch nicht verbunden
hat und das riechst du dann so ein bisschen noch nach, aber ist dann weg.
Also das verbleibt nicht.
Spannend, das mag man mal brauchen können. Ich habe ja meine vorletzte Wohnung,
war eine Schimmelwohnung, wo wir also in diversen Stellen einen erheblichen
Schimmelbefall an den Wänden hatten.
Da hilft das natürlich dann wieder nichts, weil das Problem liegt dann halt
in der Mauer und in irgendwelchen undichten Leitungen und im Keller und weiß der Geier wo.
Ja, meistens auch an Kältebrücken. Also es ist ja feucht, deswegen,
weil da eine kalte Stelle ist und sich da Feuchtigkeit aus der Luft absetzt.
Und solange das nicht warm ist, das nicht irgendwie regelmäßig warm kriegst,
bleibt das halt eine Schimmelstelle.
Ja, damals auch mit diversen Baumaßnahmen wurde alles Mögliche versucht.
Das ist ein ziemlich hoffnungsloser Kampf, so zumindest Erdgeschoss-Altbau.
Ein Nebeneffekt von solchen Maßnahmen ist natürlich, dass du dann in so einen
Putzfibbel kommst und dann möchtest du natürlich auch dein Auto so richtig sauber
haben und fährst dann erstmal in die Waschstraße und holst den dicken Staubsauger raus.
Habe ich auch gemacht, bin leider bei einer Waschstraße mit etwas mangelhaften
Saugkraft bei ihren Staubsaugern gelandet. Deswegen ist da noch einiges zu tun.
Aber da bin ich dann irgendwie so in dieses so, da muss es doch auch Leute geben, die sowas macht.
Und da bin ich dann auch noch auf einen anderen Begriff gestoßen,
der mir so bisher noch nicht bekannt war, der natürlich wenig überraschend aus
den USA kommt, nämlich das Detailing.
Detailing, ja.
Hast du schon mal gehört?
Ja, ich habe auch schon YouTube-Videos zu dem Thema gesehen,
wo Leute also nicht nur das selber machen, sondern sowas halt auch.
Also da gibt es ja YouTuber, die machen das beruflich und zeigen dann vorher,
nachher und wie sie das zubekommen.
Das hat ja was Unglaubliches, Beruhigendes. Also ich habe generell eine große
Vorliebe für so Reinigungsprozesse.
Anderen Leuten beim Arbeiten zugucken.
Ja, wenn sie das vor allem auf eine unterhaltsame Art und Weise tun.
Ja, das stimmt.
Wobei es da unterschiedliche Skalierungen gibt.
Also wo ich zum Beispiel große Freude habe, ist so Rohrreinigung.
Rohrreinigung ist definitiv so ein richtiges Scheiß-Thema.
Ja, aber ich meine, das ist die Realität. Die Klos sind verstopft.
Irgendwie nichts fließt mehr ab. Die Suppe läuft ja irgendwie über.
Und viele Leute denken das erste Mal überhaupt über das Thema nach,
dass das, was sie da die ganze Zeit reinspülen, ja aber auch irgendwo wieder rauskommen muss.
Und das ist dann vielleicht mal nach ein paar Jahren dann eben auch nicht mehr
rauskommt. Und wie wirst du das dann los?
Da habe ich dann viel gelernt über Rohrreinigung und ich finde das sehr beruhigend,
Leuten bei der Arbeit zuzuschauen. Und es gibt dann so verschiedenste,
wenn wir jetzt gerade bei den YouTube-Kanälen sind, da gibt es dann so verschiedenste Ansätze.
Da gibt es dann so die Leute, die also wirklich, sagen wir mal so,
im Wesentlichen von ihrer Arbeit berichten und dann auch wirklich akribisch
so diesen Debugging-Prozess mit, man kommt irgendwo hin, nichts fließt mehr ab, wo ist das Problem?
Wie findest du überhaupt erstmal die Stelle, wie gehst du dann dabei, etc.
Und dann gibt es auch Leute, die machen da so eine richtige Kirmes draus.
Da fühlst du dich irgendwie sofort zu Hause, weil einfach die Typen so schräg
sind. Und da ist jetzt mein Tipp.
Der Podcast hat jetzt schon eine komische Wendung genommen.
Letztes Mal Scheiß-Thema, dieses Mal Schimmel, jetzt Rohrreinigung.
Alles muss raus.
Alles.
Da muss mal Grund rein.
Scheiße.
Naja, also Ja, es ist ein reinigender Prozess, der hier stattfindet Ja.
Es ist Katharsis Also.
Wer Lust hat mal in die wundersame Welt der Rohrreinigung einzusteigen und dabei
auch Spaß haben will und sich auch automatisch gleich Teil einer Community zu
fühlen Mein Tipp für heute, ich hab großen Spaß mit dem Herrn.
Drain Cleaning Australia,
Und Bruce, der Rohrreiniger aus Australien, aus Westaustralien bei Perth,
ist einfach, das ist jemand, der liebt nicht nur seinen Beruf, der lebt seinen Beruf.
Das ist für ihn einfach, er kann sich überhaupt nicht vorstellen,
irgendetwas anderes zu tun als das und bemitleidet fast Leute,
die einfach im Büro sitzen müssen, weil he is living the dream.
Es ist grandios. Drain Cleaning Australia, meine Empfehlung,
wenn ihr Spaß haben wollt mit Rohrreinigung.
Aber ich wollte ja eigentlich aufs Reinigen der Autos zurückkommen und habe
festgestellt, Detailing is a thing.
Und das gibt es tatsächlich hier auch in Deutschland. Habe ich jetzt noch nicht
als Dienstleistung in Anspruch genommen, finde aber dann teilweise so das Detail,
mit dem dieses Detailing betrieben wird, wirklich bemerkenswert.
Also es gibt ja so Leute, die machen einfach nur sauber.
Aber dann gibt es halt auch Leute, die also mit einer Akribie diese Fahrzeuge
wieder aufbereiten, dass wenn du sie zurückbekommst, sie im Prinzip so sind,
als wie sie aus dem Verkaufsraum kommen.
Also wo sie dann wirklich nur noch nach dem Original Kunststoff riechen.
Huckel hatte doch mal sowas für sein Motorrad machen lassen.
Hat er irgendwann mal erzählt, dass er da beim Händler war und er meinte,
sagt mal die Maschinen, wenn ihr die verkauft, Auch wenn die sagen,
die sehen ja perfekt aus und so, könnt ihr das auch mal bei meiner machen.
Ja, ja, kostet so und so viel.
Und dann war er sehr happy, dass das Motorrad...
Genau, und da denke ich auch drüber nach, weil dieser ganze Grind,
der sich da so mit der Zeit ansammelt, der ist auch irgendwie verstörend.
Weil wenn es nie so richtig sauber ist, dann lohnt es sich auch nicht, es zu putzen.
Also du musst es erstmal in so einen Urzustand wieder zurückbringen und dann
macht es auch mehr Spaß, diesen Zustand möglichst beizubehalten.
Während wenn du immer nur so nachschaufelst und dann ist es irgendwie immer
noch dreckig, weil du dann nicht genug Zeit hast oder nicht genug Energie oder
nicht die richtigen Tools, dann macht es ja auch irgendwie keinen Spaß.
Man merkt aber auch, dass eure Kinder halt aus einem gewissen Alltag raus sind.
Wenn ich in dieses grundgereinigte Pfad meinen Fünfjährigen reinsetze,
dann hält dieser Zustand ziemlich exakt 30 Minuten.
Ziemlich da, wo du gestartet bist. Ich spreche aus Erfahrung.
Ja, das ist in der Tat eine Phase im Leben, wo man da eine gewisse Distanz zu entwickelt. gilt.
Ich verstehe das auch, dass du dann mit dem Scheiß-Thema.
Ich weiß nicht, was du da fordert wirst.
Weil das hast du dann wirklich quasi...
Genug gesehen.
Okay, das ist so eine Art Anti-Detailing dann.
Okay.
Ja, was ist in dem Kontext, das musste ich auch erst lernen,
hat mir auch Claudia rausgesucht, mobile Autoreinigung.
Die kommen bei dir quasi einfach vor die Tür, wo dein Auto parkt und,
waschen das sowohl von außen, als auch machen halt gründliche Innenraumreinigung
und du musst aber halt nicht irgendwo hinfahren und irgendwie sonst was anwerfen
und sie haben den Claim, also die, die wir jetzt hier hatten,
war Tiger Wash, es gibt aber mehrere,
dass sie deutlich umweltschonender sind, als wenn du in eine normale Waschstraße
oder sowas reinfährst, weil das also nur drei bis vier Liter Wasserverbrauch
ohne Chemie und das Ergebnis war hübsch, also es gibt mittlerweile echt ja für
alles irgendeine Dienstleistung.
Tiger Steam Teamwash oder was?
Genau, das haben wir in der Tat gemacht und dann freut man sich leider den ganzen
Tag darüber, wie schön sauber das Auto ist.
Und die kommen vorbei. Die kommen vorbei, genau.
Aber man darf doch sein Auto auf der Straße gar nicht waschen.
Naja, die schon, weil halt nichts den Boden quasi erreicht.
Das heißt also, die haben dort so Dampfapparaturen, wo sie alles gleich absaugen
wieder, was sie dort produzieren.
Ja, das ist so etwas, was man in diesen Detailing-Videos oft sieht,
dass also so mit heißem Dampf gemacht wird und dann halt natürlich auch diese
Nasssauger und so weiter.
Genau, die gehen also nicht mit einem Kärcher drauf, sondern Spezialapparaturen.
Das bringen die halt alles mit und erkundigen sich halt vorher,
wie viel Platz haben wir da links und rechts.
Also die brauchen halt schon natürlich ein bisschen Arrangiermasse.
Das heißt also, wenn du schon kaum noch die Tür aufkriegst, dann ist es natürlich
schwierig, aber solange du die Tür normal aufkriegst, reicht denen das.
das also wenn du so ein parkplatz irgendwo in der umgebung hass kommen die bei dir vorbei okay und.
Und, was kostet das so?
Äh, es geht. Irgendwie Außenreinigung war irgendwie 69 Euro und Innenreinigung,
da war allerdings auch alles wirklich echt desaströs.
Das ging irgendwie an die 100 Euro, was die hatten.
Die Adresse ist geil, ist direkt bei mir um die Ecke.
Ja, guck. Aber dafür haben sie dann aber auch irgendwie irgendwas über eine
Stunde halt sich da, oder anderthalb Stunden, glaube ich, sogar außen plus innen abgearbeitet.
Wie viel sagtest du?
Außen war, glaube ich, steht hier auf der Seite, Außen war 69 Euro und Innenraum irgendwie 100 Euro.
Je nach Wagengröße.
Genau.
Okay, aber das ist so.
Und angesichts unseres Verschmutzungsgrades im Innenraum kamen sie dann irgendwann
ganz schüchtern an und meinten, wir müssen nochmal über den Preis sprechen.
Von der Größe her sei es ja nicht so wild, aber das wird ja schon, also.
Es geht eher in Richtung Intensivreinigung.
Es wurde dann eine Intensivreinigung.
Dein Sohn hat die ganze Arbeit geleistet.
Naja, ich habe halt zwei Racker da und das ist dann schon ein wildes Potenzial, was sich da entfaltet.
Okay, also wenn die sagen Intensivreinigung, Innenraum, dann meinen die das auch.
Ich würde vermuten, dass es noch nicht jetzt den Grad erreicht,
den du hier mit deinen Detailern hast.
Aber das war schon, das geht deutlich über das hinaus.
Weiß ich nicht, das ist ja hier auch so in diesem Preisrange,
also ob die sich Detailer nennen oder nur Innenraumreinigung,
also ich glaube am Ende ist das genau das Gleiche.
Also es war deutlich besser als das, was ich jetzt irgendwie hier mit dem Staubsauger
in der Tankstelle erreiche.
Also auch die ganzen Sachen dann, die ganzen Armaturen alle vernünftig irgendwie
aufpoliert und so. Also das sah dann schon wirklich sehr, sehr gut aus, der Innenraum.
Also die, die sich Detailer nennen, die haben halt irgendwie so Sportwagen auf
ihrer Homepage, um damit zu werben.
Ja, meine Karre ist halt 20 Jahre alt. Die sieht dann halt auch aus wie 20 Jahre.
Aber das kriegst du dann da auch mit der besten Politur nicht mehr so richtig.
Ist halt so.
Alright.
Gut, weitermachen.
Wer möchte?
Was haben wir denn noch so? Ach ja, das ist doch ganz hübsch.
Wann habt ihr denn zum letzten Mal über das alte Rom nachgedacht?
Nachgedacht auf welche Art und Weise? Wie es da so ist?
Völlig egal. Hauptsache nur über das alte Rom nachgedacht.
Das ist bestimmt häufiger vorgekommen in der letzten Zeit. Ich hatte gerade
vor zwei Tagen über das Kolosseum tatsächlich nachgedacht.
Also ich muss jetzt mal dazu sagen, ich hatte fünf Jahre Latein in der Schule.
Sehr gut. Gallia est omnis divisa in patis tresquam, unam incolunt belge,
aliam aquetani, terciam quipsorum, lingua celtri, nostri gallia plantur.
Richtig. Heißt was? Caesar de bellum Gallicum.
Das ist der erste Abschnitt vom gallischen Krieg von Caesar.
Jeder, der Latein gemacht hat, muss das lernen.
Wie war das Gallien?
Ich kann das nicht nur mit Altgriechisch kontern.
Ja, aber das nehmen wir ja gut. Der humanistische Podcast.
Andra oene, Pemusa, Polyptrobron, Osmalapol.
So nämlich.
Ja, so sind wir.
Gallien ist in drei Teile aufgeteilt.
Fress das, ihr YouTuber.
Weiß ich nicht mehr genau.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was es heißt, aber es ist der Beginn der Odyssee.
Aurea prima satast. Das war Ovid.
Lass uns wieder zu Deutsch zurückkehren. Und was mit Rom denn nun so auf sich hat?
Also mit Rom tatsächlich, Also es ist so, dass ich das sich.
Durchaus… Meinst du Rom die Stadt oder Rom das Römische Reich?
Ne, das alte antike Römische Reich plus Rom als Stadt und Kolosseum und whatever.
Also ich denke öfter darüber nach, weil mich diese Zeit generell fasziniert,
weil sie schon so einen hohen Grad an Ingenieurskunst und an gesellschaftlicher Ordnung gelegt hat.
hat die Ursprung unserer Sprache in vielerlei Hinsicht darstellt etc.
Rechts ist eben.
Ja, ja, da ist einiges dabei.
Das haben die Römer jemals gesagt.
Jemals, genau.
Das Aquädukt, genau. Nee, also es ist tatsächlich so, dass ich einige History-Sachen
auf YouTube abonniert habe und jetzt neulich auch was gehört habe.
Zum Thema Richard Carrier, ich weiß nicht, ob dir der Name was sagt.
Nee.
Der wurde bekannt dadurch, dass
er quasi ein Standardbuch zum Thema den mythischen Jesus geschrieben hat.
Und da drin mehr oder weniger, also es ist ein wissenschaftliches Paper auf 600 Seiten.
Und er kommt zu dem Schluss, es ist wahrscheinlicher, dass es ihn nicht gegeben
hat, als dass es ihn gegeben hat. Die Wahrscheinlichkeiten sind nicht gut,
aber es ist ein bisschen unwahrscheinlicher, dass es ihn tatsächlich als historische Person gegeben hat.
Egal, ich habe halt in einem Podcast neulich ein Interview über ihn gehört,
wo er sehr stark darüber spricht,
wie sich die Demokratie in der griechischen Antike von der Demokratie in der
römischen Antike unterscheidet.
Und wie viel von dem, was die Demokratie in der römischen Antike an Errungenschaften
hatten, sich dann hinterher in der Verfassung der Vereinigten Staaten wieder
gefunden hat. Ich weiß nicht, das ist jetzt eine lange Antwort.
Aber ihr seid offensichtlich voll die Zielgruppe. Habt ihr nämlich mitbekommen,
dass es vor rund einem Jahr einen TikTok-Trend gab?
Vor einem Jahr? Das ist ja quasi Antike bei TikTok.
Die Antik-Tocke. An TikTok, ja.
Frühjahr 23 gingen also TikTok-Videos viral von im Wesentlichen Ehefrauen und
Frauen, die sich über ihre Typen lustig machen, wie häufig die übers römische Reich nachdenken.
Themen, wo man sich fragt, what the fuck, wie kommt man da überhaupt drauf?
Und dann ging es also dann wirklich halt viral, dass also jetzt einfach Frauen
ihre Typen gefragt haben und Kamera drauf gehalten haben, sag mal,
wie oft denkst du eigentlich über das römische Reich?
Und so, naja, ein paar Mal täglich schon.
Und die Damen das also 0,0 nachvollziehen können.
Ich habe damals schon etwas etwas bezweifelt, dass das Ganze irgendwie empirisch haltbar ist.
Und was davon irgendwie gestaged war. Und ob das jetzt wirklich ein Massenphänomen
war. Aber immerhin eure Reaktion.
Niemand würde bei TikTok irgendwas stagen.
Trotzdem, das ging halt vor einem
Jahr rum. Und man hat irgendwie klar vor Augen, was dann passiert ist.
Roland Emmerich, unser Mann in Hollywood, wir erinnern uns, der im Schwabenländle
groß geworden ist und dann relativ früh nach Hollywood abgereist ist,
um dort endlich mal die großen Blockbuster-Filme zu machen.
Was er, muss man ja sagen, dann auch mal wirklich geschafft hat. Independence Day.
Kleine Filme macht er nicht.
Day After Tomorrow 2012. Alle solche Geschichten hat er da gemacht.
Und ich muss sagen, ich habe eine gewisse Schwäche für Emmerich.
Ich mag irgendwie so diese Der ist so schön untreiwillig komisch.
Diese Grundprämissen und er hatte auch schon irgendwie so ein paar schräge Ideen
drin und ich finde, er hat vor allen Dingen Kino schon ganz gut verstanden.
Das ist also ein gewisser Flow, ein gewisses Tempo, eine gewisse epische Anlage
irgendwie für Dinge brauchst.
Naja, der hat das also mitbekommen und hat sich gesagt, oh, Rom,
prima, lass uns mal eine Serie drüber machen.
Also ganz so war es dann nicht. Es funktioniert auf der Zeitlinie leider nicht,
aber es gibt jetzt auf Amazon Prime,
Eine Serie über das alte Rom von Roland Emmerich, Regisseur,
nämlich Those About to Die, also Morituri,
die Salutan, wobei der zweite Teil schon weg, auch wieder ja unter uns Lateinern, ja Morituri,
also Those About to Die, das ist also die gnadenlose Effizienz der lateinischen
Sprache, die also vier englische Worte in ein einziges lateinisches gießen können.
Naja, so effektiv ist Englisch ja nun auch nicht.
Die Grammatik ist ja schon schick von Latein. Wie auch immer,
diese Serie gibt es jetzt also auf Amazon Prime.
Und da ich auch ganz viel über das römische Reich nachdenke,
hat mich das in der Tat interessiert.
Und ich bin angetan, muss ich sagen.
Das ist eine interessante Serie, weil die hat sich eben nicht emmerig ausgedacht,
sondern der eigentliche Showrunner ist Robert Roddard, ich weiß nicht,
wie man den ausspricht, oder Roddard, Robert Roddard, keine Ahnung.
Das ist der, der Saving Private Ryan geschrieben hat.
Also der hat schon ein bisschen was auch seriöseres zu verantworten und das
Ganze basiert auf einem Tatsachen-Sachbuch aus,
ich glaube irgendwie den 80er Jahren unter dem Titel auch Those About To Die,
wo die Historie der Gladiatoren-Spiele im Laufe der Jahrhunderte des römischen
Reiches so ein bisschen durchdekliniert wird.
Und da haben sie sich jetzt quasi eine Zeitscheibe rausgesucht,
nämlich das sogenannte Flavianische Zeitalter.
Der wird dann auch von Dennis, nee, von, wie heißt er hier, Schweigender Lämmer.
Anthony Hopkins, genau, gespielt. Der alternde Kaiser mit seinen beiden Söhnen,
die dann irgendwie in Nachfolgestreitigkeiten geraten und das Ganze dann halt
als letzte Maßnahme wird dann das Kolosseum gebaut.
Das heißt also, Tim, wenn dich die Geschichte des Kolosseums interessiert,
wäre diese Serie auch was für dich, weil es entsteht nämlich genau in diesem Zeitalter.
Und ich finde, da kommen ganz erstaunliche Komponenten zusammen bei dieser Serie,
weil es zum einen wenn halt inhaltlich gar nicht mal so over the top ist und
so fern von dem, wie wir heute annehmen, dass es damals funktioniert hat.
Also auch wie diese ganzen Geldkreisläufe rund um die Spiele dort funktioniert
haben, welchen Star-Status dort die einzelnen Kämpfer oder Wagenlenker hatten.
Im Kern stehen also Wagenrinnen bei der ganzen Geschichte.
Die 3D-Ansichten von Rom sollen wohl die exaktesten sein, die es bisher zu sehen gibt.
Das heißt also so, wie genau ist das Stadtbild aus der Zeit abgebildet,
wie fühlt sich auch gerade so dieser ganze Unterschichtenbereich an,
wie leben die Leute, wie ist die Ausstattung.
Also da wurde mehr Attention to Detail rangegeben, als man bei Roland Emmerich
ansonsten vielleicht so vermuten würde.
Und es hat in der Tat einen interessanten, coolen Cast, unter anderem einen
meiner Lieblingsdarsteller, nämlich den Ivan Rian.
Das ist ein Herr, den kennt man vor allen Dingen aus Game of Thrones,
wo er den Superverrückten gespielt hat.
Ich weiß gar nicht, welche Rolle hat der da, wie hieß der, war das Theon,
muss mal eben gucken, Television, haben wir hier Game of Thrones,
Ramsey Bolton, genau, das war
der komplett Verrückte, der irgendwie die Leute gehäutet hat und sowas.
Das war seine zweite Rolle von, also bei Game of Thrones war es schon seine
zweite Rolle von so einem Außenseiter-Typen, der einen Dachschaden hat.
Zum ersten Mal habe ich den gesehen in Misfits. Kennt ihr die Serie? The Misfits?
Englische, ich glaube BBC-Serie.
Die ist auch cool. Das ist, wenn man The Boys gut findet, was jetzt gerade so
Superhelden quer gestrichen ist.
Ist das auch nochmal eine interessante
Variante davon, weil das quasi Superhelden quer gestrichen ist?
Was heißt das?
Also The Boys, kennst du die Serie? Okay, gut. Also du kennst das Marvel Universe.
Ja, ja. Aus der Ferne. Aus der Ferne. Aber da gibt es so dieses...
Ich bin mehr so DC als Marvel, aber...
Okay, also gut, also, muss man hier wieder beim Bei dem Thema wird.
Es wirklich schwierig.
Okay, also The Boys nimmt halt dieses ganze Superhelden-Thema und dekliniert
es durch, wie es denn realistisch ablaufen würde. anfangen.
Wenn es wirklich Leute mit Superhelden gibt,
nämlich das werden alles Narzissten, die ihre Macht ausnutzen auf der einen
Seite und zum anderen werden sie in eine kapitalistische Verwertungslogik eingepasst
und das Ganze ist also ein einziges großes Geschäftsmodell.
Das ist also quasi die Grundprämisse von The Boys.
Schon ganz eindrücklich gemacht. Kann man sich mal den Piloten angucken.
Danach hat man, glaube ich, schon einen ganz guten Eindruck.
Und Misfits war früher, war deutlich
vor The Boys und dreht dieses Superhelden-Ding nochmal anders auf,
indem so eine Gruppe von fünf Versagern, die alle zur Sozialhilfe verdonnert
werden oder zur Community-Labor,
die plötzlich durch einen Unfall alle verschiedene Superhelden-Eigenschaften
bekommen und damit überhaupt nicht umgehen können und quasi da ihr Teenagertum dann umleben.
Aber gerade die ersten beiden Seasons sind sehr, sehr schön gemacht.
Da kann man auch seine Englischkenntnisse auf harte Proben stellen,
weil einer spricht so richtig, oder ein Nee, so richtig harten Cockney-Akzent.
Einer kommt aus Schottland. Also wenn man denkt, dass man gut Englisch kann,
dann mal in eine Folge Misfits reingucken.
Ich empfehle Trainspotting im Original.
Ja, so ungefähr. Noch breiter, weil plötzlich noch mehr Akzente nebeneinander
hast, nicht nur schottisch halt.
Also Misfits gute Sache und da hatte der schon eine fantastische Rolle von so
einem Typen, der auch schon so draußen war.
Und der spielt jetzt also die Hauptrolle in Those About To Die,
in dem er eben quasi ein Emporkömmling ist, der jetzt also in die oberen Gesellschaftssphären
von Rom aufsteigen will, darüber, dass er eben seine Wettgeschäfte und seine
ganzen Arena-Ambitionen irgendwie mal nach oben bringt.
Und das ist schon für das, was es eigentlich sein will, ungewöhnlich clever
und interessant erzählt.
Also ich würde sagen, das hat schon klare Game-of-Thrones-Qualitäten.
Aber es ist mehr...
Theater als Doku oder wie?
Also ich würde sagen, so vom Grundspirit her auch sowas, was das Verhältnis
von Action zu Dialogszenen angeht, ist es schon alles ziemlich ähnlich zu Game of Thrones.
Also du hast so Action-Pieces, die schon ganz interessant sind.
Wahrscheinlich nichts für mich.
Sicherlich irgendwie nicht wie bei Spartacus und du hast sehr,
sehr gute Dialog-Passagen. Also ich würde sagen, es ist gut geschrieben wirklich so.
Also es ist mehr eine Story.
Die Figuren sich entwickeln. Ja, das ist null Doku eigentlich am Ende des Tages.
Es passt alles ganz gut in die realen Vorkommnisse, aber am Ende des Tages ist
es auch komplett ausgedacht.
Nicht komplett ausgedacht, also ich würde sagen so 40 Prozent ausgedacht, 60 Prozent Realität.
Zum Thema Rom realistisch nachgebaut, die Frage, wie lange ist dein Commute?
Also wie lange brauchst du, um zur Arbeit zu kommen und wieder zurück?
Da brauche ich mit dem Fahrrad zehn Minuten.
Oh, das ist wenig. Also lustigerweise, es gibt jemanden, der hat das tatsächlich
mal wissenschaftlich untersucht und ist draufgekommen,
dass der typische Commute im antiken Rom zu Fuß zwischen einer halben und einer
Dreiviertelstunde ist.
Das heißt, seit 2000 Jahren hat sich das eigentlich nicht verändert,
wie lange die Leute irgendwie bis zu ihrem Job brauchen.
In Großstädten zumindest nicht.
Vielleicht noch ein abschließendes Wort der Warnung zu der Serie.
Die ist gerade im letzten Drittel nichts für zartbeseitete Gemüter.
Das heißt also gerade, wenn man so sagt, so okay, Game of Thrones,
Red Wedding, das war mir viel zu hart.
Das ist gegen das, was dann dahinter am Ende so passiert in den letzten drei
Folgen, ist das schon so eher so das Mittelmaß. Also da drehen sie ganz schön auf die Zwölf.
Ich finde das Täter auch nicht unbedingt nötig, dass sie da so extrem in Sachen
Torture-Porn letztendlich, würde ich das mal bezeichnen, irgendwie einsteigen.
Das schaue ich mir dann doch lieber eine Pompeji-Doku an.
Kommt übrigens auch vor, weil es auch genau in die Zeit reinfällt.
Also ich war ja in Pompeji im letzten November tatsächlich und habe mir das
mal alles in Ruhe angeschaut. Da habe ich sehr viel über Rom nachgedacht.
Ja.
Wie soll ich das nennen? Also du gehst da so durch diese Straßen,
es ist ja relativ viel übrig, also du siehst richtig,
du hast so eine harte Stadtstraßenstruktur mit irgendwie 90 Grad Winkelstraßenanordnung
und dann siehst du eben auch diese einzelnen Läden und vor allem dann siehst
du halt sehr viel so, naja,
so McDonalds, also Straßenfood.
Wo so halt in so Steintische, Kochstellen eingelassen sind, wo dann halt einfach
Essen gemacht wurde und dadurch beschleicht einem so das Gefühl,
wahrscheinlich hat sich so in den 2000 Jahren jetzt auch nicht so viel geändert.
Also man würde natürlich dann, wenn man da hingebeamt wird, die Sprache erstmal nicht verstehen.
Aber wenn man halt mit einem Bubblefish unterwegs ist und vielleicht andere Kleidungsprobleme.
Was? Das gab es auf dem Burger. Es waren keine Tomaten dabei.
Nein, Zwiebeln glaube ich auch nicht.
Weil die alle noch nicht so weit gezüchtet waren, wie wir.
Nein, weil die alle aus Asien sind und damals noch nicht kamen.
Obwohl Tomaten sind, glaube ich, vom amerikanischen Kontinent.
Aber die gab es im antiken Rom noch nicht.
Warst du dann auf dem Vesuv auch oben?
Kartoffeln auch nicht.
Vesuv war gesperrt.
Ja, weil also ich war vor sechs, sieben Jahren oder sowas in Pompeji,
Neapel, Vesuv und hatten dann als touristisches Highlight dann oben eben Vesuv-Besichtigung
und der war komplett in Wolken und in einem dermaßenen Umwetter,
dass du also nicht mal irgendwie durch den Regen da 20 Meter nach oben vernünftig laufen konntest.
Du hast also eine Sichtweite von irgendwie zwei Metern gehabt,
das war komplett pointless, das haben wir dann bleiben lassen.
Ja, es ist auch relativ viel Erdbebenaktivität da in den letzten Jahren.
Also es ist eine erhöhte Warnstufe.
Vulkan halt.
Es ist nicht so wie jetzt auf Sizilien da mit dem Ätna, der geht ja gerade wieder richtig steil.
Aber naja, irgendwann knallt es da halt auch mal.
Ich hoffe, ich bin da nicht dabei. Jetzt haben wir ja irgendwie ein großes Insekt.
Ein sehr großes Insekt. Jetzt hat er sich hinter dem Monitor versteckt.
Größer aus, als es ist.
Irgend so eine Wanze oder sowas. Schildwanze.
It's a bug.
Ich mache gleich den Ozongenerator.
It's a feature.
Okay, naja, so viel zu Rom. Vielleicht stimmt das auch. Vielleicht denken Männer
einfach mehr über Rom nach. Ich weiß aber auch nicht warum.
Es gab dann in der Tat ein paar Kulturwissenschaftler, die sich danach dessen
angenommen haben und deren Grundthese war halt, dass halt viele männliche Werte
halt auch damit verknüpft werden.
Also diese Effizienz der Legionen, wie gut strukturiert das alles war,
diese Ordnung, Klarheit,
Durchsetzungsfreude, das sind halt alles irgendwie erstmal maskuline.
Ähnliche Stereotype bedient es.
Vielleicht haben sich da auch nur ein paar Leute massiv trollen lassen.
Ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass das so einen gewissen Appeal ausmacht.
Was ich immer wieder spannend finde an Rome ist, okay,
das antike Rome ist jetzt 2000 Jahre her, trotzdem hatten die technologisch
sehr, sehr viel Kram, was man so auf den ersten Blick denen halt nicht zutrauen
würde. Und das finde ich das eigentlich Spannende daran.
Also man muss halt im Detail immer noch hingucken.
Über Pumpwerken, über diesen künstlichen See, den sie da angelegt haben,
diesen sechseckigen, achteckigen See neben Rom, das ist eigentlich ein Hafen,
der da gebaut wurde und lauter so ein Kram.
Toilettensysteme.
Toilettensysteme, die auch die Aquädukte sind, sind ja eigentlich super bei einem.
Man muss aber auch immer schauen, wie viel davon haben sie von den alten Griechen geklaut.
Also das ist immer nochmal ein Blick wert, was sie eigentlich nur eins zu eins
von den Griechen übernommen haben.
Die Aquädukte haben sie von den Griechen geklaut?
Nee, also einfach die Grundzüge des Rechtssystems, der Philosophie, Architektur.
Das ist am Ende eben alles nicht von den Römern erfunden, sondern von den Griechen erfunden.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Ein artes Ziel.
Ja.
Darin waren die Römer in der Tatsache. Und in Istanbul gibt es ja,
das war ja auch mal so, wie hieß es damals?
Konstantinopel? Ja, auch Byzanz. Oder Byzanz, genau.
Es war auf jeden Fall so ein römischer Outpost. Und die römische Outpost.
Das war das römische Reich, nach dem Westrom gefallen ist. Und zwar bis zum Ende des Mittelalters.
Byzanz ist der Grund, warum wir diese ganzen griechischen Schriften überhaupt noch haben.
Okay. Ich wollte einfach nur auf die konkrete Hinterlassenschaft in Istanbul hinaus.
Da war ich nämlich auch. Da habe ich auch viel über Rom nachgedacht.
Kaum denkt man mal drüber nach.
Naja, also ich muss mich jetzt gerade mal erinnern, wie heißt denn das da oben nochmal?
Und zwar haben die natürlich auch das Wasserproblem da ganz speziell,
weil durch Istanbul fließt ja kein Fluss.
Das liegt zwar an dieser Meeresenge, aber es wird halt nicht durch einen großen
Fluss versorgt. Wie das ja eigentlich normalerweise bei großen Städten üblicherweise
ist, dass der Fluss der Grund der Ansiedlung ist.
Aber hier war der Grund wohl eher strategisch, keine Ahnung,
die Berge, diese Meeresenge.
Es gab andere Gründe dort eine große Stadt zu machen.
Genau, militärisch-strategisch.
Und um militärisch-strategisch, genau, und um da die ganze Versorgung,
die ganze Wasserversorgung sicherzustellen, haben die Römer da so einiges hingebaut.
Unter anderem die großen Zisternen, das war glaube ich das Wort,
nachdem ich gerade gesucht habe.
Genau, jetzt muss ich mal kurz das mal anfliegen, um mich zu erinnern.
Wir fliegen wieder über Google Earth.
Das kann keiner sehen.
Das kann keiner sehen, aber das muss jetzt auch keiner sehen.
Auf jeden Fall gibt es da in Istanbul, da ist ja viel Stadt,
wirklich eine große Stadt, von der ich eigentlich nur das Geringste gesehen habe.
Aber dann gibt es halt da irgendwie einen großen Palast da oben auf dem Berg.
Und da liegen dann eben oben auf diesem Berg auch die Zisternen.
Und dort haben sie dann halt das Wasser, ich weiß nicht, wie haben sie dann
das Wasser nochmal hingeleitet? Auf solchen Aquädukten.
Aus den Bergen haben sie das da irgendwie hingeleitet und dann gibt es halt
so riesige Zisternen, die sie da in den Boden eingegraben haben,
also mit so Säulen 20 Meter hoch, da kann man dann so runtersteigen und es ist
einfach eine Unmenge an Wasser, die sie dort gespeichert haben.
Also es ist immer wieder krass, wie groß die gedacht haben.
Das finde ich bemerkenswert. Und deswegen denke ich immer wieder gerne an Rom.
Aber es ist wirklich mehr das und die männlichen Stereotype, weiß ich nicht.
Also dieses ganze Legionärsgedöns und so weiter und ihre Kriegstaktiken fand
ich jetzt nicht so inspirierend.
Nee, ehrlich gesagt finde ich die römische Armee selber auch nicht so spannend.
Echt, aber so eine Schildkröte, das ist also so ein Konzept schon.
Bei Asterix ist das super, aber ansonsten.
Aber nicht besonders effizient.
Katapulte und wenn ein Hannibal auf den Elefanten über die Alpen und so.
Ja, der ist aber nicht Römer.
Nein, der ist natürlich kein Römer, nein, nein.
Ach ja, gut.
Schön,
dass wir jetzt hier auch echt mal diese Humanismus-Schiene hier in diesem Kulturpodcast.
Wir können auch anders.
Wenn man jetzt noch Gaming in dieses Thema reinklinken will,
Assassin's Creed 2 und zwar von Assassin's Creed 2 der zweite und der dritte Teil.
Der zweite Teil spielt in Rom und der dritte in Istanbul, Byzanz, Konstantinopel.
Meiner Meinung nach wirklich ein Wiederspielen wert, obwohl Obwohl die jetzt,
glaube ich, auch schon über zehn Jahre alt sind.
Aber da kann man schön rumlaufen, sowohl in Rom.
Klar ist Rom jetzt in dem Zustand, in dem er in der Renaissance war,
aber trotzdem, man kann da auch im Kolosseum rumrennen und alles.
Gut. Nächstes Thema. Ich habe eine Suche, eine Anfrage.
Also ich denke über Urlaub nach.
Ja.
Ja. Und das ist ein bisschen schwierig, weil ich denke darüber nach,
Urlaub in Neuseeland zu machen.
Wird sehr empfohlen.
Genau, wird mir sehr empfohlen, wurde mir oft empfohlen. Alle Leute,
die ich kenne, die da hingefahren sind, haben es nicht bereut.
Und ich habe auch vor, das nicht zu bereuen, wenn ich es denn mal tue.
Nun wissen wir alle, Neuseeland ist relativ weit weg.
Da muss man schon das Innere von Flugzeugen sehr gern haben.
Das ist, glaube ich, der am weitesten entfernte Ort von Deutschland.
Genau, das ist im Prinzip genau auf der anderen Seite der Kugel.
Also wenn du jetzt nicht in die Antarktis fliegst wahrscheinlich, ja.
Naja, es ist tatsächlich auf
der anderen Seite der Kugel. Also es ist uns diametral entgegengesetzt.
Also Nadel durch die Mitte und so weiter. Wenn du durch deine Erdkugel-Voodoo-Puppe
deine Nadel durchstößt, dann landest du da so akupunkturell in Neuseeland.
Naja, auf jeden Fall muss man glaube ich wenig Worte darüber verlieren welchen
Reiz so Neuseeland auf einen ausüben kann,
wissen wir ja alle, schönes Land und kulturell sehr zugänglich und ja,
Ich muss das irgendwie planen. Also ich denke halt darüber nach,
da länger zu sein und nicht nur so für zwei Wochen oder so hinzufahren,
sondern da mal ein paar Monate zu sein, um dann auch mal alles mitzunehmen und
auch mal so richtig abschalten zu können.
Das ist glaube ich auch die unterschiedlichen Areale da sehr unterschiedlich.
Genau, du hast halt so den Strand
im Norden und dann ist es irgendwie da Sonnenschein, Pipapo. Apropos.
Herr der Ringe ist glaube ich nicht so deins, ne? Die Filme,
die Locations, sich da in echt anzugucken.
Das wäre voll mein Ding. Wahrscheinlich nicht drumherum kommen.
Ich habe jetzt nicht so ein Ding am Laufen mit Herr der Ringe,
aber ich habe auch überhaupt nichts dagegen.
Also ich finde das alles ganz toll, die Filme so.
Aber ich kann die nicht alle auswendig runterzählen und welcher Elf da jetzt,
welchem Org in welcher Szene eins auf den Nuss gegeben hat, das weiß ich alles nicht.
Aber die Landschaftsaufnahmen waren gut in dem Film.
Ja, ja, natürlich. Ja, das ist natürlich klar. Und ich meine,
es ist ja auch bekannt, dass Neuseeland quasi alles zu bieten hat.
Also wie gesagt, von Strand bis wirklich krasse Bergregionen von Norden nach
Süden ist da ja alles zu holen.
Und es bietet sich natürlich vor allem deshalb an, hier dem kalten Berlin zu
entschwinden, weil dann ist es ja da warm.
Also in unserem Winter, in den dortigen Sommer.
Das ist der Plan, genau. Und es gibt so verschiedene Ideen, die ich so verfolge.
Also ich würde gerne natürlich die Zeit nutzen, meine Podcasts natürlich aus
der Ferne weiter machen, aber vielleicht dort auch selber noch einen Podcast
machen quasi auf dieser Reise.
und da bin ich so ein bisschen auf der Suche nach Hörerinnen und Hörern aus,
Neuseeland. Bitte melde dich.
Ich weiß, dass es euch gibt, weil ich hatte schon früher mal Kontakt.
Es gibt diverse Experts und so weiter und wenn ihr das jetzt gerade hört und
ihr seid irgendwie aus Neuseeland und ihr meint irgendwelche Tipps,
Ratschläge oder sonst so wie,
was geben zu können, was mir in irgendeiner Form diese Reise,
ermöglichen oder leichter machen könnte, dann I'm open for it.
Am allerliebsten würde ich gerne dieses ganze Land mit so einem Wohnmobil bereisen.
Habe ich auch schon mal so ein bisschen geguckt. Es gibt so ja mittlerweile
diese ganzen private Wohnmobil Vermietungen und so weiter, bloß so für so einen langen Zeitraum.
Kostet auch ein bisschen, also Kosten muss man natürlich auch noch mal ein bisschen
in den Blick kriegen, aber es geht jetzt erstmal nur darum,
auf Ideen zu kommen, Orte zu haben, wo man vielleicht mal andocken könnte,
aus der sich in irgendeiner Form so eine Kette der Ereignisse ergeben könnte.
Und ja, dann schreibt mir doch einfach mal eine Mail, timmetmetaebene.me und dann gucken wir mal.
Ist ja noch ein bisschen Zeit, aber so Januar, Februar, März sind so ein bisschen
meine Kandidaten nach dem Kongress. Abhauen.
Ja, Neid.
Die Kongress-Seuche nach Australien tragen. Äh, nach Neuseeland tragen.
Psst, wo gerade schon wieder so viel Pandemie-Gerede ist, wollen wir damit gar
nicht erst anfangen, nicht, dass der Laden wieder zumacht.
Aber an der der angepasste Impfstoff kommt.
Ja, ach, das wird schon alles gut gehen. Ich bin da ganz zuversichtlich.
Okay, was haben wir noch auf der Uhr, wenn man so schön sagt.
Du wolltest noch ein bisschen über die Digital Legacy reden. Genau.
Das ist ein Thema, wo ich gar nicht so viele Antworten habe, aber viele Fragen.
Und vielleicht sind da draußen schlaue Menschen, die die ein oder andere dieser
Fragen beantworten können.
Wir haben ja eben schon die Frage geklärt, wie oft wir über das Römische Reich nachdenken.
Eine andere Frage ist so, wie oft denken wir eigentlich über uns selber nach
oder über das, wie wir...
Personen eigentlich repräsentiert werden in diesem Digitaluniversum.
Und ein Spielchen, was vermutlich die meisten von uns doch irgendwie zumindest
ab und an mal spielen, ist ja, ich google mal meinen eigenen Namen.
Und guck mal, was da so an Ergebnis irgendwie zurückkommt.
Ich nenne das Ego-Surfing.
Ego-Surfing, okay. Habe ich lange nicht gemacht, aber immer wenn ich das mache,
dann sieht das ganz so danach aus, als wäre ich der einzige lebende Mensch,
der diesen Vornamen hat.
Ja, also ich glaube, die Erfolgschancen steigen oder fallen sehr stark damit,
was man für einen Namen hat.
Das sehe ich auf jeden Fall auch so. So, auf jeden Fall so, wenn ich das mal
mit meinem Namen gemacht habe, dann waren die Ergebnisse eigentlich immer ganz
beruhigend und ich hatte den Eindruck, dass Google da im Großen und Ganzen schon
einen guten Überblick hat,
was ich in der Digitalsphäre eigentlich so alles treibe.
So und jetzt wissen wir ja, Large Language Models sollen, deren Use Case ist
nicht, eine Google-Suche zu ersetzen.
Trotzdem, die Leute da draußen tun es.
Ob man das jetzt irgendwie gut findet und ob man da jetzt irgendwie die Leute
warnt, Achtung, das sind keine Wissensmaschinen und das sind auch irgendwie
keine Auskunftsmaschinen für solcherlei Fragestellungen.
Es wird da draußen einfach passieren und Stichwort Apple Intelligence,
es wird alles eher mehr werden als weniger und von daher bin ich einfach vor
ein paar Wochen mal auf die Idee gekommen, was ist denn eigentlich,
wenn ich so eine klassische Frage zu meiner Person eigentlich mal ChatGPT stelle.
Was weiß dieses System denn eigentlich von mir und dem, was ich so tue?
Und ich habe das aber umgedreht, indem ich gesagt habe, nicht was weißt du jetzt
irgendwie über Ralf Stockmann, sondern ich habe die Frage gestellt,
ich nenne dir jetzt eine Reihe von Open Source Initiativen und Projekten und
baue mir daraus mal eine Tabelle mit den Spalten Name des Projektes,
kurze Beschreibung des Projektes, Gründungsjahr, die Person,
die man am ehesten als Gründer bezeichnen könnte und Ort der Entstehung.
So, und da habe ich reingefüttert als Projekte StutIP, Gobi,
Europeana 4D, Ultraschall für Podcasting, das Sendegate, das Sendezentrum und Masterwall.
Man ahnt, worauf es eigentlich hinauslaufen sollte.
Alle diese verschiedenen Initiativen innerhalb der letzten 24 Jahre habe ich
angeschoben, mehr oder weniger zentral.
Und das, was dann ChatGPT dort zurückgemeldet hat, war ein wenig ernüchternd,
um es vorsichtig zu sagen.
Ich habe dann die verschiedenen Modelle ausprobiert. Derzeit hat man ja im Wesentlichen
jetzt nur noch 4.0 und 4.0 zur Verfügung.
Das 3.5. haben sie jetzt schon abgeschaltet. Das ist quasi durch 4.0 mittlerweile ersetzt.
Die tun sich da überhaupt nichts.
Und von den 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 Projekten, die ich reingegeben habe,
wird also einzig und allein Ultraschall einigermaßen richtig spezifiziert.
Alle anderen falsch. Mal als Beispiel, StudIP, kurze Beschreibung,
Lernmanagementsystem, das
in Deutschland vor allem an Hochschulen eingesetzt wird, das ist korrekt.
Gründungsjahr 2001, ist falsch, war 1999, aber da würde ich mal sagen close enough.
Person am ehesten als Gründer bezeichnen, Professor Carsten Morris.
Wer zum Teufel ist Professor Carsten Morris?
Ort der Entstehung, Universität Osnabrück, Deutschland. Falsches war Universität Göttingen.
Da geht es also dann schon nicht so um die Feinheiten, sondern ist schon einigermaßen falsch einfach.
So kann man jetzt also die verschiedenen Bereiche durchgehen.
Mal eben gucken, hier Masterwall hat also angeblich einen Peter Ullrich erfunden im Jahr 2018.
Ist also auch einfach mal frei erfunden.
Und also auch irgendwie Sendegate, das hast du also mit Philipp Banse zusammen gestartet.
Tim Pridloff plus Philipp Andichtskehm. Philipp, hallo, Grüße.
Verdienter Podcaster, hat aber nun mal ersichtlich mit irgendwie Sendegeld und
Sendezentrum nichts zu tun.
Das heißt also, all diese Informationen sind falsch. So, das heißt also,
wenn man jetzt dazu kommt und sich überlegt, okay, in einer nicht allzu fairen
Zukunft von fünf oder zehn Jahren werden LLMs, ob wir das jetzt gut finden oder
nicht, von den Leuten da draußen, TM,
als Suchmaschine genutzt werden.
Wie können wir denen denn eigentlich beibringen, dass unsere digitale Erinnerung
irgendwie einigermaßen korrekt ist?
und da grübele ich jetzt also schon ein paar Wochen drüber nach und ich komme
dort zu keinem sinnvollen Ansatz, der mir irgendwie praktikabel erscheint und
das macht mich etwas unglücklich,
weil also, das sind alles Pro Bono Projekte, kein einziges davon ist kommerziell,
da will man doch zumindestens irgendwie,
mal ein bisschen Attribution für haben, so dass es sich daran erinnert wird,
so okay, XY hat es erfunden Ja.
Aber warum erwartest du denn das ausgerechnet von so einem LLM?
Naja, all darüber wurde publiziert. Das heißt also, wenn man jetzt eine Google-Suche
macht, kommst du auf entsprechende Spuren suchen,
wo du irgendwelche Medienberichte, Wikipedia-Seiten, was auch immer hast,
wo man das raus her distillieren könnte. Bzw.
wenn das nicht der Fall ist, ist halt die Frage, okay, was kann jetzt eigentlich
ein Privatmensch da draußen tun, um den nächsten Generationen von LLMs zu helfen,
dort zu besseren Verbindungen und Informationen zu kommen.
Ich weiß nicht, machst du das gerade mit dir? Du starrst hier interessiert auf...
Lustig, dass du das so aufbringst, weil ich das eine Diskussion mit meiner Tochter
darum hatte und dann haben wir tatsächlich mal in das aktuelle Chat-GPT 4.0
einfach nur ein Wer ist Tim Pridloff eingegeben.
Und es war erstaunlich akkurat, diese vier Absätze, die da rauskamen.
Also sie waren komplett fehlerfrei und und ausreichend Lob rudeln,
dass ich das als Erfolg verbote.
So, der entscheidende Unterschied zwischen dir und mir ist welcher?
Was jetzt so Informations,
Dokumentation.
Du hast nicht nach dem Namen gesucht.
Ich bin etwas promisker mit dem Internet unterwegs als du.
Du hast einen Wikipedia-Eintrag.
Ja, das stimmt.
Weiß ich nicht, ob das der Unterschied ist.
Du hast doch auch einen. Nee, hab keinen.
Aber du hast einen Wikidata-Eintrag.
Das habe ich dann auch geschaut. Ich habe einen Wikidata-Eintrag.
Und dann dreht das Desaster seine weiteren Runden.
Da bin ich in der Tat drin verzeichnet, sogar mit meinem aktuell richtigen Titel.
Sprich, als Bibliotheksdirektor stehe ich da drin.
Aber beispielsweise einer falschen Institution. Nämlich immer noch...
Stabi Berlin und nicht ZLB Berlin. Das heißt irgendjemand, achso ja und ich
bin ein Opinion Journalist. Das ist quasi mein Hauptclaim.
Auch interessante Zuschreibung sagen wir mal.
Also letztendlich das was wir hier mit Journalist.
Also Deutscher Publizist heißt es hier auf Deutsch.
Ja.
Naja.
Erinnerst du dich?
Eben, das ist jetzt also die Frage.
Das ist die Frage?
Also irgendjemand hat mich als Library-Direktor eingetragen,
aber halt nicht wovon eigentlich. Das war also nicht von der richtigen Institution.
So und jetzt ist halt, also meine Frage ist, lohnt es beispielsweise jetzt viel
Zeit und Energie in die Modellierung eines vernünftigen Wikidata-Profils zu investieren?
So und die Frage habe ich natürlich dann als erstes mal ChitGPT selber gestellt.
fließen in deine Trainingsdaten eigentlich Wikidata-Modellierungen ein.
Und da greifen natürlich diverse Schranken von ChatGPT, dass es natürlich keine
Auskunft darüber geben darf, was in seinem Trainingsmaterial drin ist,
beziehungsweise ist das wahrscheinlich selber gar nicht weiß, in Anführungszeichen.
Das ist halt Betriebsgeheimnis.
Mit so etwas verqueren Fragestellungen, so gibt eine Wahrscheinlichkeit an,
dass und so weiter, das sind ja so die gängigen Tricks, um dann trotzdem irgendwelche
einigermaßen plausiblen Mutmaßungen rauszukriegen.
Würde ich sagen, mit einiger Sicherheit ist Wikidata keine Datenquelle,
die dort in die Trainings reinfällt, weil es zu wenig quasi Semantik mitbringt.
Das war dann auch die Argumentation von ChatGPT selber.
Zu wenig Semantik? Naja, also Fließtext. Zu wenig Syntax.
Verknüpfung natürlich ohne Ende, aber eben halt nicht Im Rahmen eines Fließtextes.
Genau, also LLMs ernähren sich halt primär von Fließtext.
Genau.
Und das heißt aber nicht, dass sich nicht KIs, die solche Informationen auch
reproduzieren können, sich nicht trefflich mit so etwas füttern lassen.
Lassen sie sich. Also tatsächlich ist Wikidata eine hervorragende Quelle,
gerade in Zeiten, wo du eben auch Aussagen über die Daten leistest, liefern musst.
Das muss ja auch stimmen.
Das sagen wir so als Datenfans. Aber glaubst du ernsthaft, dass das OpenAI auch so sieht?
Was OpenAI jetzt dazu denkt, weiß ich nicht. Und es ist mir auch ehrlich gesagt
jetzt schnuppe. Es geht ja allgemein um LLMs, dann geht es ja jetzt nicht nur um OpenAI.
Naja, aber das ist das, was demnächst halt auf dem iPhone läuft, ne?
Nee, auf dem iPhone läuft Apple Intelligence und Apple Intelligence läuft halt
komplett anders. Da hast du halt eine LLM als Schaltzentrale.
Aber halt nicht für die allgemeinen Wissensfragen, die werden dann ja eben zu OpenAI weitergetun.
Ja, jetzt in dem ersten Release und so weiter. Ich glaube, dass wir in einer
sehr vergänglichen Zeit leben gerade.
Wir begleiten zwar jetzt seit einem Jahr die nächste große informatische Revolution. Resolution.
Aber so wie das Internet Anfang der 90er Jahre war und wenig zu tun hat mit
dem, was heute Realität ist, so ist es eben jetzt auch.
Also viel von dem, was wir heute als ist so annehmen, da lachen wir schon in
einem Jahr drüber. Und in fünf Jahren sowieso, weil dann ist das alles nochmal komplett woanders.
Das ist eine Ausprobierphase. Also ich habe Schwierigkeiten damit aus dem aktuellen
Zustand der Dinge irgendwelche Aussagen über wie es jetzt mal wird oder was
jetzt das Problem damit sein wird zu machen.
Also ich habe im anderen Kontext mich mal mit Wikidata-Leuten unterhalten.
Die hatten ja im Juni diesen Jahres ihr 20-jährige Wikimedia-Feier hier in Berlin.
Und da bin ich mal hingelaufen und habe die Frage gestellt, wie wir dort eigentlich
vom Föb-Bibliotheksdaten mal modellieren könnten. Also alleine was für Standorte,
also Verband öffentlicher Bibliotheken in Berlin hier.
Alleine sowas wie Standorte und Öffnungszeiten
findest du halt auch nicht vernünftig irgendwie in Wikidata.
Und da war meine Frage, also was wäre jetzt eigentlich mal ein vernünftiger
Workflow, um sowas da mal rein zu modellieren.
Und ich habe glaube ich an dem Abend mit fünf Leuten mich dort unterhalten aus
dem Projekt und jeder hat mich dann immer wieder an die nächste verwiesen und
ich hatte den Eindruck, dass die an so einer Spezialmodellierung gerade eigentlich
überhaupt kein Interesse mehr haben,
sondern dass die eigentlich nur noch an Konnektoren von anderen Datenbanken
und anderen Datenbeständen arbeiten und Interesse haben.
Und diese Ebene, so wir machen jetzt eine Handmodellierung von XY,
dass sie das überhaupt nicht mehr irgendwie auf dem Schirm haben,
dass das noch ein Anwendungsfall sein könnte.
Weil wir haben jetzt halt keine FAB-Datenbank, die man da dranhängen könnte.
Und genauso wenig gibt es jetzt halt hier für uns als einzelne Person irgendeine
Datenbank, die man da dranhängt.
Also, wenn da draußen jemand zuhört und ich das jetzt alles völlig ins falsche
Ohr bekommen habe, das heißt also, nein, Wikidata-Handmodellierung ist immer noch das totale Ding.
Und hier ist ein How-To, wie man das Das ist beispielsweise für Projekte.
Also auch diese ganzen Projekte, die sind halt nicht in Wikidata modelliert.
So könnte man ja mal machen. Aber wie macht man das? Entlang von welchen Guidelines?
Weil es halt jetzt nicht irgendwelche Gebäude oder Events sind,
sondern halt Projekte, Initiativen.
Also wir müssen, glaube ich, demnächst mal mal den Jens nochmal einladen,
der das Wikidata-Projekt ganz erheblich mit losgetreten hat und auch immer noch dabei ist.
Aber soweit ich weiß...
War es zumindest, stand vor zwei Jahren so, der Großteil der Daten,
der in Wikidata landet, kommt aus anderen Datenbanken.
Also dieses von Hand und so weiter. Ja, klar.
Du hast natürlich hier, wie der Name schon sagt, die Möglichkeit manuell nachzufeilen
und Datensätze wie zum Beispiel jetzt deinen auch mal der Realität anzupassen.
Also wenn ich jetzt hier mal schaue, hier sind deine Arbeitgeber benannt mit
Staatsbibliothek bis 31.
Dezember 23, Zentral- und Landesbibliothek ab 1. Januar 24, ist ja alles korrekt.
Ja, sozusagen deine und öffentliches Amt oder Stellung Bibliotheksdirektor, stimmt doch.
Ja, aber nicht die Einrichtung.
Wie, Zentral- und Landesbibliothek Berlin ist falsch?
Das steht da in meinem Datensatz hier nicht, den ich hier habe.
Arbeitgeber steht hier.
Ich lese nur Q112415597.
Ja, ist Employee Berlin State Library.
Ja, kannst du auch auf Deutsch umstellen. Im Übrigen, um es einfacher zu machen.
Hier ist deine Mastodon-Adresse, mehrere sogar.
und ja, ganz viele sonstige Kennungen hast du noch mehr als ich.
Warum hast du jetzt ZLB und ich nicht? Also ich habe jetzt den Link,
den ich hier in den Chat auch gepostet habe.
Der Link, den du auch in den Chat gepostet hast, ja.
Achso, na du solltest vielleicht mal diesen Mobile View ausschalten und mal
das M-Punkt da wegmachen, dann siehst du auch die volle Datenpracht.
Keine Ahnung, was das jetzt hier wieder begrenzt hat, aber,
da ist auf jeden Fall alles dabei. Also alle Aussagen. Und eine Aussage ist Arbeitgeber.
Ist hier immer noch Berlin State Library bei mir.
Was? Ja. Auf Englisch?
Auf Englisch, ja.
Aber das ist ja eigentlich kein Eintrag, der sprachabhängig sein sollte.
Dürfte es nicht sein.
Weiß ich gerade nicht, was du da siehst, weil ich sehe das hier sehr wohl.
Wo siehst du da ZLB?
Da, in der Mitte, was ich vorgelesen habe. Arbeitgeber drei Einträge.
Du hast doch da auch drei Einträge.
Ja, das ist dreimal Stabi.
Dann ist die ZLB falsch übersetzt.
Ah, Moment mal.
Ja, also das sind so Dinge, die gepflegt werden müssen. Du liest sozusagen eigentlich
das Richtige, aber die Übersetzung der ZLB ist wahrscheinlich falsch.
Da liegt der Hund im Pfeffer. Okay, na immerhin, wenigstens das.
Seit 1. Januar 2024, das stimmt sogar. Interessant, wer das da eingepflegt hat, aber ja, das stimmt.
Genau, es ist leider mit null Fundstellen dokumentiert, das könnte man natürlich
dann auch nochmal nachtragen.
Also Wikidata können ja noch weniger als Wikipedia bearbeiten und da ist es ja schon dünner.
aber grundsätzlich ist das schon mal eine ganz gute Basis ich würde mir ja auch
wünschen dass wir dann auf der Subscribe,
die Subscribe, die Podcast Konferenz, die da drüber kommt, wo ja alle euch unbedingt
ein Ticket besorgen müsst, ihr müsst echt alle kommen da müssen wir mal die
neue Datenwelt ausrufen, weil ich klare ja schon seit vielen, vielen Jahren,
aber auf mich hört ja immer keiner dass,
dass Wikidata nicht ernst genug genommen wird. Und gerade in der Podcast-Landschaft
finde ich das ja ganz wichtig, wo wir so viel über Themen und so weiter reden,
sollten wir das eben auch mit Wikidata machen.
Weil Wikidata ist quasi die Aussagelogik der Welt.
Also man kann das, glaube ich, gar nicht hoch genug aufhängen.
LLMs und so, das sind alles diffuse, suchende Matsch.
Da kann man irgendwie das Richtige finden oder auch nicht, aber es ist so Stecknadel,
Heuhaufen, Deluxe. Und Wikidata ist halt klar, für klare Fakten ist es halt einfach genau der Ort.
Alles was sich exakt beschreiben lässt, das kann man da wunderbar ablegen.
Aber Tim, du bist alt genug, um zu wissen, ja Recht haben hilft da aber nichts.
Das heißt also, wenn meine Theorie zustimmt, dass die Leute in fünf Jahren hauptsächlich
über LLMs suchen werden und die sich nicht Wikidata bedienen,
ist das herzlich egal, ob man dort die Wahrheit modiert hat oder nicht.
Die Welt ist auch darstellen. Und wenn du halt irgendwie Wikidata benutzt,
um deine Fakten darzustellen, wenn du deine Genres, deine Themen,
worüber du hier im Podcast gesprochen hast, mit einem Wikidata-Item verlinkst,
dann ist klar, worüber geredet wurde.
Und dann kannst du darüber nicht nur suchen, sondern du kannst es einfach anklicken
und dann kriegst du alles, was von diesem Typ ist.
Das ist mir schon alles klar. Stell mir beispielsweise die Frage,
müsste man den ganzen Kram mal auf LinkedIn modellieren?
Weil das beispielsweise viel eher eine Lernquelle von LLMs ist.
So und jetzt verziehst du die Augen, weil du sowas mit der Zange nicht anfassen
würdest, aber vielleicht muss man da halt mal so den harschen Realitäten ins Auge blicken.
Ja, ich meine, mir ist doch egal, was die anderen machen. Also es reicht doch,
wenn man selber das Richtige tut.
Das ist jetzt interessant.
Na, wieso? Irgendeiner muss doch damit anfangen. Also ich bin dann,
also mal ehrlich, dieses Thema, ich weiß, das ist jetzt so eine Nische,
aber dieses Thema Shownotes von Podcasts.
Du möchtest gerne eine Aussage darüber trainieren. Jetzt haben wir Transkripte.
Okay, da helfen uns natürlich jetzt die neuen KI-Algorithmen,
die so wunderbare Sprache erkennen und das dann verschriftlichen und das wird
jetzt irgendwie auch jede Stunde immer besser und so. Das ist schon mal super.
Also man kann jetzt wunderbar zusammenfassend suchen.
Es ist leider noch ein bisschen schwierig, diese LLMs so in die eigene Webseite
zu integrieren, um jetzt mal hier wirklich nur über die eigenen Podcasts suchen zu können.
Das würde ich mir nochmal wünschen.
Das kommt sicherlich bald auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise.
Trotzdem möchte ich es halt auch gerne mal schematisch haben.
Und ich möchte gerne nicht diffus auf eine Wikipedia-Seite verlinken,
sondern damit eigentlich eher auf die Wikidata-Informationen verlinken.
weil das dann klar ist weil du dann diese Ambiguität nicht hast weil es sich
dann nicht verwechselt ja, weil ich meine, wir wissen ja alle,
ich erlebe das ja täglich wenn ich hier einen Podcast veröffentliche und dann
irgendwie diese blöden Bilder generiere, ich meine okay ich weiß Leute,
ihr schaut so auch voll von dieser Optik und so weiter, ich tue alles dafür
dass die Optik passt aber die Alternative ist immer keine Bilder aber das ist immer ein.
Interessanter Prozess wie man dann immer in dieses System so rein...
quatschen muss und das ganze Gefühl hat, man hat es wirklich mit Vollidioten zu tun.
Weil dann einfach irgendein Quatsch dabei rauskommt und dann sagt man extra, nee, mach das nicht.
Und nur weil ich das erwähnt habe, macht es das natürlich dann extra.
Und all so eine Sachen, das macht mich wahnsinnig. Mir ist schon klar,
man kommt damit weit, aber ich bin ein Freund der Klarheit und ich möchte gerne
das mit richtigen Daten machen.
Ja, also ich bin ein Freund von handfesten Ergebnissen.
Also mein Aufruf nach da draußen wäre einfach, probiert es doch mal mit eurem
Namen und euren Projekten aus.
Ich vermute mal in unserer Hörerschaft gibt es ja etliche Leute,
die auch mal irgendwie so das eine oder andere angestoßen haben in ihrem Leben.
Guckt mal, was da so rauskommt bei Google im Vergleich zu LLMs.
Und gibt es irgendwelche sinnvollen Strategien, wie man sowas systematisch verbessern kann?
Und wenn alle sagen, es geht nur über Wikidata, dann meinetwegen,
aber vielleicht habe ich doch einfach blinde Flecken und übersehe ich was. was denn ich finde.
Es gibt ja diese schon seit vielen Jahren tobende Debatte um das Recht auf Vergessen.
Ich finde, wir haben auch ein Recht auf Erinnertwerden in der digitalen Sphäre.
Du möchtest, dass wir uns an dich erinnern?
Ja, ich bin öffentlicher Dienst. Und zwar korrekt.
Seit 40 Jahren. Ich habe irgendwann mal die Entscheidung getroffen,
ich werde nicht reich und berühmt, ich werde nicht Gründer und Startup sonst
was Typ, sondern ich mache es irgendwie für die Allgemeinheit und eine digitale Almende.
Aber dafür will man dann doch am Ende des Tages zumindest irgendwie mal ein
bisschen erinnert werden.
Das finde ich schon. Wenn die dann irgendwelche Osnabrücker-Profs stattdessen
raushauen als angebliche Gründer von StudIP, dann finde ich das scheiße.
Gut, also ich meine hier äußerst du dich ja jetzt seit einiger Zeit,
das steht ja dann auch in den Transkripten, das wird ja dann auch alles geharvestet.
Ich meine, wenn der Rest des Internets nur noch aus KI erzeugten Texten besteht,
ist klar, dass da nichts bei rauskommt.
Also ja, das ist so ein bisschen wie mit dem, das war hier bei Logbuch-Netzpolitik
in den Kommentaren, das haben wir gar nicht in der Sendung aufgegriffen.
Da ging es ja auch so um KI und was passiert, wenn die KI sich von sich selbst ernährt.
Und das war ja das Problem mit dem Rinderwahnsinn, dass die Rinder diese Krankheit
deshalb entwickelt haben, weil sie irgendwie ihr eigenes Fleisch zu essen bekommen
haben, also von ihrer eigenen Gattung.
Und so ein bisschen ist das glaube ich mit der KI auch. Auch.
Trotzdem, also hier kommen immer schöne Sachen raus. Hier kannst du ja mal hier
einen Absatz vorlesen, den Chat-GPT einfach nur auf die Frage,
wer ich so bin, gemacht hat. Und das kriegen wir schon hin, dass das für dich auch noch passiert.
Gut, da entblöden wir uns jetzt nicht, das jetzt in der Tat feierlich zu verlesen.
Tim Pridloff hat durch seine Arbeit wesentlich zur Verbreitung und Professionalisierung
von Podcasts in Deutschland beigetragen.
Seine Podcasts zeichnen sich durch hohe inhaltliche Qualität und ausführliche
Diskussionen aus, oft in Fort von langen Interviews oder Gesprächen mit Experten, nicht gegendert.
Er gilt als einer der einflussreichsten Akteure der deutschsprachigen Podcastszene
und wird für seine Fähigkeit geschätzt, komplexe Themen verständlich und unterhaltsam aufzubereiten.
Und jetzt hast du das so schön langsam vorgelesen, dann steht das auch korrekt
im Transkript und dann ernährt sich die Maschine auch wieder davon.
Super.
Selbstverstärkend.
Rinderwahnsinn. Man füttert der AI, was die AI ausgeschnitten hat.
So sieht's aus.
Oh mei. Gut.
Wir kriegen das schon hin.
Ja, man kann das jetzt irgendwie als irgendwie egozentrik oder sonst was irgendwo
ego-denken, aber das Problem haben ja da draußen immer Millionen von Menschen.
Die Lösung ist eben nicht, dass jeder von uns einen Wikipedia-Eintrag bekommt,
weil dann hängst du sofort in der nächsten Löschdiskussion drin.
Es muss doch for the rest of us irgendeine Modellierungsebene geben,
wo man sich an uns erinnert.
Dieses Problem würde ich gerne lösen.
Du willst erinnert werden, aber ohne Wikipedia-Artikel. Okay, genau.
Jeder soll erinnert werden können, der irgendwo dieser Gesellschaft etwas Nützliches beigetragen hat.
Okay, dann bin ich ja eh raus.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob ich etwas Nützliches beigetragen habe, aber gut.
Ich denke, wir sind hier einfach am Anfang. So und wir werden diese LLM-Technik
und was da jetzt noch sich daraus
entwickeln wird in Kombination mit Datenbanken, das werden wir sehen.
Spezialisierte Trainingsmodelle, die quasi mit dem LLM eigentlich nur ihr Interface
bekommen. LLMs mehr als Einstiegswolke und als Dialogschnittstelle,
um einfach ordentlich mit diesen Systemen reden zu können.
Im Prinzip genau das, was Apple mit seinem Apple Intelligence System angekündigt hat,
wo sie das quasi in die Mitte stellen und dann docken sie eben aufgabenspezifische
Sachen mit rein und warum soll man nicht auch so eine Personendatenbank wie
Wikidata es ist, dort anknüpfen können.
Da stehen natürlich dann keine Lobhudeleien drin. Die müssen dann schon noch von woanders kommen.
Jemand hat im Chat gepostet, dass der Podcast Papst laut ChatGPT ein gewisser Steffen Rühl ist.
Da steht jemand.
So, Tim, so nämlich. Jetzt haben wir dich. Da siehst du mal.
Wie bogus das alles ist. Das ist doch alles irgendwie Quatsch. Oh Mann, ey.
Naja. Und was damit ja so ein bisschen verbunden ist, da gab es neulich im ETP-Podcast
auch eine schöne Diskussion dazu,
dass Computer ja extrem schlecht da drin sind, mit dem Tod umzugehen.
Ich habe das jetzt ja auch schon
so, also ich habe so Leute in meinen Kontakten, die leben nicht mehr.
Menschen, die man mal kannte, mal getroffen hat, so und dann stellen die halt einfach.
Passiert und wird ja auch nicht weniger.
Und du willst jetzt einen Todeshaken haben?
Ja, es gibt dafür nichts. Also dieses Adressbuch frustriert mich sowieso auf
dem Macintosh enorm, weil es einfach ganz wichtige Dinge nicht enthält.
Todestag.
Obwohl, ich habe neulich festgestellt, dass man tatsächlich Geburtstage jetzt
auch ohne Jahr eintragen kann.
Ach.
Okay.
Das geht jetzt.
Okay, das ist mir tatsächlich neu. Das wäre in der Tat auch so eine Sache, die ich moniert hätte.
Aber man kann ja noch nicht mal sagen, ob die Leute leben.
Und man kann halt auch nicht sagen, ob das vielleicht Leute sind,
mit denen man nichts mehr zu tun haben will.
Du kannst sie rauslöschen.
Ja, aber gerade Leute, mit denen man nichts zu tun haben will,
die will man eigentlich nicht rauslöschen.
Die will man in der Blockliste haben.
Zum Beispiel, da will man irgendwie wissen, wer hinter der Telefonnummer steht etc.
pp. Also das sind ja alles Informationen, die habe ich ja angesammelt,
die will ich jetzt nicht löschen.
Und das kann ja auch sein, dass das nur ein temporärer Zustand ist.
Manchmal willst du Leute nicht mehr sehen und dann merkst du,
das ist doch nicht so schlimm.
Also, verstehst du, ich kann dem Computer,
der ja jetzt drauf und dran ist mit all seiner, Anführungsstriche,
Intelligenz, mir irgendwelche Vorschläge zu machen, woran ich erinnert werden möchte.
das Ding kommt auch mal hoch, hier deine Erinnerungen an diesen Tag.
Guck mal, wie schön es da war. Dann war das halt der totale Scheißtag.
Und das willst du halt irgendwie auch nicht. Ich meine, okay, bei mir.
Da schlummert jetzt nichts, wo ich jetzt total getriggert werde,
aber es kann natürlich auch alles mit Ereignissen zu tun haben,
die gar nicht so gut waren in deinem Leben.
Und das kann auch was mit Personen zu tun haben. Aber der Computer bietet mir
keine Möglichkeit, das zu modellieren.
Und gerade dieses Adressbuch, jetzt mal um konkret bei dem Beispiel zu bleiben,
die haben ja ernsthaft, du kannst ja da tatsächlich jetzt Pronouns eintragen.
Ja, also es gibt da tatsächlich die
Möglichkeit, in der Kontaktkarte Feld hinzufügen und dann gibt es da ein,
ja es ist ja auf Deutsch, wo ist denn das jetzt hier, wieso finde ich das jetzt gerade nicht?
Achso, jetzt finde ich das hier gerade nicht. Warum finde ich das jetzt nicht? Ah ja, hier Pronomen.
So, Pronomen kann ich jetzt irgendwie auswählen.
Da gibt es sogar ein eigenes User-Interface dafür, wo ich dann für jede Sprache
sagen kann, in welchem Fall ich welches Wort benutzen möchte für diese Person.
Mal ernsthaft. Würdest du sowas pflegen?
Aber was ich nicht Was ich nicht eintragen kann, ist, welches Geschlecht,
Geht nicht. Gibt's nicht. Liegt nicht vor.
Warum?
Naja gut, aber ist denn das nicht über die Pronomen abgedeckt?
Bei Pronomen kann ich nur Worte eingeben, die in irgendwelchen Fällen in einzelnen Sprachen kommen.
Ich werde doch jetzt nicht in 90 Sprachen eintragen, wie irgendwas heißt, was ich eh nicht weiß.
Und was soll mir das helfen?
Ja gut, aber ich meine, du sprichst ja auch keine 90 Sprachen.
Ich brauche da einfach einen Button irgendwie Mann-Frau um was anderes.
Also das reicht doch vollkommen.
Ja, aber sie haben sich wahrscheinlich gedacht, die Diskussion Mann-Frau-divers
oder sonst was kann man einfach umgehen, indem man sagt, es gibt für eine Person… Was.
Ist denn für eine Diskussion?
Du weißt doch, wie die Rechten in Amerika sind, die irgendwie denken,
dass die Liberals in Silicon Valley mal wieder Und.
Die sollten was dagegen haben, wenn man eintragen kann, dass jemand ein Mann
oder eine Frau oder was anderes ist?
Also ich glaube, dass es damals bei Facebook eine große Diskussion darum gab Warum gibt.
Es dieses Feld nicht schon seit 20 Jahren, bevor es diese Diskussion gab?
Das kann ich dir nicht sagen, vielleicht weil es auch niemand interessant fand.
Weil es keiner weiß. Ja, aber das ist nur mal für ein Adressbuch,
manchmal ganz praktisch, weil manchmal will ich halt explizit nach jemandem
suchen, wo mir da einfach der Name nicht einfällt.
Und dann wäre es ja schon mal ganz gut, wenn man einfach nach bestimmten Kriterien suchen kann.
Und da ist so was wie, ich weiß, dass es sich dabei um eine Frau handelt,
wirklich hilfreich, weil es schränkt schon mal weil die gesamte Suche auf gut
die Hälfte meiner Einträge eint.
Ich habe da eher das andere Problem, dass ich manchmal hier so Namen entdecke
und mir denke, wer war denn das? Bitte schön.
Naja, das hättest du ja dazu schreiben können.
Also diesen Modellierungsaspekt, da würde ich sagen, selbst wenn dort ein Feldgeschlecht
wäre, würde es von den Leuten ja aber auch nicht gepflegt.
Das heißt, ja gut, aber Pronomen zu pflegen ist derzeit zumindest in Social
Media Anwendungen total gängig.
Benutzt du das mal ehrlich? Benutzt du das jemals?
Ich sehe es täglich zigfach auf Mastodon, dass da he, her.
Ist, was auch immer. Das sehe ich auch, aber benutzt du das für irgendetwas?
Wenn ich irgendwie eine spezielle Anrede oder sowas brauche und mir aufgrund
des Namens nicht sicher bin, kann ich da nachgucken. Ja, warum denn nicht?
Tust du das?
Das tue ich schon, ja.
Wie oft?
Ich hätte jetzt gesagt täglich, weil das ist ja de facto das Geschlecht.
Also ich verstehe da jetzt deinen Punkt gar nicht.
Ja, aber das pflegst du doch hier nicht ein.
Wie gesagt, auf Social Media pflegen es die Leute selber.
Aber du pflegst es nicht in deiner eigenen Datenbank ein.
Nee, aber ich würde auch nicht das Geschlecht hier eintragen.
Weil wenn es mir egal ist, modelliere ich weder das eine noch das andere.
Wenn es mich interessiert, kann ich genauso gut die Pronomen hier nehmen auf
Deutsch. Hat auch denselben Effekt.
Ich finde die, die ist mit dem Geschlecht jetzt auch ein bisschen...
Kannst du das mal bitte mal ausprobieren, wie dieses User-Interface dafür ist?
Das ist faszinierend.
Das kannst du mir nicht erzählen, dass du das benutzt hast. Da hast du keinen
einzigen Eintrag in deinem Adresse.
Ich habe es gerade eben mal bei mir gemacht. Ich finde das eigentlich cool,
weil es im ersten Schritt wählst du die Sprache aus.
Da ist jetzt erstmal Deutsch vorausgewählt. So, dann werden dir vier Sätze vorgegeben.
So, ich kann das einfach jetzt nochmal eben editieren. So, wo haben wir das
denn jetzt hier? Also Pronomen.
So, personalisieren. So, Deutsch. Es gibt vier Sätze.
Gestern ging sie zum Park. Das ist ihr Schirm. Ich ging mit ihr. Ich sehe sie.
Das sind also die vier Fälle, in denen halt irgendwie Pronomen auftauchen.
Ja, aber warum muss ich denn das viermal eintragen?
Das reicht doch für Information Frau. Musst du ja eben nicht.
Wenn du in das allererste Feld, gestern ging sie zum Park, da tippe ich jetzt
also ein R, dann wird automagisch alle anderen Fälle korrekt mit ausgefüllt. Tada.
So, das heißt also, dann kannst du immer noch sagen, okay, irgendwie das gefällt
mir nicht, aber der Grundeintrag ist dann sofort korrekt.
Ja, aber warum muss ich das für jeden einzelnen Kontakt so pflegen und dann
auch für jede Sprache separat?
Das mit der Sprache ist ja optional. Ja, aber du wolltest das doch für jeden Kontakt pflegen.
Ja, aber es reicht einfach das Geschlecht. Ich meine, da gibt sich doch alles andere draus.
Ist doch bei dir da jetzt auch gerade. Du trägst das ein und ich meine,
hast du schon mal auf Social Media einen She-Him gesehen?
Eher selten, ja. Aber … Eher selten?
Du hast das noch nie gesehen. Es gibt kein Ski-Him. Warum sollte es ein Ski-Him
geben? Also ich verstehe … Nein.
Es gibt ein Them-Them.
Sorry, aber jetzt gehe ich mal echt komplett in alter weißer Mann-Modus.
So ein bisschen.
Ja, aber ich verstehe es nicht. Erklär es mir. Was soll das?
Ganz ehrlich, ich begreife diese ganzen Pronomen-Diskussionen überhaupt nicht.
Ich verstehe deinen Anwendungsfall nicht. Filterst du nach Geschlecht dein Adressbuch?
Was bist du denn für einer? Ja, selbstverständlich.
Wozu?
Weil das für mich ein Suchkriterium ist, habe ich doch gerade eben gesagt.
Wozu, war die Frage.
Ich versuche mich an eine Person zu erinnern. Dann will ich halt alle Kriterien
heranziehen und wenn ich mich daran erinnere, dass es sich um eine Frau handelt,
dann ist das für mich natürlich ein Suchkriterium,
was schon mal 50 Prozent im Schnitt aller Personen in meinem Adressbuch,
was nicht klein ist, ausschließt.
Natürlich ist das hilfreich.
Selbstverständlich will ich das eintragen. Es gibt auch Fälle,
da lade ich halt nur Männer, nur Frauen ein, weil es darum dann geht oder so.
Wie viele Leute hast du in deinem Adressbuch?
Das ist mal eine gute Frage.
3.709. neun.
So, und wenn es dann 1800 sind, hast du was gewonnen? Nicht wirklich.
Klar. Ich habe ja noch weitere Kriterien. Das ist ja nicht das Einzige, was ich vermisse.
Ich vermisse eine Menge, aber wenn es schon bei solchen grundlegenden Sachen,
also ich meine, diesen Pronomen Kaspar Kram, da kümmern sie sich drum.
Aber sowas Einfaches wie Geschlecht ist nicht drin.
Also ich meine, das kann ich doch selber entscheiden, ob ich das benutze oder nicht.
Also ich habe 452 Karten, aber ich muss sagen, es sind auch relativ viele Nicht-Personen dabei.
Das kommt noch dazu. Du kannst auch nicht sagen, ich mache nur einen Eintrag für eine Firma.
Doch.
Nein, naja, du hast dann aber trotzdem immer noch eine Person dabei.
Nee, aber die musst du nicht eintragen.
Die musst du nicht eintragen, aber du kannst es auch nicht wirklich trennen.
Du kannst nicht sagen, zeig mir jetzt mal nur alle Firmen an oder zeig mir Firmen nicht an.
Also diese ganze Suche ist Quatsch.
Nee, gut, dass die Suche nicht gut funktioniert, ist davon jetzt nochmal eine ganz eigene Thematik.
Steigen wir mal wieder ein, worum es hier eigentlich geht. Wir möchten gerne,
dass der Computer meine Welt versteht und ich möchte ihm vielleicht dabei helfen.
diese Welt zu verstehen. Und da sind natürlich dann solche Informationen ganz
hilfreich, zum Beispiel schon mal zu wissen, ist irgendjemand eine Frau?
Weil es kann ja sein, dass das wichtig ist, zum Beispiel um Pronomen abzuleiten.
Ich möchte aber jetzt nicht für jeden der einzelnen 3.709 Einträge hingehen
und irgendwelche Pronomen eintragen, die er dann sowieso automatisch berechnet,
wenn er das auch aus dem Geschlecht ableiten kann.
Was für mich eine Information wäre, die ich durchgehend pflegen würde.
Weil das einfach eine der grundlegenden Informationen ist, die ich überhaupt
über Personen haben kann.
Also ich weiß manchmal sehr wenig von Leuten.
Ich kenne ihre Telefonnummer und ich kenne das Geschlecht und das war es dann
und ich weiß noch nicht mal den Namen.
Schämlich.
Na ist ja manchmal so, irgendwelche Leute, ja hier melde ich mal bei dem Typen,
hier ist die Telefonnummer. Was trage ich da jetzt ein?
Der Typ, der.
Ja, der Typ, der. Aber dann könnte ich ja auch gleich Mail sagen.
Also um jetzt ein bisschen zu provozieren, aber auch nur ein bisschen.
Geschlecht ist in der Tat jetzt bei mir in meiner Kontaktverwaltung überhaupt
keine Dimension, die für mich irgendwie relevant ist.
Da könnte ich genauso gut Augenfarbe oder Haarfarbe modellieren.
Auf die käme ich aber auch nicht.
Das kann ja alles sein, aber du kannst mir doch nicht erzählen,
dass das deswegen für mich keine Option sein darf.
Also das ist doch wohl albern. Das ist doch wohl eine grundlegende Eigenschaft
von Menschen, dass sich bei Geschlecht irgendeine Aussage darüber schon machen lässt.
Die muss ja jetzt nicht binär Mann-Frau sein, sondern das kann ja auch…,
Was weiß ich, wie viele Einträge hat Facebook bei der Auswahl von Geschlecht? Elf?
Keine Ahnung, ich nix Facebook.
Ja gut, ich habe da jetzt auch nicht, bisher noch nicht so viele Leute,
wo sich das irgendwie ändert, ein paar, aber auch das ist dann eine interessante Information.
Ich kann sie aber hier nicht ablegen.
Gut.
So, und genauso, und da bin ich ja eigentlich hergekommen, kann ich auch nicht
sagen, diese Person ist, sagen wir mal, nicht in meinem sozialen Kreis oder diese Person ist tot.
Geht nicht.
Und ich finde, der Computer, wenn er jetzt anfängt, mir irgendwelche Dinge vorzuschlägen,
mir irgendwelche Erinnerungen heraus zu generieren und generell damit wirbt,
jetzt mit seiner Superintelligenz auf meine Bedürfnisse besser eingehen zu können,
beziehungsweise mich zu verstehen,
wenn ich jetzt anfange, mit diesem System zu reden, um irgendetwas zu möchten.
Zum Beispiel, gib mir mal die Telefonnummer von der Frau, die mich letzte Woche angerufen hat.
Also sowas wie Todestag könnte ich ja aber modellieren.
Aber das haben Sie ja versprochen, dass das die AI dann kann.
Was heißt, du kannst das modellieren?
Naja, ich kann ja ein eigenes Label für...
Ja, aber dann weiß der Computer nicht, was das Label bedeutet.
Du kannst da irgendeinen Quatsch reinschreiben, aber das ist am Ende nur ein String.
Der wird nicht lokalisiert und der weiß nicht, was es ist.
Klar, ich kann auch alles in die Notizen reinschreiben und das tue ich derzeit natürlich auch.
Wenn Leute gestorben sind, schreibe ich das da rein. Aber das ist halt nur ein Wort.
Und das ist halt kein Datenbankkriterium.
Du kannst noch ein anderes Datum eingeben. Also was du ja machen kannst, ist Geburtstag.
Okay, da kann ich jetzt mir den Kalender aussuchen.
Ich kenne tausend Wege, wie man das hacken kann, wie man da irgendwas irgendwie
schon irgendwie reinkriegt. Das ist aber nicht das, wovon ich rede.
Ich rede davon, der Computer macht es mir leicht, meine Welt ihm darzustellen.
So, damit ich mich da besser drin orientieren kann, aber vor allem,
dass der Computer sich auch darin besser orientieren kann.
Und da ist so eine Information, wie die Person lebt nicht mehr,
halte ich jetzt für nicht ganz unwichtig.
Weil da muss ich jetzt nicht eine E-Mail hinschicken, wenn ich sage,
schick eine Mail an alle, die folgenden Kriterien entsprechen.
Und ich kann aber nicht sagen, schick mal nur Leute so. Ich kann ja noch nicht
mal bei den E-Mail-Adressen, die ich da sage, angeben, welche ist die aktive
und welche habe ich jetzt nur da drin, damit ich noch alte E-Mails dieser Person zuordnen kann.
Und am laufenden Meter schicke ich irgendwelche E-Mails an alte E-Mail-Adressen,
die ich aber nur deshalb noch im Adressbuch drin habe, damit ich von der E-Mail-Adresse
auf diese Person schließen kann.
Das Problem kennt ihr doch sicherlich auch. Das selber mit Telefonnummern,
alte Telefonnummern, will man alles haben und man möchte auch gerne mal eine Priorität angeben.
Wo ist der Haken, wo ich sagen kann, verwende diese E-Mail-Adresse?
Gibt's nicht. Also es ist wirklich vorsinnflutlich und das bezieht sich jetzt
alles hier im Wesentlichen auf Mac oder auf iOS,
teilweise ist es bei iOS ja noch schlimmer, weil man da noch weniger Möglichkeiten
hat, irgendwas zu machen und ich finde es halt einfach unangemessen.
Also ich habe mir mit FileMaker vor ewigen Zeiten eine Adressdatenbank gemacht
und die war tausendmal fähiger als das,
was jetzt mir hier angeboten wird.
Aber ich benutze das halt, weil es natürlich in alles integriert ist.
Ja, gut. Also die erste Stufe wäre ja quasi halt, dass man komplett eigene Label
vergeben kann und dann halt mit eigenen Inhalten füllen, aber wie du schon sagst,
daraus lässt sich natürlich dann keine Programmatik irgendwie ableiten.
Genau, da muss halt eine Semantik dahinter sein. Und ich finde sowas Einfaches
wie Geschlecht und Todestag, sorry, aber da muss man jetzt nicht irgendwie noch
30 iOS-Releases und macOS-Releases abwarten, um auf diese geniale Idee zu kommen.
Mensch, ist euch eigentlich schon mal aufgefallen, dass Menschen auch sterben?
Ich meine, wie diskutieren die denn da überhaupt darüber? Das ist doch das Erste,
was ich vor 20 Jahren da reingemacht hätte, als sie dieses Adressbuch an den
Start gebracht haben. Nichts ist da.
Stattdessen irgendein Quatsch. Geht auch mit Spitznamen nicht ordentlich um.
Man kann zwar einen eintragen, aber du kannst ja auch nicht sagen,
was ist jetzt der Name, mit dem diese Person angesprochen wird.
Also Pronomen kann ich ja eintragen, aber einen Namen, mit dem die Person angeredet
werden möchte, das kann ich nicht eintragen.
Du kannst auch einen phonetischen Namen eintragen.
Ja, hurra. Was soll das?
Ja, das ist Ansprache.
Ja, das ist nur damit man weiß, wie man einen chinesischen Kontakt ausspricht.
Aber ich kann mir einfach selber mal vorlesen, wie das dann klingt.
Das wäre mal ganz gut. Also ich bin unzufrieden, falls euch das noch nicht aufgefallen ist.
Du meinst, da könnte Apple mal ein bisschen nachbessern?
Deutlich. Also ich finde, das ist unterirdisch schlecht und wirklich überhaupt nicht gut.
Abgesehen davon, von den technischen Problemen, die man hat.
In letzter Zeit ist es ein bisschen seltener geworden, aber wie oft hatte ich
alles doppelt und Duplikate finden ist auch eine totale Katastrophe.
Also da finde ich vieles nicht.
Ich merke gerade, wo ich mal hier ein bisschen durch meine Kontakte durchgehe,
dass ich das einfach exakt nie nutze.
Das heißt, ich bin immer in irgendwelchen Kommunikationszusammenhängen,
wo man etwas fortsetzt, was ohnehin mit den Personen schon am Laufen ist.
Ob das jetzt in Messagern ist, ob das per E-Mail ist, ob das auf irgendwelchen
Social-Media-Plattformen ist.
Also, dass ich für irgendein Szenario mein Adressbuch kontaktiere,
das passiert alle Monate mal.
Ja, weil es ja nichts kann. Aber ich benutze das halt die ganze Zeit.
Aber überall anders sind ja die aktuellen Informationen da, weil die Leute es selber pflegen.
Das ist halt der zentrale Unterschied. Ja, was heißt überall?
Du weißt ja nicht, was noch aktuell ist. Woher soll ich denn wissen,
welcher Social Media Account aktuell ist?
Na, wenn da jemand letzte Woche was gepostet hat, ist er mit einiger Sicherheit aktuell.
Ja, aber Leute haben auch verschiedenste Identitäten und ich brauche das ja
in irgendeiner Form zusammengefasst.
Warum sehe ich nicht alle meine E-Mails aus dem Adressbuch heraus,
wenn ich die Person anwähle? Warum sehe ich nicht, hier ist die ganze Kommunikation,
die du mit dieser Person hast.
Das sind die E-Mails, das sind die Messages, das ist über Signal gekommen,
das ist über Telegram gekommen.
Warum ist das nicht zusammengefasst? Warum kann dieses Adressbuch...
Datenschutz.
Ach, Datenschutz, fick. Die müssen einfach mal langsam mal anfangen,
mir diesen ganzen Datenwust aufzubereiten.
Ich muss die ganze Zeit diese mentale Transferleistung selber leisten.
Aber Tim, mit dem Angriff von Apple Intelligence wird das alles in Ordnung kommen.
Scheiß wird das kommen. Also ich meine, ich weiß ja, dass ich den Ruf habe,
so ein totaler Apple-Freund zu sein, aber ich kann euch sagen,
so geil ist das gar nicht.
Es ist nur so, dass die anderen Sachen, die sind halt noch schlimmer.
Aber mal ehrlich, also toll ist es null. Also das Adressbuch für die totale
Katastrophe und dieses ganze Zusammenfassen und mir Personen,
also überhaupt, dass das System mal eine Vorstellung hat von Entitäten.
Ja, das ist alles auch nur eine String- und Zahlensammlung. Aber dass hier wirklich
mal Personen abgebildet werden oder Kommunikationen zusammengefasst werden auf
eine interessante, intelligente Art und Weise. Wo ist der View,
der mir irgendwie die Kommunikation mit dir macht?
Wir haben zehn Kanäle, über die wir kommunizieren. Ich werde wahnsinnig.
Haben wir das jetzt in Discord geschrieben?
Haben wir jetzt gerade im Slack geredet? Haben wir Messages gemacht?
Über Signal geschrieben? War es eine E-Mail? Über welche E-Mail-Adresse?
So geht das doch die ganze Zeit. SMS, pipapo, permanent. Und was macht der Computer?
Muss selber mit klarkommen.
Toll. Und ich kann auch nicht mal die, guck mal, wenn du da,
ich werd verrückt, wenn du jetzt hier so einen Adresseintrag aufmachst,
was kann man im Jahre 2024 für Kontakte eintragen?
Da kann ich eintragen, Twitter, steht da, Twitter, find ich auch okay,
aber you know, Facebook, Flickr.
Was, echt?
Ja, das ist das Standard-Pop-Up-Menü.
Nichts gegen Flickr, aber.
Ja, LinkedIn, bist du angeschnallt, Myspace, Sina Weibo,
Tencent Weibo, Yelp und ich glaube die anderen habe ich dazu getragen.
Wo ist denn hier überhaupt?
Aber er weiß gar nichts darüber. Also er weiß bei Twitter, dass man da ein Ad
davor schreibt und wenn ich irgendwie das Profil, dann kann ich auf Tweets anzeigen
klicken und was macht er dann?
Dann startet er dieses bekloppte alte Twitter-Programm, was irgendwie nicht
mehr richtig funktioniert und eine totale Schande ist.
Und nichts ist geholfen dabei. Mit anderen Worten, sie vernachlässigen diesen
ganzen Bereich komplett.
Es gibt überhaupt nicht dieses Konzept von dieser User hat Accounts und er hat
hier irgendwie Profile und Programme können sich da nicht reinpluggen und können
sagen, hier, ich bin Dienst sowieso, blende das mal ein.
Aber ich kann eine Fax eintragen.
Also ich habe hier.
Aber das ist schon die Beta von 17. Zoom, Threema, Duolingo,
Slack, Telegram, Ivory und Signal.
Ich komme gerade auf diese Kategorie Social Media überhaupt gar nicht.
Ich habe hier nur Messenger bei mir.
Ich bin hier auf der Beta, ich glaube 15.1 ist das, was ich jetzt hier habe.
Nee, du musst Social Media hinzufügen.
Aber wo tu ich?
Achso, ich bin jetzt hier gerade bei IOS. Aber das ist egal.
Übrigens, ich habe hier in meinem Adressbuch beim Durchblättern gerade noch
den guten Freund Bobby Tables gefunden,
wo ich als Adresse zweimal eine SQL Injection mit einem Drop Table Users und
Drop Table User gemacht habe.
Das ist übrigens hier Interface-Design. Wenn ich mich jetzt ein Social-Media-Feld hinzufüge,
kann ich nicht ein abstraktes Social-Media-Feld hinzufügen, sondern ich kann
nur Twitter hinzufügen und kann dann in einem zweiten Schritt Twitter ersetzen
durch eine der anderen von dir eben schon feierlich verlesenen Sachen.
Also ja, das müffelt schon alles arg. Das ist einfach scheiße.
Es gibt da kein anderes Wort dafür. Also das ist der totale Fick.
Naja, du sagst Plus und dann gibt es da halt dieses Ding und dann kannst du
vorne... eigenen Dienst hinzufügen.
Es ist so propelig scheiße programmiert und es ist so dumm und blöd.
Ich finde da gar keine Worte dafür, wie schlecht das ist.
Ich schreibe in die Notizen immer noch ein.
An solchen kleinen Usability-Geschichten kann man bei Apple auch schon lange leiden.
Was mich zum Beispiel täglich nervt, was ich auf Windows in Outlook einfach
wirklich täglich mehrfach nutze, ist, ich schreibe eine E-Mail und da möchte
ich dranhängen als Dateianhang die letzte Datei, an der ich gewerkelt habe.
Mehr nicht. Krieg das mal unter macOS hin.
Ja, ist schon schwierig, überhaupt den letzten Ordner mal zu finden,
an dem du gerade was gemacht hast.
So, unter Outlook, Windows, ja, hast du da dein Datei-Icon, hast den Pfeil daneben
und hast die Litze, das sind deine letzten zehn bearbeiteten Dateien.
Und das ist immer korrekt. Das ist immer die PowerPoint-PDF,
die ich offen hatte, steht da in der richtigen Stelle. Was ist so schwierig, sowas da reinzunehmen?
Aber du hast doch, du hast doch benutzte Objekte.
Ja, diese benutzten Objekte. Da sind irgendwelche Images, die in irgendwelchen Caches verrotten.
Aber mit Sicherheit nicht die Datei, die ich gerade eben offen hatte und gespeichert
habe. Ich habe mir mal so ein, so ein Makro ist es nicht, ich weiß gar nicht,
was das, irgendeine Query mal zusammengebaut im Finder.
Wie habe ich das hier genannt?
Aktuell hieß es. Das hat eine Zeit lang funktioniert, bis Apple auch das irgendwie
zerbrochen hat. Warte, ich muss gleich mal gucken, wie waren denn Suchkriterien einblenden?
KDM Item Content Type Tree gleich Public Content war die Suche dafür.
Fragt mich nicht, warum, habe ich mir irgendwo mal aus dem Internet rausgeklaubt.
Und das hat eine Zeit lang, hat das wirklich am ehesten die zuletzt bearbeitetsten,
Dokumente mir angezeigt. Mittlerweile geht das aber auch nicht mehr.
Das hatte ich dann in der Seitenleiste und hat das Problem teilweise gelöst, aber jetzt nicht mehr.
Ja, was erlaube Apple?
Es gibt ja für die Variante von iOS 18.1, wo dann auch der ganze AI-Kram kommt,
gibt es ja schon eine Beta.
Da steht aber ganz deutlich dabei, nicht in China und in der EU.
Insofern habe ich mir gar nicht erst die Mühe gemacht, das mal runterzuladen. weil, ja.
Also ich habe jetzt gerade mal eine Weile nicht auf den Chat geschaut,
da gab es natürlich jetzt hier zu den Geschlechts- und Pronomen Diskussionen
noch den einen oder anderen Hinweis.
So,
ja, also klar, man kann so hintenrum sowas machen und es gibt hier,
oh, was ist das denn hier?
Das biologische Geschlecht und das soziale Geschlecht unterscheiden sich halt zuweilen mal. Okay.
Ja, aber das ist doch uninteressant. Es geht ja nur ums soziale Geschlecht.
Wieso?
Also worum es mir geht, ist doch meine Sache, worum es mir geht.
Ich will einfach Daten speichern, die ich für relevant halte und was für mich
relevant ist, muss ja nicht für alle anderen relevant sein.
Klar, wenn du jetzt ein Newsletter rausschickst, wo du einen Urologen empfiehlst, dann ist es, aber ja.
Es geht ja nicht immer um eine Mail zu verschicken und so weiter.
Und natürlich kann ich jetzt irgendwie mit diesen Pronomen das irgendwie hacken,
aber das ist halt nicht das, was ich meine.
Ich möchte gerne einfach, dass das System es einfach macht, Sachen zu erfassen.
Und da würde es ja schon mal reichen, dass man selber so Felder anlegen kann,
die einfach systemweit dann einfach existieren. Geht ja schon mal nicht.
Ja, da bricht dann natürlich früher oder später Chaos aus, weil dann hast du
halt Daten, die nicht, das sind halt, also ich meine, das kannst du halt auch
im Prinzip alles in Notizen eintragen.
Ja, aber dann kann ich nicht Values dafür angeben, die es haben kann und so weiter.
Klar, kannst du ja JSON reinschreiben.
Ja, ja, mit Freitext. Genau, JSON in Notizen reintragen und so.
Klar, ich kann das alles ignorieren.
Ja, aber was anderes ist ein eigenes Feld ja auch nicht. Also ich meine, das ist irgendwie...
Ich finde, die Computer haben sich uns anzupassen und nicht...
Da gebe ich dir natürlich recht,
aber eine bediebige Freifelder löst dein Problem wahrscheinlich nur sehr unzureichend.
Ja, natürlich löst es. Das ist ja die einzige Möglichkeit, die ich derzeit habe.
Wenn jemand tot ist, dann schreibe ich halt gestorben da rein.
Aber das ist dann halt keine wirklich gut suchbare Information und ich kann
auch nicht das irgendwie exkludieren und all diese ganzen Sachen.
Ich reg mich nur auf. So, haben wir noch Themen? Ich glaube nein. Nein.
Haben wir noch Aufreger.
Wir haben uns schon ganz schön viel aufgeregt jetzt hier diese Sendung.
Ja, ich habe nur noch zwei Kleinigkeiten, die ich irgendwie noch kurz erwähnen
wollte. Oder vielleicht drei.
Also erstens EcoFlow.
Ja, von denen ist meine Batterie, die ganz kleine.
Ja, genau. Hast du, glaube ich, schon mal erwähnt.
Letztes Mal sogar.
Letztes Mal sogar. Und von EcoFlow gibt es einen Solarhut.
Das Ding sieht so scheiße aus.
Naja, aber Sonnenhüte sind halt Sonnenhüte, aber ich finde die Idee einfach wirklich geil.
Also sie bezeichnen das hier als the dorkiest piece of headgear und damit haben
sie wahrscheinlich auch recht. Aber es ist natürlich absolut Festival-tauglich.
The dorkiest piece of headgear.
Ja, also du hast einen dicken fetten Sonnenhut mit Solarpanel drin und USB-C-Anschluss.
Das heißt, du kannst mit diesem Sonnenhut durch die Sonne latschen und nebenbei deinen Telefon laden.
Also ich habe mir das etwas genauer angeguckt.
Die Idee finde ich erstmal geil. Ich habe mich gefragt, was so mit der Temperaturentwicklung
ist, weil das ist halt erstmal ein Pech-Schwarzer-Hut.
Der hat aber so Gase.
Das heißt, so ein Sonnenhut hat ja neben Handy-Aufladen auch noch so eine Primärfunktion,
die irgendwie Schatten- und Kühlespenden irgendwie beinhalten sollte.
Da bin ich jetzt verhalten optimistisch.
Aber vielleicht haben sie sich darüber, also der hat so eine Mesh-Struktur,
der ist also jetzt nicht irgendwie kompakt.
Ganz cool fand ich, wie der sich zusammenfaltet, weil am Ende des Tages sind
da halt irgendwie wie viele Panels, acht oder sowas, drin verbaut und die faltet
man dann so ganz elaboriert zusammen und hat dann so eine Dreieckform am Ende,
die man also schon vernünftig irgendwie in den Rucksack reinkriegt.
Also man knüddelt das nicht, sondern man faltet die ganze Geschichte.
Und das ist jetzt so als ein Fashion Statement, sagen wir mal,
gewöhnungsbedürftig, weil der hat dann halt doch so Ecken durch diesen Faltmechanismus,
also kein runder Hut, sondern schon schon so ein Angeegter.
Dann hat er so ein etwas komisches Verhältnis von Krempe zu der Haube, die oben auf dem Kopf...
Schwierig. Ich dachte, du hast ja den gekauft und wir könnten den hier mal ausprobieren.
Sehe ich das richtig? Der hat keine eigene Batterie drin. Das heißt,
man muss tatsächlich, wie auf den Bildern, man hat diesen Hut auf und hat das
Kabel, das einem hinten den Rücken runterläuft.
Oder aber alles andere wäre gewichtstechnisch auch wieder doof.
Also wenn du dann da irgendwo noch so ein Akkupack irgendwie mit drin hast,
dann ist es glaube ich endgültig. Ja, aber ich will doch.
Also gerade so ein Hut, wenn ich den, ich bewege ja meinen Kopf und wenn du
dann hinten das Kabel ständig hast und es wundert mich nicht,
dass sie ihn direkt 50 Dollar runtergesetzt haben.
Also es kriegt auf jeden Fall Punkte für Pfiffigkeit.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es ein besonders belastbares Produkt darstellt,
aber da kann man auf jeden Fall dran arbeiten.
Der Gedanke, dass man diese ganze Sonne, die dann im Sommer auf einen draufknallt,
auch einfach mal gleich nutzt, den finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich will Sonnencreme mit Solarfunktion.
So, und dann wollte ich noch Whitescreen mit euch teilen, weil kann man vielleicht mal gebrauchen.
White Screen White Screen, also weißer Screen wie der Name schon sagt macht einen weißen Screen,
oder auch einen gelben oder einen orangenen oder einen Purple Screen falls man
halt mal irgendwie einen Screen braucht, der irgendwie eine bestimmte Farbe hat.
Blue Screen Blue Screen oder halt auch Prank Screens, also ein ein Screen of
Death oder mein Computer installiert gerade Updates.
Also du kannst halt hier so ein Fake-Update-Screen drauf machen,
falls du halt irgendwie...
Aber sowas gab es doch schon mal.
Bestimmt.
Da haben wir, glaube ich, vor zehn Jahren schon mal drüber geredet.
So jetzt konkret in der Ausführung habe ich das nicht in Erinnerung,
aber ich glaube, nach zehn Jahren kann man dann auch noch mal so einen Tipp
wiederholen, sollte das Webseiten zehn Jahre alt sein.
Ist ja aber, glaube ich, nicht. Aber wenn du halt irgendwie in der Situation
bist, dass Leute dich dazu zwingen wollen, jetzt irgendwas mit deinem Computer
zu machen und du musst irgendwie nachweislich,
demonstrieren, dass es gerade nicht geht, weil läuft gerade ein Update,
dann könntest du mit widescreen.online schon relativ schnell am Ziel sein.
Gibt es hier für Windows 11, 10, XP, Mac OS X, sogar Ubuntu und ja,
noch diverse andere Kleinigkeiten.
Ach, der DVD-Screen ist doch niedlich.
DVD?
Ja, da.
Ah, wo das DVD-Logo durchläuft. Oh Gott, die Zeiten.
Ja, okay. Mehr muss ich dazu nicht sagen.
Sehr schön, ja.
So, ich bin durch mit meinen Themen. Es sei denn, wir wollen hier noch über dieses Gerät reden.
Da kann ich aber noch nicht so sehr viel zu sagen. Das habe ich mir gerade besorgt.
Der geneigte Hörer darf rätseln, was für ein Gerät der Papst jetzt diesmal angeschafft hat.
Genau, der Gerät.
Es ist schwarz, hält sich in der Hand wie eine Pistole und sieht aus wie aus
einem Dorky 15er Jahre Shooter.
Genau. Ja, Ralf, hast du noch was?
Nee, ich habe nichts. Ich teste gerade hier schon ein Programm,
was angeblich mein letzte Dateien finden Problem lösen soll.
Werde ich mal testen und nächste Folge berichten. Default Folder X.
Achso, ja, der gute alte Default-Folder. Ja, der kann in der Tat ganz hilfreich sein.
Ist ein bisschen, war früher unter macOS deutlich besser integriert als bei
macOS 10, weil das so ein bisschen so ein Overlay hat und ich fand das ein bisschen
störend, aber ich habe das früher auf dem guten alten macOS,
habe ich Default-Folder immer benutzt,
und auf macOS 10 mache ich es nicht mehr. Aber vielleicht gebe ich dem nochmal eine Chance.
Boah, Apps, die ein X im Namen haben, um anzuzeigen, dass sie jetzt auch für
macOS X tauglich sind. Das war noch Zeit.
Ja, die Zeiten sind noch nicht ganz vorbei. Gut, wollen wir die Sendung beenden?
Ja, wir klappen zu.
Weil es ist heiß hier und wir kriegen heute die vier Stunden nicht voll.
So machen wir das.
Leute,
ihr wisst schon, was jetzt kommt. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Ich hoffe, ihr habt euch an den Rahns nicht so sehr gestört.
Und an den sonstigen Themen. Scheiß und Schimmel.
Aber wir hatten auch Erbauliches und Humanistisches. Genau.
Es ist auf jeden Fall viel Reinigendes dabei.
Es wurde Latein gesprochen.
Bis bald.
Tschüss.